And they think it's great.
Oh,
this is awesome.
We have greater Matt here.
I speed over live.
Yeah.
When they,
when I got the high speed Internet here that let you have high speed,
high speed Internet,
while you have the highest DSL you can get the highest DSL can suck it right as
I narrowed it really hurts me.
Like I'm just like,
oh,
this is not the product that I wanted to give out this week.
So the Internet is weak.
However the audio is the same and why you want to look at me so closely anyway?
You Bet.
Freaking bitch.
Um,
but it will all be fixed.
Well this is a work in progress we should do,
we should probably get a recorder so I could record a high quality version of
what the mixer is outputting the name.
Yeah.
And then we could upload like a,
almost like an HD version.
What do we have to do?
Just tell me.
Amazon inertia.
Okay.
What's Amazon?
The shit out of that.
Did your organ experience podcast is brought to you by ting?
Why?
What is Tim Bert Kreischer tings.
A cell phone service.
Yes.
It's cell phone service.
He used to sprint backbone.
And the way they have it set up is you don't have any contracts.
They have awesome phones.
If you use,
uh,
the URL,
rogan.ting.com you'll save yourself 50 bucks,
all of any other android devices.
And it's all from a non evil cell phone company.
That's the,
the,
the reason why we like what they're doing though,
the way they have it set up.
I mean Brian explained like what they did with,
with your uh,
your minutes.
Oh,
it's so cool man.
Like I've been using it for maybe two weeks now and it's pretty much,
you're using everything sprint like [inaudible] like do your voicemail,
it's sprint.
Like Hey,
welcome to spray.
And he put it in your pass code.
So like the network is solid.
It's fuck like I have you both at and t and sprint.
Well,
pretty much ting now and I always have service throughout Los Angeles.
I'll almost always full full bars and stuff.
So it's been,
the service has been great.
But the coolest thing is,
is that if you,
once you log into your account,
it shows you how much you've used.
So like,
like it said,
like [inaudible] seven minutes,
you know,
this,
uh,
week so far you've used 20 texts,
you've used this much data and so it tells you how much you've spent already.
So what I'm guessing,
I haven't done a full billing cycle yet,
but this one I'm guessing,
I'm guessing it just takes like if you're on a $50 a month plan,
say or $40 a month plan and you only use $12 of it,
then I guess it would just subtract it from your bill every month.
So it's really interesting.
But yeah,
it's,
it's very ethical.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
It seems like why doesn't every cell phone company do this?
It's like,
yeah,
it's creepy that they don't,
right.
It's really creepy.
Gross.
The idea is so fucking gross that you have to sign up and what's really going on
though folks,
and this is a,
in the interest of full disclosure,
what's really going on?
And so when you get a contract for a phone,
you see like an iPhone contract,
it'll say like x amount of dollars with a two year contract.
Well that over the two year contract you're paying off that phone.
The reason why it's only $299 as opposed to $699,
what are full retail would be,
that's sort of rolled into the bill.
Okay.
With,
with Ting,
they do not have that.
When you're paying for a device,
it's,
it's yours and you're getting it at,
you know,
it's,
that is exactly what it costs.
If you want to quit at anytime,
you don't owe them money.
So the reason why contracts are exists and they're hard to break besides that,
it's,
you know,
financially it's good for them to make it hard to break so that you could pay
off that phone.
They don't have that with Ting.
So with Ting,
um,
when you're,
when you're buying one of these phones,
that's what it costs.
It's 180 bucks.
That's what it costs.
I just remembered something.
The galaxy s three I have,
uh,
I,
I can't figure out certain things about it cause I'm so used to the iPhone and I
can't figure out how to turn off the notification.
Every time I get an email it goes like that.
So I'm like at the olive garden or something like that,
just walking around and selling it goes,
and it sounds so realistic that people are looking at me like,
did that guy just whistle at me?
One noise became like a universal sign for,
hey,
you look sexy.
Yeah.
How did that come out?
That's weird.
You know?
Tinging ting is embarrassing me though.
I think that at restaurants and public places with that,
that's the Android,
you got to figure out the android operating system.
I would think if anybody would've figured it out by now,
be you.
You're a fucking Dork.
Complicated is a really,
yeah,
it really is.
But I think it's one of those things,
once you figure it out,
you're like,
oh dude,
you're just,
you know,
it's just like any other operating stuff.
Yeah.
It seems like it was pretty easy.
I didn't really have any problems.
It's just like you could find the,
Huh,
I haven't spent it.
Yeah,
I'm not spending that time trying to turn off that fucking whistle.
Which one is that just changed my wife's cause it went and it was an obnoxious,
you'd be out to fucking eat and she was like,
I'm offended by people's songs except Limo drive is the best ones.
Horrible,
horrible,
top 40 pop love nonsense song and you're happy when it goes,
oh fuck.
Who was just at my house?
I think it was half.
Ron Has the worst song on his,
I think it might be half frons hit him singing.
Yeah,
fraud.
However,
I'm going to try to get half run in next week.
Yeah.
Anyway,
go to rogan.ting.com that's the name of the cell phone company and everything
else has explained there.
All the plans are explaining there and they,
like I said,
we had,
like we said,
rather they have the top of the line android phones,
including the the galaxy s three that Brian can't figure out.
And the note which gives me like full on screen envy.
Have you seen the note?
No,
it's fucking,
it's like a tablet phone.
It's pretty much like the iPads 70 like I just saw it last night.
I'm just looking at it.
I don't know if I have you tried to put it in your pocket?
Joe
wanted to run.
I want to steal it and run away.
I have a fucking boner for that phone.
We'd all start wearing old navy painter pants.
Let's go with purses.
Fuck it.
Fuck it Brock.
A fanny pack.
This is ridiculous.
I would love somebody fucking purses.
Men to more backpacks.
You were but haven't declared a backpacks.
I got this new one for travel channel.
This is essentially a purse.
I'm ready to get a flight in woman's bag there,
so
my bag that I carry my computer around and that might well be a purse at looking
back.
He got recently.
Yeah,
it was a curse.
That was a purse.
I got one.
I was trying to be interesting for a couple of weeks.
I just thought it would be cool to have like one made out of saddle leather told
phase.
Where else?
They're like a leather,
padded saddle of the,
you would smell the horse and feel good when you're carrying around.
Oh,
it's so stupid.
This no zippers.
I'm like,
where's this day?
But Oh my God,
I used to have to use a buckle.
That's so dumb.
I was going so far back in technology.
Looks like George Clooney who would also wear it as a hat.
It was so heavy to,
where's the hat?
It's just,
it looks like the style of like a Gq,
like cleaning Brad Pitt also own this nice leather boots unnecessarily.
Tevye to,
they're completely unnecessarily have it.
Like it was fucking heavy.
Like my regular computer bag.
It's pretty light.
Throw it on my shoulders.
It's like this thick ass leather fucking show.
What's the course?
I don't look at it.
Don't remember.
Hold on.
I'll look through my,
Amazon got a leather backpack when I first moved to New York,
so I thought it'd be like an artist and I put it over my shoulder and it would,
it could,
it was a leather strap and it could never stay on my shoulder would always slide
down my wrist.
Like you're saying,
you put it on one shoulder just from course,
of course.
Fucking horrible.
Whenever you trying too hard,
it fucking blows up in your face.
God dammit.
Oh,
I got to see what this Sacho Sacho but in the meanwhile we were also brought to
you
by on it and we were just talking about about bulletproof coffee before the
show.
We were talking about,
um,
there's a,
there's mold apparently on a lot of coffee and this is something that has to do
with how the coffee is taken care of once it's picked.
You know,
what,
uh,
in what environment it's stored.
I guess all that shit is really important.
I had never even heard about it until Dave Asprey came on the podcast and uh,
Dave Asprey blew my fucking mind and a lot of ways,
very,
very smart cat,
but um,
very knowledgeable when it comes to certain areas of nutrition that I was
completely ignorant on.
That make a lot of sense.
The bulletproof coffee sounds fucking awesome.
Sounds like you don't,
you're not hungry or we feel alert.
You're not jittery.
It's like,
it's like a speedy sort of
like all day buzz.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I've had friends who had compare it to Adderall.
I have never,
oh are you are I fucking love Adderall.
Adderall.
So my dad was on speed for awhile.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I think I might've told you this.
He was just eating speed.
He didn't know the doctor prescribed me cause he lose weight.
My Dad's is like losing weight.
He's like fucking pacing around hotel rooms,
pulling out pistols and put them on the table.
Like a speed freak.
Well they used to do that
man.
They used to give you a phen phen do you remember the fender?
The two?
The first fan was a,
I just research just cause my dad was on the second fence.
a serotonin booster.
So it was,
yeah,
it was like,
it was like a,
it was like Zoloft or something like that.
So you boosted your serotonin and the other one was speed.
They mixed two together.
Wow.
You're like a future person.
Oh my God.
That sounds awesome.
Happy how we all should be.
If we can maintain it.
That's what I'm saying,
right?
We've got to maintain it.
Dude.
[inaudible] hard to read line or shitty brains.
That's the real problem.
If we could just flood our brains with like opium and Mtma all day,
we would be so loving and care,
but we just cannot hang in that state and build buildings.
We just can't get a lot of shit done in that little things I'd have to do during
the day and I can't get through.
We got sidetracked to busy person,
but upgraded coffee is Dave Asprey's own personal bulletproof coffee.
Diane's birth.
And we started knowing this.
He sleep.
That's not colored version.
That is not it.
Fuck you.
Fuck your mother.
Leave me.
You're so silly.
You've had that up there for 10 minutes to people.
People watching.
They used to them like,
what the fuck is he doing?
Or they weren't singing.
Oh,
that's right.
Upgraded coffee is a Dave Asprey's coffee.
It's mold free.
And uh,
it's,
it's really interesting.
He had some really,
really interesting points of view that I really,
to be quite honest,
I haven't completely,
um,
looked into it 100%.
There's,
there's a lot of,
uh,
like I've always heard that like coffee was bad for like your adrenals,
but his,
his take on it is that a lot of what it is is this toxic mold that people are
drinking,
which is firing up your adrenals because your adrenals realize it's fighting off
a poison.
I don't know if he's right about that,
but it makes a lot of fucking sense.
I told you I heard it on dangerous grounds.
Guy was saying majority of like 80% of coffee has mold on it and they grow it
still great coffee,
but they already harvested.
They're not going to not sell it because it's there.
It's a crop harvesting coffee.
It's like fucking a Peruvian dude and his wife and his kids and he just gets up
barrel it takes it into the city,
sells it like he doesn't,
he's not going to get a fucking bit of mold on it.
Yeah,
they're just selling it.
If they can still sell it,
he's not going to be conscientious,
conscientious.
I don't think he's come down to his mind.
Moldy is shit,
you probably won't give me half price.
We have a bunch of other cool things at uh,
at [inaudible] dot com we have stuff for kids that we just started chewable
vitamin.
We have chewable Omega three Jelly Jelly candies,
so like gummy bear type thing or gummy worms and uh,
they actually have a fish oil in them.
They taste a little fishy.
I'm not gonna lie to you,
but my two year old does not mine.
My four year old almost fucking threw up on it,
but she hates everything.
But the two year old young them down man,
all the tastes.
That's the,
was a little bit of fishiness to them but it doesn't mind.
I like fishy.
I liked that it tastes,
but it's odd to have like fish and sugary taste,
but a,
they're super healthy and if you can get your kid to eat them,
I'm not guaranteeing you can [inaudible] you can't eat them.
They're the shit.
I got two for one for two in my house.
One of them loves it,
the other one can't be bothered.
We have but green vibrance.
It's a drink for kids.
It was great.
And we also have
killer bee honey.
This is some new shit that we got.
Why killer bee honey?
Because it's gangster.
There's nothing more gangster than Dank in the fucking honey from a bunch of
savage evil bees.
That's a fucking gangster ass job.
Killer bee honey keeper.
Yeah.
That guy was a beekeeper and you have to have a big deck to pull that job off.
Cheapos you have to be a bold motherfucker to try to keep all those sliding
monsters in line with is figuring out a way through your nets.
Get to you while you're in that stupid suit and just fucking one after the
other.
Fly right up your nose and staying your brain and then they sent up here and
that's when they start coming and you try to run,
jump in the pool.
I don't understand killer bees.
I guess there's like bees that we used to have that didn't,
that weren't as aggressive and that these killer bees are more aggressive.
It was,
I think they filled them out.
They're from Africa.
But do you remember like when everybody was afraid of bees,
like we know we can't make up her mind.
There was like a period in the 90s where everybody was terrified of killer bees
and you would Africanize killer bees.
So you picture these bees,
these big decks,
decks with wigs on and on and fucking yeah,
and like a Michael Jordan Jersey with a fucking machete.
Yeah.
And everybody was terrified of these Africanized killer beans.
And then it became,
everybody was terrified cause there's no bs.
My,
that's what's going on now there's a us to my backyard.
My wife and I went to go get rid of it cause of the girls.
And my wife's like,
no,
you can't do that.
Then I realized she planted fucking all the bushes around our house to attract
bees.
Your wife did on purpose.
Yeah.
She wants to be.
It's just crazy.
Well,
listen,
bees can sting you,
but they perform a great service as far as pollinating plants and stuff.
It's not crazy die after they sting you.
Oh,
the kind of country,
you know,
there's all kinds of animals.
Not only did they die,
when they sting you,
they die when they fuck when male honeybees.
Fuck their dicks explode.
Yeah.
The Dick dislodges until the woman and they bleed out.
That's nature telling you to go fuck yourself.
That's nature telling you that it does not like it.
It made a mistake.
This,
this be is just like,
we just threw a little bit too much aggression into this.
Be Crazy.
How is that even on the phone possible while every other animal can defend
itself,
like a B is the only animal that when it,
when it sinks into you once that's a wrap.
Yeah.
You'd never think you think they hear about that and they'd stop.
Nature didn't really like them that much.
Nature didn't give him a good design like s like a spider spider stings unit.
It's fine.
Be Fine.
The spider doesn't,
it doesn't bother the spider.
I mean that's what he's supposed to do.
Staying the fuck out of you hosting a couple of more times to,
that's,
that's these fighters do.
Bees are kind of like,
they're just trying to hold it together.
They're like Bobbi Brown.
Like Donald want to get too fucking crazy.
You think so?
Yeah.
Cause there's like if you're the we Fokker we fight and we're dead.
Just keep it on the DL.
Yeah,
you got to really walk a line man.
You got to balance on a fucking rope rope.
If you're a battle rope,
if you're a B,
we have battle ropes as well.
What a battle ropes.
Better ropes is first of all manly as fuck.
Okay.
And when you get your weight,
your workout in from hurling ropes around back and forth,
that's a mail man strength that you can use a tussle.
Okay.
You should sell slack lines too.
What's a slackline mother fucking great to throw up in my backyard for my kids.
What is it?
It's like a,
it's like a tie down.
You know there's,
there's crank crank,
crank tiedowns are like this.
It's a tie down a,
it's like a strap that you tie down on the truck.
You've seen her in the truck.
Okay.
Yeah.
And it's about like this wide,
two inches wide and it's yellow and it's just the strap and you strap the strap
to two trees and then let it hang off the ground like a foot.
And it,
it sways,
it's got like a swing and a bounce to it.
And I let my kids get up there and try to walk on it.
And they've gotten so fucking good at it that now they get on and they can like
move their body and swing.
I was like,
where does that pay off?
Well,
my wife takes my girls ice skating for the first time and everyone's got the old
lady walkers when they ice skate until the ice skate now with like an old lady
Walker.
Right.
So they don't fall.
Now my kids fucking threw that shit to the side,
started ice skating because they're fucking balances gangster.
Wow.
Fucking skiing.
If you type in like dudes slacklining it's,
and it's huge in Colorado.
Dude,
I got,
let me tell you something.
I am powerful Burke Christ and drop and fitness knowledge.
I'm fucking to paddle.
Boarding's hardy shit.
I've tried to paddle board like four or five times it every single time on PR
broke my foot last time.
Like he was,
it was when we shot that episode in La.
We went paddle boarding also.
Wow.
And,
and I fucking,
I ain't shit so hard.
Yeah.
Paddleboarding looks like it'd be difficult.
I'll tell you another funny,
I'm going to try that slack line thing though.
I gotta I gotta look that up.
But uh,
anyway,
on a.com go there,
buy some kettle bells and battle ropes,
all kinds of other things.
You dirty fucks,
fish gummies,
fish gummies and uh,
and that's it.
Use a codename Rogan and you'll save 10% off any and all supplements that
includes,
um,
uh,
Alpha brain and includes shroom tech sport,
which is a must.
If you work out,
you're,
you're fucking yourself if you don't use it.
It's true.
Tech Sports,
amazing for like really intense workouts were that you did two or kickboxing or
something.
There's like a noticeable difference when I don't take that.
So you take it before.
Yeah,
I take it about an hour before I work out.
I take medicine,
I take the,
the fucking new mood that really works.
Like that is one of those things where I was actually kind of shocked at how
fucking little work.
Well,
it's been proven that five HTP can boost your serotonin levels been proven.
So there's that.
And there's also,
the new mood has a l trip to fan,
which converts to five HCP.
So l trip to fan converts to five HTP converts and Serotonin and you're,
you know,
it's like the,
the idea is that it's a slow release.
A fact was fucking awesome.
So it's an effective blend of the,
you know,
the two different like mechanisms to get Serotonin,
but it's,
uh,
you know,
everybody should eat healthy.
And if you can take vitamins that can make you feel better,
why wouldn't you do it?
I don't understand why people,
I know that it feels good to eat shitty food and it
feels good to fuck off.
It doesn't anymore.
I lost 30 pounds and I'm fucking,
I,
anytime I eat shitty,
I feel sick.
I feel physically fucking ill.
I
like it.
I like cheeseburgers and shit.
I love cheese.
When she got to do,
you've got to earn that shit.
You gotta earn that Shit.
No,
that's what I think.
Even still,
my stomach gets fucked up.
I had a,
I had a cheeseburger the other day,
first cheeseburger and like in like four months.
What have you been in?
You've been going Vegan on me,
so no,
no.
I did the,
I did that clean program cleanse,
lost like lost like 20 pounds and then kept losing weight.
I got down to about two oh five right now.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
and that's amazing.
My blood pressure is perfect.
My Hell.
Like everything's fucking perfect.
That's fantastic dude.
[inaudible] but now they're like,
I go get like a cheeseburger like,
like because in their clean program you take everything out of your fucking
diet.
Like no cheese,
no booze,
no nothing,
no caffeine.
And then you start putting it in slowly and you realize what gets you sick man.
Fucking cheeseburgers make me sick to my stomach.
That's so ridiculous.
That goddamn delicious.
You sound like an American right now.
I don't know who the fuck is pulling your strings.
Puppet.
This is bullshit.
I'm down with cheeseburgers folks.
But I say you got to earn him.
That's what I say.
And the majority of your meals should be spent eating healthy,
nutrient rich and dense.
Just each Kale shakes all day.
Bitch are you want to be super healthy?
It doesn't taste the best,
but if you ate kale shakes all day,
you'd be healthy as fuck.
You'd be vibrant.
And there's a ton of protein and Kale too.
We make uh,
we we'd sell rather,
we do make a hemp force,
which is a,
um,
a hemp based protein,
but we also sell with the Blendtec blenders that are the best blenders for
making those kinds of like vegetable shakes.
It really makes it like super liquid.
I do it every day.
It's fucking fantastic for you.
I throw some Kale in there and Rog garlic and Roger
did yours by the way.
Yours tastes like shit.
My majors one time.
It's not fucking Ms. So aggresses yeah,
it's very aggressive.
It's not necessarily taste good.
It's to make you feel like a fucking viking and the ship works.
Go get yourself something days.
Just hands back on Joe.
Bad spin off the whole show.
I'm going to stay off a goat.
[inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n,
I t.
And again,
use a code name.
Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off.
All right,
you,
you fucking freaks the great bird crises here,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's time to get freaky.
Let's try five day Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Dude,
this is a conspiracy afoot.
You have to put the Rory Macdonald,
uh,
Joe Rogan podcast.
Check it out.
You got to put that back in there.
Oh,
because uh,
in not doing that as well.
There you go.
Well,
good experience Joe Rogan podcast.
He's just very disrespectful to remove a dude's call out.
I was just pushing the wrong button on the wrong thing to camera roll that dude.
Shout out if someone had asked me about it.
Like is it,
did I did that the last couple of years?
Currently I don't pay attention.
You know,
I,
I it's,
it's right now we've heard it so many times.
It's sort of like actually think we need somebody else to add to it.
So,
oh,
don't say that.
Yeah.
He can't request those though.
Dude,
I'm making a request,
request
request and planning mind when I do it,
it's gonna be on a big,
it's going to be like on Rachael Ray and I'm going to,
I'm going to make her say it on accident and I'm just going to get her to sign
it in.
I had a dream about her last night.
Why you love her,
Huh?
No,
I don't.
God Damn it.
I'm trying to do a long can start up the gates.
No,
I don't love.
I do love her.
I love her.
I love this woman that I love,
that aren't,
I'm not in love with them,
but I love him.
She's just really cool.
What's that?
Oh,
John out from the UFC is a woman who works for the UFC.
She's the nicest lady of all time.
I love the shit out of her.
Yeah.
I love Oprah.
I kind of love him.
Yeah,
you live.
How far would you fuck,
bro,
Bro?
No,
I don't love thinking about it.
Think about it.
Oh No,
hold on.
Nope,
let's back it up.
Like,
I fucked a dude if you left me in prison.
Let's be realistic.
I'll probably fuck over.
Yeah,
for sure.
But I would like me.
You're asking me
fucking ridiculous questions.
I can.
I used to have a whole bit about for as a hole in the wall in my house,
I think I would fuck it.
It was warm and I came home drunk and I stuck my finger in there and be like,
wow,
Jesus.
No,
I can't believe I fucked my house again.
It was like a stupid bed.
A little bit about fucking my house.
I'd fuck up,
bro.
Yeah.
Well I just love her.
I love what she does.
It sounds ridiculous,
but just every time I look at Oprah,
she's always promoting positivity.
Like every,
everything is positive.
Everything is.
Let's go to Africa and started school.
You know,
let's help these people.
Let's tell you how to eat right.
Let's tell you how to be healthier.
Let's tell you how to,
you know,
make your house more eco friendly.
It's like everything's positive.
She's such a positive person.
I bet she did improve.
She should improve your life a little bit.
It's like a weird thing with people.
It's like if you say that you like Oprah,
like someone will say like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like how would you like Oprah?
She was like this woman show or a bunch of fucking caddy wenches.
Sit around and talk nonsense.
How groovy man go on there.
And essentially uncle Tom it,
I wouldn't pretend to agree with her.
And she,
he
did you see the pan across the audience and uh,
when she does my favorite things episode and it stops on Joe,
just really excited.
She's always
struck
me as being a person who is like legitimately used all of our stardom in a good
way.
Yeah.
Like there's just no like crazy like stories of extravagance that you hear about
her,
you know,
like doing crazy things.
She's always like being positive and doing nice things like for someone is that
successful?
That's pretty fucking rare.
You know?
I think that's,
that's to be commended,
you know?
And if that makes me some sort of a girly man,
okay,
fine,
I'm to fucking girly man,
fuck her.
Or Ellen,
I don't think I'd like to fuck either one of them.
I respect those ladies.
I don't think that they need me inside of them.
If you had to choose one,
if I had to choose one or that,
that dude,
I found it,
I would have interview the both be
valid.
But you're each year it would be the one who's the end it the most.
The one who wanted to give it a shot,
you know,
I would do,
I would say,
listen,
the the,
the aliens are going to make us fuck.
Okay.
It would be like a star trek episode.
Remember where it wasn't that part of the crooked a fuck that green chick.
I don't know if they follow through with the photo.
Maybe I'm missing my plot lines off my mind.
My point is if you,
you know,
you were alone with them and said,
listen ladies,
the aliens have intervened.
So I got fuck one of you.
Okay.
To save the world,
we're gonna have to fuck.
So,
uh,
who's into it?
Who wants to give it a shot to let them pick?
Fuck yeah.
Whoever is the boy.
I'd go,
listen,
one of you is going to have to sacrifice.
Okay,
we're going to have to do this.
Yeah,
so whoever it is,
I'm fine with either one of you.
I definitely wouldn't Oprah.
I would want it to be the one who wants it the most.
I want to just see the curtain come down.
If Alan was like,
I've been thinking I'm more attracted to Ellen,
maybe I'm not lesbian.
What if she was thinking like Berta bds just fucked me correctly once I didn't
push her right back over the fence,
carry me to the bed and make sweet love to her.
That's what every guy believes right in the back of his mind.
Can't change someone's sexuality.
Every guy believes that lesbians are only lesbians because they ain't got up
pizza this week.
What I'm saying,
fuck.
I'd make him wear a wig and I would eat her out for like an hour and then fuck
the shit out of her and she would be like,
what the fuck?
She'd be like,
Jesus,
I live with two lesbians in New York for Awhile at that felt so much better.
Yeah.
Ellen don't get fucked.
It was be like,
oh my God,
I felt so much better.
What she wants is probably a man that behaves like a woman
and she can be the man.
Why do you think he bought Justin beaver?
That car?
I put Justin Bieber hit that shit.
Who bought that car?
Ellen bought Justin Bieber like this really expensive shiny robot car that's
shiny home.
The fifth one.
Yeah.
Ellen bought that for her after he fucked the shit out of your,
probably.
You think so?
Maybe so.
He's,
he's too young to know.
What the fuck did you do a as well.
He knows you've gotta be very careful if you try to break into the lesbian.
By the way,
if you're a lesbian right now and you're getting offended by this,
how dare you take yourself so seriously,
pussy and freak and you're yourself and you stop them there licking,
licking boxes and you think that I'm a Weirdo.
I love,
I love you.
Do whatever you want.
That's not my point.
My point is if you were going to try to talk a lesbian over from the dark side,
you have to be a man of experience.
I would have to say you have to be a strong man of some,
some accomplishments,
probably 20s at least a liberal lesbians for two years in New York.
And there was no,
that's something that you,
that was the signal they were sending out to you.
They were not in Shit in fucking you.
The only time that you saw them interact with men you around as well.
So you've tainted the,
the,
the tire experiments.
My study group was contaminated it.
Well you were in it.
Oh No,
he's fucking women.
They don't have nothing to do with it.
[inaudible] yeah,
cause you were with them 100 of the time that you were with them.
Yeah.
So you're all your database that you've drawn from their behavior was around,
you know,
but I think they were be there as well.
So you want to send any free signals of a fucking possible gang.
Bang.
You know,
you get them drunk and they're like,
whoa.
All right,
let's just try it for us.
Come on everybody together.
You were around and they were like,
we don't like guys at all.
If you get that,
get that.
Did you get that bird?
No deck at all or it's like,
oh okay.
Shit.
No,
they were there.
They were,
I dated one of them for awhile.
The defense rests tech.
Just what I just said.
You did it to him.
Bert turned them.
You turn them or you can do that.
If you,
if you're a shitty enough boyfriend,
you can't turn a check.
I have,
I uh,
I don't,
I don't know about that either.
Boy.
Maybe I'd,
maybe you can.
Cause you do see some of those women that are just like in their,
like late fifties and they're like,
they're just like,
I'm better with another woman.
I think that there's nothing wrong with the idea of loving somebody who you,
whoever you love,
if you love a man,
if you love a woman,
if they love you back and yeah,
whatever you guys like doing together,
I'm all for it.
100% but when you look at like why try to speculate like why a person goes gay
or while am person,
you know,
why a person to assist,
there's so many factors you have to take into consideration.
Who the fuck knows psychologically who the fuck knows physically what anybody
thinks or feels?
Who knows?
So it's so hard to like point in any individual one,
but I think that ultimately it would be a little easier in this culture for a
woman to like just give up on men and have and start having a relationship with
other women because it's sort of much more culturally accepted than if a man
just was like,
stop trying to get laid,
like really
straight,
but girls just won't fuck them.
But guys are always trying to fuck them.
And he's like,
all right,
come on.
Come on.
Come fuck me.
Somebody has got to fuck.
I'm fucking somebody.
It sounds fucking me.
I guess I'm gay now.
That's much rarer that a guy will never heard of a guy getting tapped out of it.
Yeah,
right.
But women do give up on men.
Like,
I've talked
to women and you,
you know,
you ask him like,
you know the,
I talked to him,
one who was gay and then she was straight and then she was gagging and uh,
and I was like,
well what happened?
Like what,
what like was it just you were changing like your body was changing?
She goes,
I just,
I gave up.
She was like,
just,
I when I was hanging out with girls,
like we could be cuddling together and you know,
and nobody would,
you know,
be angry at me or yell at me or hit me.
And it was just like,
it was warm and friendly.
There's never that feeling of violence.
Like some girls,
again,
a path loop and there'll be a brown,
a certain type of guy and then they'll find themselves like repeating that
pattern for some strange reason.
Like they're attracted to these guys that are like really abusive and mean to
them.
There can be abusive and lesbian relationships would,
that was one of the things that were the ones I love with.
They'd beat the shit out of each other.
It's so crazy.
Like they get fucked up and then something would pop off and next thing you,
someone would throw a punch and then I'd try to break it up.
So then,
cause I was there with my friends,
so I break it up and then they'd start fighting me.
So then you are,
I remember one time I had won,
I have won by like the,
by like the shirt and I was holding the door that I had thrown the other one in
and I wasn't letting them get at each other
when I was young.
When I was doing taekwondo,
there was this lady who was like a US national champion that trained out of our
gym and she was a lesbian and she was really aggressive and she would spar with
men and fucking light them up really?
And she was a black belt.
Have you sparred with many women?
Really good.
Very rarely.
And when you do [inaudible] Kim,
sorry,
excuse me,
I load,
I gotta load,
caught my throat load a flim ladies and gentlemen,
um,
when you spar with them,
you gotta be very careful.
You can't hit them hard and just beat the shit.
No,
not at all.
It's mostly move and just be defensive.
If you,
if you really hit them,
you have to really check your,
your,
your power and you have to be really nice.
Like I've never seen,
well I've seen guys like get a little too rough,
but I've never seen it like accepted where everyone says like,
you know,
the women have to fucking get in there and fucking footage.
Just
if you're sparring with a chicken,
you better be technical and just be real gentle with how you hit them.
Oh,
very diverse part of the chick I have,
you know,
if she's part of the right ones,
it's cool.
You know?
It's just like they have to trust you.
You have to trust them.
That's the whole thing about sparring.
The beautiful thing about Jujitsu is that you can go full blast.
That was this curious thing about Jujitsu.
No,
that's the most beautiful thing because you can't really do that.
And kickboxing,
see when you're in kickboxing,
if you go full blast,
you can,
you can do it every day if you want.
But that your brain is not going to fucking last.
It's just not,
it's not going to last and you will,
you will ruin your body before you ever get to a high skill proficiency.
Like there's this misconception that it'll make you tougher if you just put the
gloves on and just fucking whale at each other.
Yeah,
I mean in a certain sense,
yes,
it will make you less terrified of going to war because you go to a war every
day.
But in another sense it won't make you better at war.
Okay.
You know,
it's too violent.
It's too crazy.
It's too,
it's too dangerous.
The,
the best way to learn is to learn with someone who you know is not going to hit
you.
Like if you and I respond,
I would know that you wouldn't be a deck and you wouldn't hit me full blast and
I would never hit you full blast.
And so if we just sort of hit each other like that,
so when you move and you can catch you there and you're going fast,
you go fast.
But when you kick each other,
you'd go like that.
You just pull it back and just started stop at that and it hurts a little bit
but not bad.
And that's the way to spar because when you spot that way then you understand
timing and movement and you can do it much freer so you can absorb going to hold
off the shin.
Yes,
he pulled back and you absorb information much,
much better.
And then occasionally you spar hard and occasionally spar hard just to sort of
put it together,
just sort of make you short.
You can do it under pressure,
but the real power work is never done in sparring.
Power work should be done hitting the bag,
hitting the myths.
That's where you go full on full blast with sparring.
You just working timing and positioning.
That's for the most part.
That's why the guys that are really technical,
like the the ties a lot of times especially cause they fight a lot.
They don't spar that much.
Mostly what they're doing is like hitting the bag and hitting pads because these
motherfuckers might have a hundred fights plus,
you know,
so they don't,
they don't wear themselves out.
Bless you.
My child.
So,
um,
they're,
they're much more,
they're much more conservative with their bodies,
like as far as like how the abuse,
their bodies and training.
But uh,
a lot of American MMA camps,
they get this crazy idea that you're supposed to just fucking banging out all
the time.
And so they'll have these like full power sparring sessions.
That's what a lot of people used to do.
You know,
a lot of people who are a little bit ignorant as to like the effects on the
brain,
like the effects on it.
Got It.
Now you see that and you look at people and you're like,
wow,
they're going to have a tough time.
Like you look at like,
uh,
like Brett Farve or something like that.
And you're like,
so this happened to all those dudes?
Yeah.
What's the dude's name that was on the cover of sports illustrated recently?
He used to be the quarterback for the Chicago bears and he like,
yeah,
he,
she won't let him drive because he gets lost.
Yeah.
Like that's fucking terrifying.
And he was one of those like Brett Farve,
like rough and tumble,
like really put it out.
I'm quarterbacks,
I'm going to fucking bang heads if we need to bang heads.
Well,
Kudos to him for being honest about this too,
because he sounds fine.
Like when you talk to you,
when you hear him talking to interviews,
if he was in denial about all this,
then bring it up.
He sounds fine.
Like he was doing that.
I was those that,
I remember that dude's sports show.
He's got a sport go ball.
No,
some guy,
it's a radio show,
but it's also on TV going anyway.
It's not important.
Uh,
Dan Patrick.
Yes.
Thank you.
Dan.
Pat Powerful.
Dan Patrick [inaudible] who's doing Dan Patrick show.
And when he was talking to him,
he sounded like completely normal.
Like you,
you know,
he said,
well,
you know,
sometimes I'll,
and they were telling stories about like,
dude,
find him like in the kitchen not knowing where he's going,
how he got there.
It just be stuck,
you know?
And when I was a young kid and he was a superstar.
Oh he was a fucking monster.
He used to go to the golf courses in player played barefoot.
That's just remember that's the fucking celebrity that I remember.
Like when you have something fascinating like what do you
be barefoot?
Just he's eccentric and they would let him do that.
He was Jim fucking McMann.
Some guys play pool barefoot.
Really?
Yeah.
I just thought it was really weird.
But I bet back like a lot of what pools about is like about feeling the table
and feeling the floor.
Like yeah,
it's about feel.
So maybe plant barefoot would be good.
Like you know,
that's a big thing of majority can out now working at barefoot.
Yeah,
I am working out barefoot.
Uh,
they uh,
Steve Maxwell is a big proponent of this stuff and especially like doing
kettlebell workouts and stuff.
Don't drop it on your fucking foot.
Stupid.
I dropped a fucking,
I dropped
the dumbbell.
I'm doing,
uh,
I sometimes I'll do this quick like shoulders buys lats,
like just bang them out like 10 times 10,
right.
With weights.
And so I'm doing them and I put the weights up to rest.
I put them on the arm of my couch and I'm watching TV and all of a sudden I just
hear Jeff
and it right on the top of my foot and I was,
and it had a dent in it and I was like,
motherfucker,
I broke.
It just broke my foot.
And I got,
you know when you like when you cut your finger cutting onions and then the
second you cut it,
you're like,
I want to take that moment back.
Like I don't want that moment to happen.
You feel so stupid.
Yeah.
Do you ever recommended somebody cause you weren't paying attention to unless
your foot off the brake?
A cop.
Oh,
fucking cop.
I had to take shifts and I sneezed and hit a cop.
My God.
Oh no you didn't.
Yeah,
that's fucking state trooper.
Just pay him got out of his car like confused.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
here I got to mention this.
Finally,
Death Squad,
Ohio and death squads,
Scotland.
Your products have arrived.
These are,
uh,
this buck fast is an,
an is a payer apparently like a really dangerous shit for LSD.
You just taking this stuff from random fan fucking shit.
No,
I usually just open the top.
I just opened the top.
This easily could be laced but isn't a wine.
Everyone gives me a bottles and they always say with like the,
the like,
hey,
bring this back to to La and give it to Joe or do it in the future.
Don't do that shit.
Yeah.
Well it's too late.
We're already started drinking it,
but yeah.
Thank you gentlemen.
Whoever,
whoever purchased it and it's very kind.
All their names are written.
We appreciate it very much.
It's very cool.
Rock is one of the nicest things
about this podcast is a,
how many cool people,
uh,
we have met in how many cool people that it affected,
you know,
the the most,
I hate to use that word powerful again,
but that's the perfect place for it.
The most powerful messages that I get are all these people telling me that like
the podcast changed their life,
like all of a sudden became ambitious.
Like I lost a hundred.
How do you see that dude who lost a ton of weight?
He posted his pictures.
I lost
one man.
I listened to a couple and a couple together.
They,
they,
they each last more than 90 pounds and they came to one of my shows.
It's,
well,
it's like choked me up man.
It chokes me up right now.
I'm talking about it.
It's a,
it's opened a line of dialogue that is,
that is unlike Twitter or Facebook because you're having genuine conversations
with people that are listening and then they know a part of you and you forget
that you tell them that.
So like everyone knows your secrets,
they know everything about you almost.
And then for stand up it makes stand up even crazier because then you go to do
stand up and they're like,
Ooh,
tell the time that you peed on your girlfriend's dining room table.
And I'm like,
I thought a joke.
And they're like,
just tell it like they don't even care.
Like everyone's yelling.
Flying dildos now should make that a bit,
Hey Brian,
give me some of that.
Uh,
the Zions Chaz too.
Is there any more of that?
Yeah,
there is,
right.
Oh,
I just drink it on the rocks.
You guys got ice?
Uh,
yeah,
we have ice now,
so,
uh,
yeah,
it's been crazy.
You know,
it's so funny man.
Everyone that we've done these trips flip things with.
The majority of them are all dead squat fans.
I told you that one group,
one couple I took to Vegas,
I've found them in Denver.
They heard me the night before on your part,
the day before on your podcast mentioned.
And they come riding up on their bikes and they say,
they tell me this sweet story about how,
um,
how bite all
through Europe and they didn't have any entertainment so they just listened on
his iPhone to death squad and Joe Rogan podcasts.
And they're like,
they're like,
you know,
it's so funny you guys,
you guys basically traveled through Europe with us every night.
We listen to you guys in our tent.
And I was like,
wow.
And then they're like,
it's so crazy to be partying with you.
I will say this.
Everyone in Austin,
Texas,
I am looking for new trip flip contested shit.
Saturday this Saturday,
Saturday I might go down.
Why don't you got to do a set?
I talked to the club and told them you work at a in Austin a once a year,
but I haven't worked there yet because I always had to cancel.
I love that place.
I think I might go back and do a,
um,
a club because I just did a theater.
They're like,
I'm going to go back to club.
Yeah.
Just to,
I want to work on some new shit that's a fucking,
I want to go to their club.
I emailed them,
play,
emailed them and told them that I was gonna be down.
Shit can't come down,
but I don't know the protocol because I don't really know the club,
the comic headlining of like me going into,
Oh yes.
That's an issue with a lot of guys and I know that,
I'm not saying that I'm better than he is or anything,
but I know that I would,
I would offer to go last because I've never heard of him,
but I don't want to say that because then that's the correct thing is to offer
to go last because you don't want to interrupt.
The guys said you don't definitely don't want to trample on his material.
The worst thing in the world is if a guy does the guest set before you and he
does a bit that's like on one of the subjects that you're going to cover as
well.
So that makes your shit look for Dundon.
Yeah,
that's a that that is an issue with guest sets.
So I just didn't know.
So I was like,
maybe I'll just go down with my crew and get fucked up.
Especially if someone goes long.
That's,
that's,
I mean that's me.
I've seen that.
That's pretty gross with guests.
Etsy ever seen the guy like just come in that's 45 fucking minutes and then
brings up,
I mean,
I've seen that a couple of times with a big name guys and you're like,
wow,
I definitely have the tendency to go long,
but I,
I've never really done the guests that pretty much.
I don't know.
I'm sure I fucking,
but then again,
the guy could be a scrub and you know,
really fuck them,
make them,
make them fall.
You Jason Tebow always daily.
Shouldn't be on that stage anyway.
That's possible as well.
So yeah,
if you want to,
if you're in Austin and uh,
I guess I'll tweet if I get to do a show down there,
but if you're in Austin and you want to be on trip flip,
I have some pretty amazing and say you have your kids and you want to bring your
kids.
I just got notes from the network that I could take a whole fucking family
somewhere.
You don't want to take your fucking cancer,
the of Christ because you don't want to take your kids.
Me.
Oh wait.
I just realized that I would fucking suck.
Oh.
But so if you want any information to go to [inaudible] dot com and it's all on
my blog,
all the information of where to meet and all that Shit for Austin,
by the way,
that's a fantastic name,
Bert.
Bert,
So rememberable I tried to get burned.
It was for a dog.
This got a website dedicated to his fucking dog.
And I was like,
well yeah.
I was like,
well this dog and it looked old.
So I was like,
it'll die.
And then it died.
And then he sold the fucking site to somebody for how much I fucking know.
You know,
it was the hardest part is trying to name my podcast cause I was like going
through all the fucking names and I was like,
and I was like,
I was like,
you know,
and then you're like,
well,
whatever you name it,
it's going to,
everyone's going to say it sounds gay.
So is it this weekend?
This Saturday I'm to Austin is a dude
named John Ramsey.
Okay.
So John Ramsey,
we're just going to put this out there.
Just let the,
let the Twitter verse reach out to John Ramsey and say,
dude,
do you mind if Burke crisis 15 minutes after you on Saturday?
I hope you don't cut too.
I see him and he's like,
not cool.
Anonymous.
Took my email account.
They took [inaudible].
I just got hacked my email the other day.
That is possible.
All right,
John,
I'll see you.
I'll see you this week.
Yeah,
that's funny.
Yeah.
John Ramsey,
so that's,
that's the cat who's playing there this weekend.
Cap City Comedy Club.
This is a one of the best clubs,
like literally one of those legendary clubs.
There's a,
the,
they're all dead now.
The cap cities,
one of the last one standing.
I mean the last stop in Houston was a great fucking room.
Yeah.
Did you ever to before they moved it up before they moved it?
Yes.
The after they moved to the,
I never even went back.
I said that for the opening leap weekend there,
the grand opening weekend.
I took a girl there that I used to date and we fucked on the couch after the
show and she left a little spot there and last time I went there,
the spot was still on the couch.
Yeah,
I don't think they,
they watch screen room couches a lot.
He says,
let us scary stories.
Son
fucked her on the couch.
Wait,
where's anyone there?
She should go on the trip for that.
She lives back in Texas now.
You got,
what if their kids are annoying?
What's,
what if your kids are annoying,
you're on a trip with a bunch of people.
Travel channel's been fucking amazing this year.
This season is trip flip.
They,
I mean,
I can't really go into too much detail,
but I think they've,
I know for a fact they've said we really value you and we want you to have more
fun on the shows.
We won't,
don't want you to be so much in the box.
So now this season,
it's kind of like they said,
no rules.
You can do whatever you want.
I mean we,
we have had some,
we went to Australia and had some fucking insane crazy one day they just gave me
a car in the two travelers and they're like,
get lost.
See what you find.
Like travel channel's been really cool.
But then they were like,
I go,
I'd love to take more than two people.
Like just to break it up.
And they're like,
well fuck it.
Bring if you find something that's right,
take them.
There have been,
I saw the first cut of the two,
uh,
episodes of that or premiere episode and they're fucking hilarious.
They're so funny.
And travel channel saw them and they fucking love it there.
They're keeping them up.
That's awesome.
That should be,
the show should be exponentially better.
It was a great show last year,
but it'd be,
should be exponentially more and enjoying in 10.
Entertainable nevermind.
No,
fuck my brain.
My brain.
Just token smile.
A gasket you talked for too long and you red lines
that horrible sound.
The black smoke.
Oh Jesus.
That Jamison and this is energy.
It's pretty good.
Mix it with the fruit punch.
This tastes like roller skating rink.
Jason Roller Skating Rink and I need to look,
I know I work for the UFC and everything.
I'm,
I'm at suspect
what someone who works for the UFC promotes a UFC product.
But this shit is delicious.
It's probably terrible for your heart.
Oh all this.
Is there a lot of caffeine in this bitch?
Let me see.
Can you read that Brian?
I can't read that.
Say Caffeine.
It's got an,
well this one has zero calories,
which I totally dig.
I woke up last night thirsty as fuck and I went into the kitchen.
I was,
I had been drinking uh,
from the,
my flight before and then partying with this Guy Tom.
I went in and I grabbed what I thought was a box of xeno coconut water.
Yeah.
Talk to this egg whites.
Fucking dope.
Like ride whites.
I fucking wanted to throw up so bad.
You must have immediately the feeling of like how horrible that I didn't even
catch it until like,
cause you know,
coconut does have water,
does have like a weird taste.
[inaudible] second goal.
But like two weeks ago I had a beer with a raw egg in it,
so I,
and I didn't freak out over that.
So if I,
if I hadn't had that preparation of the beer in the raw egg,
it's called a brood.
They crack a port.
Take an egg.
Did you hear about that guy that died?
What?
There's a goat died in an egg.
He didn't contest?
No.
Yeah.
He like broke some world record in the,
the most eggs ever.
And then choked.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
Hold on.
I'm gonna pull it up.
I got a dude.
I got a dude named one more bite.
I retweeted shit all the time.
He ate a jar of peanut butter in 30 seconds.
Wow.
Whoa.
I,
and he's got the video.
He just hasn't fucking loaded it up yet.
Okay.
Here it is.
A man died after eating 28 eggs for a bet.
Wow.
For a bet.
Yeah.
It just took a,
took a bet.
This is energy has 13 milligrams per ounce is a 16 ounces.
That's math.
Yeah.
You lost me.
It seems like,
oh,
this is so crazy.
It seems like he swallowed the eggs whole.
Yeah.
Oh,
the shell and everything.
Yeah.
Oh,
what a fucking idiot.
Oh my God.
Well,
he lived in Tunisia.
You know how slowly and that is out there.
It's hard to get like some solid information on egg eating.
Yeah.
Apparently it seems like that's what this article is saying,
that that this guy is swallowed them.
This is their,
their Google searches.
He Ami Canadian eggs and he was like,
yes.
Yeah.
He was in um,
the Tunisian better fucking crazy.
It was a real story.
Wow.
This dude ate a whole entire Denny's entire hobbit menu in 20 minutes.
But like the whole habit minute,
he's not even one more bite.
Is this one more bite?
Yes.
This is my guy.
This guy can eat a jar of peanut butter in 30 seconds.
A jar of peanut butter.
One,
it looks like
what's wrong with us that we're impressed with that he might got.
He does that skill kit had been developed doing something else.
The focus that allows him to eat a pound of peanut peanut butter in in 30
seconds.
He could have been really good at the tight rope or something impressive.
The hobbit is this.
It's like I guarantee you that could have been great at writing books.
He needed to focus
on doing something.
This isn't something positive and not not eating.
I want to say this quick,
I'm speaking out of school and I know Adam was going to say that this isn't true
but,
or maybe he is or maybe isn't as what I heard Denny's offered Adam Richmond $1
million to eat 40 to about dollars worth of food.
Wait a minute.
Say that one more time.
Denny's.
I'm know I'm fucking this up cause I've heard this third hand now and Adam
hasn't told me this.
I'm just telling you what I heard.
Um,
he Denny's offered Adam $1 million.
If he could eat $40 worth of their food,
he had to order $40 and if he could eat it all,
it'd be awesome.
If you had googled this before we actually started talking about it.
Yeah.
Cause it could be total horseshit and Denny's could be a like,
you know what,
that fucking show promotes propaganda and they just make things up and that Bert
Kreischer guy,
that guy's a fucking asshole.
We're not planning on giving anybody for it.
Don't go call.
Put them on the spot.
What is the,
I'll Google it.
So Adam Richmond,
that's his name.
Richmond fisherman.
You know it's [inaudible],
right?
What's up Danny?
Way better than Dennis.
It might've been.
I hop,
I don't.
It may have been something like that.
Okay.
Let's see.
Denny's is just not,
see it.
Don't come up.
No.
Oh,
maybe I made it up.
You mother fuckers.
Fuck it.
No,
my memories are so crowded now.
I start telling people something that happened.
I'll know.
I think I dreamed out here at,
no,
you are right.
It's his name is Adam Rich man.
Yeah.
That's why I said I had a Richmond dog.
Wrong.
Yeah.
Comedian.
Okay,
here it is.
You were absolutely bright.
America's diner for more than 50 years has issued a special challenge to man
versus food star.
Adam Richmond,
daring him to prove that he can eat $40 worth of items at a Denny's all day,
every day,
$2 $4 $6 $8 value menu,
the throw down,
which was issue.
Why we,
why we echo and don't do it.
Shut your mouth,
shut your mouth and speak.
When spoken to was accompanied by a pledge from Denny's to tell Nate,
$12,468 in special Olympics.
I hate when they do that.
If you're going to make a bet,
let's make a fuck that.
Don't say you're doing it for cancer because you're not doing it for cancer.
You're doing it because,
do you want to pump yourself up?
Okay,
give the guy the fucking says Danny's everywhere you fuck.
I don't care how much you've given the fucking cancer research or you know,
whatever you doing,
children,
homeless,
whatever it is,
aids,
whatever it is.
It's about Danny's you sons of bitches.
If you want to make a bet,
make a fucking bat.
I would like to,
I would like to that televised.
I mean,
I'm not saying that Adam Richmond shouldn't give all of his money to charity
because I think he should.
Is that the way they were going to give him $1 million and
actually think you it?
I think you should at least keep 50% yeah,
it's just one meal is a 72 ounce
steak and an 11 pound pizza.
What the fuck?
Must it be like to like be known for being able to eat a fuck load,
but he that's fails to.
Oh sure.
Look,
you can fail this,
these competitive eaters.
We I these man,
this guy,
one more bite.
I'm telling you,
this guy's amazing.
He ate a fucking 16 pound burger.
Me and we tried to do it.
You couldn't fucking do it.
This guy ate it and fucking 30 but I was at the greatest overeating episodes in
the history of the world.
I was there when pat from Wanaka.
Oh,
drank 70 some odd shots.
I listened.
I only have that podcast with you and bill burr on my iPad mini or my eye,
my little shuffle and I,
and I was like going for a walk yesterday.
Marco island two days ago and I listened.
I was like,
Oh,
a bill.
And I go,
it's been so long.
I probably won't remember this one.
And then the second you guys talked about that,
I started gagging again.
I go,
I remember this one fucking cause I saw it online.
That baby bird shit.
That's the most disgusting thing I've ever fucking seen.
It was the most disgusting old reading someone.
I mean,
those names are etched in my head forever because of that moment.
Dude,
Pat Duffy,
who was that intern from the opening for folks who don't know what the fuck
we're talking about.
This is kind of a specialized little story.
Opie and Anthony had an Eggnog eggnog eating contest.
And who was there?
Ari was there.
Were you there Brian?
Yeah.
Uh,
no.
No,
you won't.
I was live streaming it from res phone somehow or something crazy like that.
Um,
Bill Burr was there anyway,
uh,
you know,
oop.
Anthony,
Jim Norton.
And they had this kid named Pat Duffy who was an intern and this kid was
completely crazy.
He would do anything.
He would brush his teeth with dog shit.
Like he was just down for something.
He did.
Yeah,
he did that.
He was completely crazy.
He's awesome.
Uh,
and uh,
when they,
the end of the eggnog contest was getting close.
The Guy who won is actually a diabetic Yaki wins every year.
You can't stop him.
He's a giant.
He's got his body fits more.
It's just like,
I met him one time,
he's checking he's,
he's crazy.
He's a great guy.
Very funny guy to actually,
by the way.
Very funny.
Yeah.
So he,
um,
he makes this,
uh,
you know,
makes the end,
whatever it was,
70 plus odd shots and,
and he's letting us know he's gonna hurl,
so don't go play it,
Brian.
Don't let,
he says he's going to hurt.
We don't need to see that I have this Id.
I say,
why not have it so that he throws up in path from when Mackey's mouth and then
someone says like a baby bird.
And that's when it became,
who said there's at Norton,
who was Gilbert Gilbert said on the pocket that it was build where you're right.
It was hilberry say like,
oh my God.
So it'd be like a fucking baby pad.
Look at him just like a fucking baby bird over there.
How can the burn person that's pretty solid right there looking at him.
He's like a fucking baby bed.
Um,
so pat from Menarche unleashes what can only be described as a cartoonish
hurling.
Like did you ever see that movie?
It's a movie stand by me.
Where where the kid ass fat ass wins the pie eating contest and hurls on
everybody
drinks.
Kennedy's projectile vomiting in a way that you never see in the real world.
Well this tops that drug packet knocking Rockies packed up.
You just sit there.
Well he just did.
He's an animal isn't the guy that got puked on his,
he's still alive this cause I don't think that guy threw up in his open mouth.
Okay.
And if you haven't seen it,
you haven't gone online.
It is one list.
I hosted fear factor for six and a half fucking years.
Okay.
Six years and a half years coming back.
And that was one of the craziest fucking things I've ever seen in person to let
a person do to them.
I was,
that was crazier than fear factor for sure.
Hey,
look,
get to
God.
That is
retirement.
How can it be taught?
That was me.
That's fucking crazy.
Timber Watch Anthony's compounds show.
That's how blood.
One of the reasons why Brian and I started doing this in the first place.
Fucking love.
That was another big influence.
By the way,
I hung out with him the other day and I've totally forgot about is Tom Green.
He,
we went to his house.
He's been doing this for a long time.
Yeah,
that's right.
So all of that though,
he don't need to start doing comedy so much.
Say he was just like,
you know,
he just got it out of his house and he sold his whole,
he had a whole studio,
kind of like this in the middle of his house.
It was pretty bad ass.
Really.
He didn't just have this,
he had servers.
He had his own servers,
so he had one of the rooms.
He had a bedroom in his house.
Had been completely converted to a server room.
You'd go in and she,
she's racks of machines,
so he had these fat cables.
I don't understand the technology behind it on,
but it was,
we got to get Tom Green back in the state.
He wants to come on.
I love the love coming up a lot.
Recently,
I'll tell you one of the things I,
I been watching before I released my special,
which is available right now,
Joe Rogan dinette it's only five.
I got it.
It's only $5 free.
How do you like that?
That new business paradigm.
Fucking awesome.
Yeah,
I like it.
It's all right.
You made it so there's no copyright protection.
So like if you have like a Roku,
like you could just throw it on an SD card and throw it right into the,
yeah.
You know,
I knew people were going to torrent it,
but that's okay Ma.
You know what a lot of people are gonna buy it.
It's all,
if you don't buy it,
you're just fucking lame.
I'm telling you,
man,
it's been the,
it's been super well received.
I really,
I'm very,
very happy.
I'm very happy with people's response to it and people liked it.
You know,
this is like this.
I think my fourth or fifth one of these fucking things,
it's,
it's hard to keep coming up and making sure that each one is better.
But I,
I watched this,
I didn't watch it for a long time.
I've watched it and I enjoyed it.
I didn't actually enjoy it and I was like,
that was funny.
Like,
I,
that's like what I wanted to do.
Like it worked out.
It's your documentary come out,
Bert.
That's so funny.
Oh No,
no,
it has not.
Uh,
I just talked about that on my podcast today.
The bone that dropped today on cast.
I talked about my,
um,
documentary there were talking about doing it the way you did your hour special.
Everybody has to do everybody to do it their way.
My question to,
you know,
do I need
to buy a fucking $25,000?
I'll say,
yeah,
don't worry.
I'll explain everything to you because I'll explain to you off the air,
the handle,
this whole,
the,
um,
the shift in business is fucking insane.
It's awesome.
This is so great.
This is what's crazy.
So,
so I do the podcast based off of,
you know,
a million conversations,
the least of which is Joey who I've been having coffee with every morning going
dog.
It doesn't fucking matter.
You just get up and talk.
And then,
and then I have my podcasting stuff in my man cave and Joey was at my house and
my dad was there and he was like,
well we'll fucking podcast.
This will be your first podcast.
So we tape it.
My Dad,
Joey Thompson,
Agora and my man cave.
And it's so crazy because then you like,
especially the way you've set up this business,
cause I've rethought it cause I got approached by people to be advertisers
because like,
uh,
you know,
people want to advertise on your site and I was like,
no,
I wanna I wanna fucking do like an on it.
I want my on it.
Like I don't want to just fucking sell the stack.
I'm wearing your shit right now.
You're fucking tee shirts.
[inaudible] level.
Brian,
I'm going next level.
What does that mean by the next level?
I'm buying a fucking vodka company.
Whoa.
Fuck yes.
Why not,
right.
Machine machine vodka.
Oh my God,
I love it.
Fucking Hartman says,
Ivan says,
we put it in all the Improv's.
Oh my God,
that's brilliant.
It's fun.
Oh my God.
That's how great is that?
It's so brilliant.
It's because of you is on it.
You said one night you go,
I don't know if you remember saying this.
It was one of those nights we were,
we were drinking whisky and doing the ice house and you were like,
uh,
this is,
I forget exact wording,
but something to the effect of this is the next level.
We're going to the next level.
This is uh,
something cool.
We're all part of this family.
Fuck the middleman fucked the middlemen.
You'd be the man.
And like I thought you're talking about on it.
And I was like,
yeah,
I want my own fucking product.
That's not what I'm saying.
And Company,
I was talking about doing podcasts.
He's like,
he's like,
I'm fucking starting the business.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Well that too.
Yeah,
you can do that too.
Like the,
the,
the honest thing came out of a knowing Aubrey went,
RB was working for the fleshlight.
It all brings in Austin,
right?
Yeah.
I want to kind of get down with that guys.
You've already still oh,
fuck yeah.
He's a great guy,
man.
He couldn't be a nicer guy.
And uh,
when,
when we met,
we instantly hit it off.
Brian and I met up with them at the w very trendy for the meeting to sponsor.
So weird.
It's very trendy,
very trendy,
um,
coolest motherfucker ever.
So,
uh,
their rooftop,
like one of those like [inaudible] and we're all sitting around like on this
windy day and they're like,
wow,
this is very nice because this is a pool in some like random girls walking
around.
This is what people do in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Fucking you love your servant too.
He's amazing.
He just walked up with a cup.
I was like a fucking given Malaysia.
Nice.
Jaylee.
Leave him alone.
Yeah.
You son of a bitch.
Um,
what the fuck did you do?
Tracking Aubrey.
Oh,
Robert.
so when we got started,
the idea was that there's,
there's gotta be a way to sell things online,
like an ideal like selling it,
like having a supplement company where you're doing it like that in the most
ethical way possible.
You know,
you're offering like a hundred percent money back guarantee in the first 90 days
if you don't,
you know,
if you don't agree that it's,
it's a good product,
you provide them with the best fucking shit that you buy and it's just,
it only works that way if you have everybody on board that's thinking exactly
the same way.
And that's I think really hard for a company to pull off.
So when a company like is like super ethical,
like you hear about like companies that are like really cool like Google,
apparently a Google is like super cool to work for.
Like everybody who works for Google was like super happy though
except except further there.
Fox,
com guys.
Oh yeah,
this dude's [inaudible].
I Guess Fox comes coming to United States.
They're going to open up a thing and they just moved production of the Mac Minis
to back to the United States.
So I guess Apple's trying to like bring their business back to the United
[inaudible].
Yeah.
You know what they're going to do?
Apple's gonna dig a fucking hole from China through the center of the earth and
pop it out in the middle and what they're going to go after.
Everybody has a fucking big grand opening day for the plant.
They saw,
you know,
job here.
Yeah,
no job for you.
Let's start off.
Sorry.
Mr Kentucky Man.
No job for you.
And just the population of Asians goes up by a half a million in the states and
they just funnel them up.
They could get 500 million Chinese people through the fucking center of the
earth before we even know what hit us.
Yes,
I did that movie.
It's fucking awesome.
Like iTunes had this thing where you're like,
you could buy looper early before it comes on Blu Ray for like 16 bucks.
I'm like,
you buy it.
And they immediately says,
oh,
available for rent tomorrow.
And you're like,
oh that was,
that was rude of you to sit and do that.
Like they don't say that the available for rent tomorrow thing.
Uh,
the renting never works out on iTunes for me cause I always forget I started on
a plane and I pass out halfway and then I can forget that I have it.
Plus your fancy extravagant man.
Why don't I just buy it?
You own it.
Put Full Leo,
my sister and my sister and looper on my phone,
like cared about it.
I'm going to sit alone in the bathroom by the wife is snoring.
Looper nice.
Amazing.
My sister is intelligent.
Yeah,
I loved it.
My sister is in charge of screeners for Fox studios.
Those,
this shit's online son.
Let me tell you something.
That's some motherfuckers out.
So she,
so the first day she gets her job as a first day,
this is like a year ago.
The first day she gets her job was the first day that everyone can get
screeners.
So everyone fucking inundates her like I need screeners.
I need screeners.
He shouldn't know the fuck to do.
She goes to her boss,
she goes,
what do I do?
He goes,
look,
send out a mass email,
cut and paste that to every email and say,
if you need screeners,
you talk.
Tim Jews
in the studios told up,
Tim's name is Jews,
him Jews and Kanye e w s and Kati said,
this world is real and I'll tell you to go fuck yourself.
[inaudible] simulations.
Cottey says to him,
how do you spell it?
And he says,
Jews,
just like the people.
J E w.
S that's ridiculous.
So Cottey my sister types of mass email cuts him with a,
if you need screeners,
go cold Jewish.
I have has to be,
imagine if it was,
well my blacks white,
so maybe not to name his first name.
Hates.
And our son hates so choose.
So she sends out the email to everyone.
Everyone gets it.
She sends maybe 300 emails out,
cuts and pastes that 300 the next day she gets to work and her inbox is slam
packed and she just starts cut and paste in the morning and she's realizing,
oh wait,
tell me,
these people already reached out to me and she reads the line.
There's only one,
Huh?
What the fuck?
Not Cool.
Spellcheck had changed Tim Jews to the judge,
you in the studio store and she sent out a line,
an email to everyone at Fox if you need screeners,
contacted the Jew in the studio.
Store.
Chew can take care of everything,
but you,
oh my God.
First Day of work,
oh my God,
that fucking,
I swear to God.
I thought my sister,
I saw when she came out to la,
she's going to do stand up.
She's so funny.
She's the funniest human being here and death squad.
She's the funniest human being she got.
She got into like being an agent and then went over to publicity at Fox and now
she's had she really happy.
She was funny as fuck and I thought I pissed on her one night when we were like,
you thought you piss.
I have never had that happen.
I've never had that happen.
Like I was incorrect.
She was in like fourth grade maybe.
And my parents were out of town when I came in and spend the night to take care
of her.
And I went out partying with my buddies and I have four and I got fucking
wasted.
And I wake up the next morning,
she's like school uniform and she's like,
do you need to take me to school?
Did you piss on yourself?
And I'm like,
no.
And she goes,
you smell like piss.
He smell like fucking piss.
And so how old is she?
She's like fucking fourth grade maybe.
I am.
She was definitely before fifth grade.
Fourth Grade,
probably nine 10 10 maybe 11 last station she had to be,
I had to be over 21 so she had to be 11 years old or 10 years old.
So,
so I go,
I,
I go,
I don't think so.
I'm just in boxers do.
I get in the car and my windows are down on my car.
I get in the car in my boxers.
I told him where to drop her off to school and as we take off it's cold.
I turned the heat up,
we can smell piss.
It's fucking very like there's piss everywhere.
And she's like,
is it you?
And she leans over to smell my chest and she goes,
oh my God,
it's either you piss on yourself.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
So we wrote ride to school with the windows down the whole time,
leaning our heads up the windows because it smells so much like this.
How bad is your piss smell?
It's so strong.
You know you've smelled piss like when a dog.
Yeah,
when it dries out.
And so we're sitting in a car and it's discussing it.
You piss on yourself?
I have no idea.
She thought I pissed on her cause she,
cause I was drunk and I did talk to her in the middle of the night to find out
what time shitty at it.
You got up for school.
So she remembers me coming into a room and I do have a history with pissing on
things.
So,
so she,
we,
I drop her off at school sites.
He gets out of the car,
I don't smell it.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
I pissed on my little sister.
Like I feel fucking horrible cause it's not in the car.
It'll smell it at all.
I drive home and the second I walk in the door,
the phone rings and it's her principal and I go,
hello.
And she goes,
I had a very interesting conversation with Mary Catherine.
And I was like,
yeah.
And she goes,
yes.
She said that someone had pissed on her butt or urinated on her,
but it was Thelma and I went,
oh thanks.
And I hung up.
Thelma was our dog and she had peed on her jacket.
But this woman didn't know that Thelma was a dog.
She just thought some Old Lady Fucking Pills,
dog pee on the jacket.
The jacket.
That's what the smell was put on the jacket.
Oh,
that's crazy.
So you w you blackout so hard.
You thought you might've piss on yourself back then.
I was fucking,
I was at Celeb that should we definitely wear this thing and she,
when she tells her story,
I'm fucking in stitches.
Oh my God.
Because she was a kid.
She was a little kid.
She used to come up to Florida state and party with me.
Like I'd,
my parents going through divorce so she'd come up and hang out at parties and
we'd send her around with a hat to get money for a new keg beer to come home
with like fucking $1,000.
Did you ever try to get into new stand up?
I,
I did.
And she had no interest.
How powerful is the limit in history?
Because I don't think of Piss.
When I think of the color yellow,
I think of lemons and I see piss every day.
I rarely see limits.
Just let it sit there
kind of point.
He's got a strong point.
I was a strong as the lens of good point because even bananas can't hold claim.
I mean if you see yellow or you think lemon,
lemon is,
it's true,
but you don't think pis with,
when you think true,
do you think great yellow can bananas can't claim yellow the way the lemons can.
Giraffes?
Nope.
Orange is claim oranges.
Oranges claimed the fog.
That's cause they named it doesn't matter if they're the only fruit that's a
fruit and a color.
An orange.
It's winnable.
Yeah.
I see it's orange.
What the fuck is it?
It's an orange.
What the fuck are you saying?
Did you imagine if someone said it's a purple,
you'd be like,
go fuck yourself.
It's not a purple if it is,
it's a plum.
Is that what it is?
It's a purple.
No,
it's a color and it's a fruit at the same time.
The only,
the only thing that I can think of,
first thing that comes to your mind when I say blue blueberries,
blueberries.
Blueberries.
Really?
Yeah.
I think cold coalitions,
blue,
blue are there.
It's a color.
And then there's berries.
It works,
you know,
but just to call something an orange,
that's the most ridiculous fucking name in the English language.
What did we run in now?
Sounds that we can make with our mouth.
There's a fucking fruit and it happens to be orange and you name it the f the
color.
How did they,
how did they,
now I don't know.
You've got me into a spiral.
How do they name these things?
They're idiots.
A bunch of monkeys.
Before they had TVs
and that was just the noise they made when they saw it made noises with the
mouse.
Do you think one guy stood at the fireplace and I was like orange.
Why did anybody ever agree to Swartz and Edgar?
How did anybody ever agree to that?
I mean,
this is essentially just an annoyance that you make with your mouth to
communicate a certain thing.
Well,
this is this guy.
What's his name?
Oh,
I'm no Swatson.
Come on.
That's not your fucking name.
Is it?
[inaudible] is it [inaudible] you know what's,
what's,
my name's Joe.
You know what's your name?
Bernet.
Burton.
Yeah.
No,
I'm most Watson that go,
that's too much.
You're asking for too many,
too many things for me to remember.
You're asking for too many.
You gotta look a little dots over your letters.
Stop.
Why are you being so weird with how the noise you make to represent yourself?
That is silly.
When they have the dots over the letters.
She doesn't make the letters sound like that.
Yeah.
Just stop it.
You silly bitch.
This in Mon fucking full refund.
What is your name?
The fuck is your noise.
What is your noise that I have to make the represents you and why is it so God
damn long?
You need a bitch?
Why is it so filled with confusion and silent letters?
You Fuck?
I was thinking,
I was watching that buffalo video you posted.
Oh,
that dude,
the white buffalo.
Yeah,
he,
he hit me back on Twitter.
It seems like a nice
the,
Oh,
the intro.
The open part was funny when he said,
the guy said his name was Eric and Eric and he set it up.
That was America.
Yeah.
He thought.
He said his name was America,
but then I started thinking,
do you think in the future people start naming their kids good names so that
they can get the website or the email like no one's name in there.
Cathy gave buddy.
He bloody names.
They're fucking kid and says,
listen honey,
I know it's a stupid fucking name,
but it's a good movie when you get the website or the email,
wait,
oh,
we get the website in the email.
I think rocket fuck face punch is a good name for our younger Rockland fuck face
punch will be an industry.
I'm thinking as long as we can show that we love our child,
it doesn't matter what his name is.
Rocky fuck face punch is a very happy baby.
Did you guys get the myspace invites like the invitations to be like try the new
my space invitation only.
You have to read files back from fucking that when your,
when your website put your fucking social network website falls off the map.
You don't come.
That seems,
that seems true,
isn't it?
Isn't it funny like they don't,
we don't allow them to come back.
They're sort of like rap careers because we're Americans.
We don't allow rappers,
rappers are not allowed to make comebacks.
Like a band,
like kiss made a gigantic comeback,
shit wrap and sugar on the sugar hill gang will not be returning any time.
Mapquest seems like it's still a cool name to this day.
Rappers are to make a comeback.
That's fucking crazy.
You're talking about,
and I'm not even listening to you anymore,
Joe.
Joe Rules not making a fucking come back.
I mean like maybe before it was jam master Jay,
they got merged.
Yeah.
It may be before he died.
Run DMC were so iconic.
They could,
they could have done a comeback,
you know ll cool.
Well just know because they never really fell off.
So you can't really say comeback.
He's always had a career.
But yeah,
it's
hard.
It's hard for a rapper to fall off like DMX.
The big DMX things.
Was that Christmas?
So fucking interesting.
Did you see that Christmas thing that he did?
No.
Oh,
Brian,
pull this up.
The DMX Rudolph,
the red nose reindeer is a big viral hit.
He,
uh,
somebody asked him if he knows,
the,
uh,
the words to Rudolph the red nose reindeer and could he rabbit will apparently
he does it all the time.
And so he busts out this impromptu Rudolph,
the red nose reindeer rap,
and it's like classic Dmx Ho.
Oh no,
she got it.
No,
you gotta you gotta you gotta hear it.
I'm not doing it.
Any justice pulled up.
Right.
It's really,
really,
it's really good.
[inaudible] tonight [inaudible] him on a table slapping his hands
and that genuine,
that's his fat chain best.
How can you get to your mantra on this podcast and can I come and
I won't fucking Dmx.
I'm obsessed with that guy.
But I love the fact that his changed his somebody chains around his neck.
That's a part of the rhythm.
Like it's,
he was part of the music youth crazy.
He is the purest air,
but it was awesome.
He is the purest of fucking representation of art incarnate.
He just can't help but be fucking that like he did you ever see his reality
show?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
he was fucking crazy.
He should do a whole Christmas album,
you know,
like that.
That would be bad ass.
That would sell like fucking crazy doctor.
He puts up money.
My rate idea.
Yeah.
That would be awesome.
All Christmas songs.
Maybe we should we sit over in necklaces and have her own sound
on too terrified to someone grabbed,
I hear him sing frosty the snowman.
Have a breakaway.
Yeah,
I'd have to have a breakaway and breakaway.
Breakaways everybody knows a breakaway.
They'd snatch it and run on me,
dude.
Dude,
Jane snatch him and sing old school shit.
Dude.
Chain snatching exists ties to this black dude photos follow I,
he bought me one time,
he beat me up,
but uh,
in high school and he would go to a party and just rip your chain off.
And he goes,
that's mine.
Donovan was his name was scary mother fucker.
That's annoying.
Chain stealing.
That was a big part of growing up.
You always hear about people stealing someone's checks.
Brian,
do you want to get killed?
Do not fuck with Dr Brian.
Just stop.
I blame Jamison.
Just stopped to know what his real name is.
Whatever you do,
just stop for one or two seconds before you do it and just breathe and just
think about what you're about to do and say,
is this a smart move?
Is this,
is this a good behavior decision?
I feel like I'm talking to my six year old.
Just a way to go,
damn,
this is a special type of person.
You got to,
got to get you a on this with the show.
I don't have to,
but I would love,
you know,
there's the guy that's on your message boards right now,
uh,
that,
that people are requesting Lotus,
uh,
Flying Lotus.
Yeah.
We used to talk to them back into my,
yeah,
I would love to.
Who's Flying Lotus?
He's a,
he's a brilliant man.
Yeah,
he's really interesting musician.
Yeah.
What did,
uh,
what did he do?
He didn't,
he wasn't,
yeah,
he was,
he was a part of the dance floor.
Dale or dance hall.
Dale.
Uh,
what's that in his music?
I don't
pull up.
Pull up dance hall.
Dale,
if you've ever seen is a dance floor Dale or dance hall.
it's Tim and Eric made this video and I've talked about it before,
so forgive me if you've heard this before,
but for the interest of my friend Bert Kreischer,
in my opinion,
the most brilliant use of the Internet that I have ever seen this video,
this video is,
it's hilarious.
It's real,
it's psychedelic,
it's all things.
It's just generic from the Austin showed it's a chick who's dancing and the guy
comes up to her and he's dancing and that,
that's the second one down.
The second of it is fine.
You don't see that Flying Lotus is music and that's what we said right here.
A real rapper.
I think it's somebody else.
No,
it says Flying Lotus though.
If maybe I said the wrong name too.
Oh,
I think you're thinking of Bassnectar.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
he's going to Lauren.
He'll,
he'll,
he wants to come on.
I was obsessed with that.
Where are you going with that?
And that may show you that.
I'll play that video tape,
but let's find out who the actual person was flying.
I think it is flying.
I think it's Flying Lotus.
But let's just play that video because I gotta,
I gotta show this to Burt cause it the people who haven't seen this,
it's called,
is it called dance hall?
Dale?
Dance floor.
Dale Dance Floor Dale.
And I think it's,
is it Tim and Eric and actually that wasn't the one year we were thinking of.
That was like a recent one I was thinking of.
Oh that was,
that was the remix by Flying Lotus.
But what's the one that it good?
Yeah,
that's it.
Because it keeps going.
They start fucking cut it off in the middle.
You know it stopped that,
that video that we were actually watching.
That was it.
Yeah.
That was the end of it.
Here we'll try a different one.
Oh,
you just supposed to got a wrong copy of it on youtube.
But the,
that is the video though.
But we don't,
we don't have to keep that I've ever seen in seminary.
You know what,
for the people that are listening to it though,
it's probably annoying.
Anyway,
there's,
have you ever seen Tim and Eric's a SNL,
uh,
intro?
Oh No,
I didn't say copied SNL or you know,
like the persons at the bar and looks down at the camera,
catches them fucking hilarious.
The person,
the bar looks at you,
you know,
like an SNL when the intro,
the intro Andy Samberg and he like,
oh yeah.
Gets out of a cabin stops and like those awkward,
they'd been doing it forever,
but it's,
they still do it.
Tim and Eric did a copy of it,
did a version of it,
but for them,
for their show,
it was fucking hilarious.
The,
um,
every now and then like if I can't be bothered to like watch a whole Saturday
night life,
I just can't do it.
Fucked me too many times,
too many times I watched it and I was like,
what is,
what did I just,
the good ones get put on Facebook.
Exactly,
exactly.
The Chinese workers at Foxconn with people that were complaining about the
iPhone.
If you seen that one,
oh,
you got to see it.
We played it on the podcast for otherwise we would bill Hader doing a puppet.
Who's have you seen as bill haters?
I think that's the name.
I'm not sure he's,
it's so fucking hard to do with some of the good ones,
man.
I'm trying to don king home runs and you're really appreciative of them putting
together entertainment that quickly,
week after week.
Like I go,
wow.
But then there are so many misses,
so many misses a little bit,
and then they'll assume,
imagine if you had to do an hour of new standup every week.
How much?
Let me tell you something,
Miss.
I think,
you know,
I run into so many comics that talk about the,
is that,
is that it's silly that the whole sketch,
right?
Something that yeah,
probably have to watch your life.
See what?
I don't know.
If I could do a show like Saturday night live,
you could do it,
but you couldn't do it.
Well.
Yeah,
that would be an awesome,
that would be an awesome reality show.
They ever wanted to make a a Saturday night live comeback.
Can you do Saturday night live and then like you take a bunch of comics and you
get thrown into having to do Saturday night live.
I think.
Swear to God.
Let's take this to the next level.
Try our own Saturday night live.
I liked,
I like podcasts acting.
I watched you this week and at the fucking zoo thing keeps on popping up.
Oh,
zookeeper.
Yeah.
That was fun.
I love doing that.
I'll do movies at Kevin till the cows come home.
He's a great guy.
Yeah,
but I don't do any other movies.
I just passed on a movie the other day.
I was happy.
I was happy to say no.
Yeah,
I mean for a lot of people want to be an actor.
that sounds like a good time.
But when I tell Brian Callen acts and every time we talk about acting,
he just talks to me about fucking trailers and waiting all day and pulling away
from his family and it's like,
I didn't want to do anybody else's shit
anymore.
But what if you,
you and Brian counted a good cop,
bad cop,
lethal weapon for the new age.
Why would you do that?
And they want to know what you want to do it.
You know what you want to do.
Brian Cowen led Brian [inaudible],
Brian County.
What?
Brian Cowen excels.
Is that being him?
Yeah.
That's why when we went hunting,
when that video comes out,
let me tell you something.
We're going to,
we're going to take a lot of that show and put it online because a lot of it was
way too ridiculous and over the top and you could never fucking show on on this
television show on the sportsman's network or the outdoor channel.
That too.
It's interesting.
It's fun.
Very.
Steve Reynolds,
Steven Rinella.
He's
very interesting.
But Callan was fucking hilarious.
Really.
I knew that if I went hunting with Callan,
first of all cigarettes,
Brian Cowen,
yeah,
guy.
Brian Cowan is a man,
you know,
I mean,
he's a fucking man.
You know,
there's,
there's certain dudes that I just trust with my life and Bryan County is one of
them.
You know,
like if,
uh,
if I,
you know,
if Brian Cowen called me in the middle of the night and had I had a drive to
Russia,
I would do it.
You know what I mean?
There's certain people that they like,
he's,
he's rock solid.
So I knew that we were going to go camping in Montana for five days.
We're going to go hiking and the fucking lockets 12 degrees outside and we were
looking for animals.
We're going to animals to murder.
A new calendar would be down.
And he didn't,
didn't discipline me.
Not One fucking step of the way.
Every step of the way.
He was there five 30 in the morning.
He was up like everybody else.
There was no complaining.
There's no bullshit.
He just went out and did his fucking thing.
That's rare,
dude.
That's rare that you could find a friend who's never hunted before and you go,
come on man,
let's do something crazy.
And he's not,
doesn't just do it,
but excels at it,
succeeds at it,
kills a deer and doesn't,
does the whole thing hikes for miles.
So I also,
did they go silent?
He didn't know Steve.
He didn't know anybody.
So Steve contacted you and you were like,
can I bring a buddy?
Yeah,
I knew like four.
I'm like for five days I'm like,
I'm bringing Callan,
we're gonna.
I have probably the most fun ever.
So for five days,
freezing our dicks off,
cracking jokes at each other back and forth.
So the video that we're not going to be able to show on TV is probably way
better.
The ravine calmer.
The thing that I've been talking about on the podcast before,
Brian County did a thing while we're gutting his dear.
Okay,
we're cutting this deer into pieces.
I just murdered it recently.
So we're standing over the carcass.
We're,
we,
we were kind of getting into pieces and Callan is doing this bit about a guy who
only comes in ravines
and I the boxes in there.
I don't you does anybody else have a lighted,
you get a lighter?
I'd stole his lighter but it's in that box.
Um,
and Callan is doing,
threw it behind it.
It's wrapped up in one of those coils.
Brian,
sorry.
Callen does this bit before the day.
Remind me to,
I'm getting one of those air cleaners so that people,
so many people fucking smoke in here.
We'll get it.
We need an air cleaner turn.
Can you turn the AC on?
Jane?
See made,
made it fun.
That helps to um,
any way caught calendars,
this fucking thing where he pretends that he has some talk show and the
interviews people on the talk show.
And then at the end of the talk show he talks about what they talked about while
he jerks off violently ravine.
No sense at all,
but it was so violent and ridiculous and hilarious for five days is like I was
treated to the Brian [inaudible] show,
you know,
for five days.
It just,
we just laugh our asses off.
April there's,
there's,
there's a few people that you know that you can do things with or that you can
like,
uh,
honest,
like call in favors television favors type things.
Yeah.
I did that to you.
I made you do the skeet shooting with me.
Yeah.
That was really,
this was really fun.
You know,
man,
it was,
thank you.
So I had to say thank you.
I know I said a million times my crew.
Do you know what you know,
my crew said they go,
uh,
um,
you know why we can tell he's a good guy.
And I said,
why?
And he goes,
because he took a picture,
he said goodbye and he said goodbye to all of us individually and shook all of
our hands that made,
you know,
like my sound Guy John sales is like,
that's the only types of men that look you in the eye and say thank you and say
goodbye.
Like that's a big fucking deal.
I was like,
I didn't like,
I never noticed that I was taking us.
All you have to do is be polite.
Yeah.
But people,
but people do so many celebrity Douche bags.
That's sad.
That's sad to me.
You know,
cause it's like the,
the bottom line about being a celebrity,
even a low level celebrity like I am,
I said it's,
it's a,
you're in a very privileged position.
Yeah.
So like you have this massive privilege and if you meet people,
like the best thing you can do is just be nice.
You know?
And,
and be happy that those people are trying to be nice to you,
you know?
But for a lot of people,
they look at it like it's some big crazy bother,
which look,
it can be if you're in a rush,
if you were on the rate of the airport,
you're proud of people.
If you're checking,
if you're checking it
because there was a girl at least,
or Mister Miss Leighton Meester what the fucks,
I don't know at least to Mister Mister,
these 30
well,
Arnold Schwarzenegger was ridiculous.
She was at my show in Marco Island this weekend.
She's apparently song gossip girls and stuff,
and so they,
they were,
everyone was like,
I got done the show and everyone's like,
can you believe she was at your show?
And I was like,
alright,
not man.
Not,
not that I didn't know who she was,
but I didn't know.
She was so fucking walked over to her and these people wanted a picture with
her.
And so I just assume I'll take pictures with everyone.
I go,
I'll walk you over.
I said,
hey.
She went,
hey,
the comedian.
No one's like,
yeah.
She goes,
uh,
we'd like to enjoy your show.
I go,
Hey,
can you take a picture of these people?
But I didn't realize she's not dressed up so she's not like picture ready to
like send out in public.
She's actually dressed down so no one recognizes her cause you super famous got
like fucking 2.5 million followers on Facebook,
on Facebook.
And so he fucking girls are savage.
She was in,
she was in a,
she's been been in movies and she released a country album.
Are you in love with her or Rachael Ray.
Okay.
You asked me about Oprah and Ellen,
her or Rachael Ray.
Which one would you,
which one would you take it to?
The,
to the fucking right.
If it's,
if it's,
um,
if I'm compromising the integrity of my marriage and it's going to go home.
Now you go into a time machine,
he'd go back and
the time to before you were ever married and bring the three before you and your
wife ever even met.
Okay.
You bring them to,
you hit it,
you make your pick and you hit it.
My brain went,
Rachel,
my bane.
Oh,
Rachel,
right away.
But,
but I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do I now,
but if I think about it,
I go,
she might hear that and I don't want her to feel walker.
Who's the other girl?
Leighton,
Leighton Meister,
whatever the file name is less gossip girl.
She can't lie.
I G H t two she's hottest fussing me brother.
She listened to me brother.
She can't cook.
She can cook.
She is too hot for you.
Let's be honest,
Rachel Ray is hot but hot.
You could get that Rachel Ray's,
I'm not saying that you could get that,
but
I'm saying in the,
in the universe that's in your wheelhouse.
Okay.
I'm not saying that the individual like me,
like making her like some sort of an object that you could acquire a capture.
I'm not demeaning or dehumanizing her in any way,
shape or form,
but I'm saying that it makes sense.
See if I saw you with Traci Lords,
I was like,
oh that poor mango and get his heart broke.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't want 25 I want someone who wants to own some shit together.
If yeah,
if I saw you with some like 25 year old 11 so in 25 year old just like
Ooh,
like you,
you can't breathe.
Mr Nexstar give a picture of her.
Brian,
that's not good for you.
Girl would have like a little 10 pounds extra weight,
which is not bad.
It's Kinda hot.
I want some compounds and grows 10 pounds overweight,
a little sloppy is more likely to stay in bed and fuck you then go to work,
you know,
that's Kinda hot,
you know like call in sick and just bang her all day.
That's all sloppy though.
Almost like I get turned on by my wife's flaws now.
Like I see them and I go convenient.
Yeah.
I've got this guy on
tomorrow.
Um,
doctor Doctor Chris Ryan,
he's the one who wrote that book sex at dawn.
It's all about like what sex was like,
don't let your girlfriend know that you had that book by the way.
Why?
I was dating a girl and she,
she saw that in my car cause I bought that book and it had in my car and I took
it to the airport and I put it in my back seat or something.
And she's like,
well what's this book?
And I'm like,
Oh,
it's my book.
And then she's like,
oh,
let me read it.
And so she read it.
She's like,
why do you have that book?
That's,
that's like,
I guess it's,
it breaks down how silly like marriages and relationships with guys and girls
doesn't it?
Well not necessarily.
Um,
what would it breaks down is the origins of monogamy and the um,
the sort of what we,
we,
it's,
we're going to be really interesting to talk to this guy because one of the
things is a,
about promiscuity and about the prevalence of promiscuity in men and women in
the early civilizations.
The way we look at it,
I think we look at it very differently because we look at promiscuity is in
fucking strangers.
Like the girl goes out and she gets drunk and she starts fucking strangers.
That didn't really used to happen back in the day.
Everybody stayed in the tribe and they might be a hundred people in the tribe
and the people who fuck people,
they fucked people in the tribe.
They found someone in the tribe to fuck the new,
knew that person intimately.
Everyone else in the tribe knew that person.
Intimately situation that we deal with today is very alien.
The idea that you can meet a person in a city and they're a total,
complete,
absolute stranger.
You know nothing about them and yet you can fuck them.
That didn't exist before.
The only way that existed before was when somebody came into your village is
just started raping and pillaging spree.
But before that you didn't really just meet people and fuck them.
There wasn't that many people.
It times,
you know,
you're dealing with tribes in the,
the,
the dawn of civilization or a people,
50 people,
whatever they are to go fuck other people's wives will have.
The idea is that the people were much more inclined to be orgiastic and they
were much more inclined to have multiple sexual partners.
But even though you would use the word promiscuous to describe that,
the word promiscuity has its roots in a word that means mixed.
So it doesn't mean it doesn't have the negative connotation that we
automatically associate to this society.
What it means is that these people had these sort of,
uh,
inter,
like they had relationships with several people,
the women did,
and the did.
And there's apparently a lot of so strong is the evidence to support this,
that Darwin even changed his take on it from his initial take.
Um,
and moved on to the,
uh,
the sort of acceptance that in the dawn of civilization that sexual promiscuity
was the norm.
So was does that mean that insecurity is something that we've kind of stumbled
upon?
It might not,
it doesn't necessarily mean anything.
I mean,
secure not,
might not be bad.
It's,
it's like it might be evolution.
The idea that we should continue along the same path as the people that were
around thousands and thousands of years ago,
to me seems rather silly.
It seems silly socially.
Uh,
it seems silly in terms of how we deal with war and how we deal with slavery and
I,
we deal with a lot of other issues like religion.
I mean,
there's a lot of other issues that we have evolved to a much higher level of
human communication and evolution and understanding of like how people operate.
So why wouldn't that be the case sexually as well?
You know,
and I think it probably is,
and I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not like a proponent of monogamy,
but I know some people that are monogamous that are happy.
Yeah,
I know what I'm saying.
The idea that it's impossible either.
The real issue for a lot of people is compatibility and you being someone who
has their own shit together because if you don't have your own shit together,
you're never going to find somebody else who has their own shit together.
And so you're just going to be fussed as fun.
They do.
They attract each other and they smash heads until they both get obliterated in
a fucking sea of meth.
It's crazy how easily you can point out a mess.
You can go on a fucking person is a mess,
but you can't,
like you can't point it out to them.
You can't,
like I've tried,
I've tried to be like,
listen,
this is what's going on.
Well,
your mindset has to be in a place where you can see in your mindset has to be in
a place where you're willing to accept information and you have the idea in your
head,
you're focused on the idea of progress and moving forward.
And that really is as simple as your consciousness directing the thoughts.
But it's hard to get on a tight group like that.
And that is one of the things that I've been most proud of about this podcast is
the ability to affect people in a positive way.
Just because they can sort of pick up on the way that the guests will think or
the,
you know,
we've had some brilliant people on this podcast and you can pick up the way they
think and communicate and
the ideas that they espouse and the uh,
the approach they have to life,
you know,
whether you know,
and a number of,
I take it to the next level and I'll say this as I came to this podcast is a fan
of the podcast.
Like I was listening to it and enjoying it and then started doing it.
And then so then like,
so these,
both these bottles desk got Ohio and death squad,
Scotland,
these desks squads gotten guys,
they just texted me or tweeted me and said,
if you're in Scotland,
we'd love to have a drink with you.
And always shooting.
And I was like,
well,
I just wrapped up sitting by a bar,
told them where I was.
They showed up.
What if they brought a bag and tape and the saw
fertilizer.
So rogue instance maybe wouldn't have giant gay guy wearing a leather mask.
Invert.
No.
So,
but it's so funny because we ended up um,
you had just done a podcast with God.
Bob Bobcat Goldthwait.
Yes.
And we ended up sitting down having a beer was talking about that podcast cause
we'd all listen to it and it was like there was no like there were twice or
three times maybe they were like I can't believe I'm going to be with the
machine.
But there was no that it was us talking about your podcast.
It was us talking about like those dudes technique,
tech mad technique,
the black Jesus Christ.
That was such a fucking great podcast.
I would have never heard of them in my entire life.
They were the two dudes,
Gi Joe,
Dj Gi Joe and a Suede Suede is the bat the battle rapper.
Right dude,
I fucking obsessed with him cause he's guys were so cool.
Like hung with us due to mortal technique brought me some food that his
grandmother made some delicious food.
It was so,
it smelled so good man.
Immune like in a pot and everything.
Like they left a tray of food.
Grandmother,
Maine.
Those are so cool man.
How come?
Do you know what I'm doing?
I'm going to get busy.
A lot of people have been saying to get Vinnie paths.
We're going to get mini pads.
Oh,
you and he's in town when he's in town.
He's going to do it.
That of turned me onto that Vinny paths guy to another one.
He invited me over to his grandmother's house where his mother's house to cook a
spaghetti.
He's these silly.
Yes,
he affiliates are cool.
I got to have that guy come to my show and I'm going to invite you over there.
Mom's house for some spaghetti.
That's a cool motherfucker.
Yeah,
I've fucked Vinnie pads.
It's awesome.
And his album had come out to his album hadn't come out yet,
I think when you tweeted it or something or the new album.
So man,
I tweeted about a video.
Oh,
there was a video that I tweeted that was just fucking bad.
I preordered his album because of that.
I love that.
He's fucking great.
Yeah.
He's a box cutter.
Baby bath,
kind of patsy.
Patsy,
his nickname.
I'll watched the rap battle online last night.
Lux and Calico cheese steaks is the Brian,
pull that up.
It's,
it's cheese takes his,
the video.
It's on youtube.
Yeah,
it's called cheese steaks.
Vinnie pads.
Cheese steaks.
That's a great fucking salt.
That's all.
I got addicted.
I play take fucking video like 2030 if you go there right now,
you'll probably see a hundred thousand fucking hits that have like a,
yeah,
it's,
oh,
it's over a million man.
You serious?
Yeah.
Why you think he makes for that?
I don't know dude,
but I'm telling you the last I looked at it,
it was like,
I think it was,
I want to,
I don't remember.
Maybe I was incorrect,
but I don't think it was nowhere near a million.
I thought it was like in the hundreds of thousands.
Is it great.
Gritty as fuck.
That's him.
And he's a Muslim big,
big boxing fan.
Yeah.
I think he,
I think I like it.
I read is I kind of like a spiral on him.
So his Brody from homeland,
he's driving in his city,
bobbing his head.
Where have we seen this before?
He's got a gun.
No rappers have good sniper,
but now he's got his own necklace that makes it a little jingle of as he has his
own sound for this song.
I liked that.
Halfway through the video you can tell that he shaves his hair back to a
straight line cause it's,
they didn't cut it perfect or it's right there.
I think you haven't cut it yet.
I love his lyrics.
How did my sister used to put her fucking lines in her eyebrows and my mom used
to looks like Jeff Ross a little bit.
No,
he does kind of looks like Jeff.
Ron.
No,
he does sort of out.
Wait,
look,
there's a moment.
There's a moment where he looks like
it does look like Jim Rohn.
He looks like Patton Oswald [inaudible] rapper.
Oh my God.
He's got so much like you said,
by the way,
mad respect to Patton.
Oswald got love.
Patton Oswald.
Well,
did you see that?
What do you just showed that guy flying through the air that's in the
ballplayer,
dude,
if you're going to be famous in a city,
best city to be famous in Tokyo,
I love Philly.
If you're going to be,
if you're going to own a city and lock it down,
you don't want to do in New York.
Everyone's gotten New York.
Jaycee's got New York.
Damn.
I've got New Orleans.
Talk to you about Philly.
We got New York.
What are you living in?
A fucking MTV music video.
Burton.
Burton soap.
Disconnected.
Very bursty.
Ultimate target.
Target consumer.
Like they fucking didn't get him.
They can target him.
Oh,
fucking suck.
One's got Philly locked out.
Jaycee's got New York.
Fuck they talking about is Jz and every restaurant at the same time.
No one has a goddamn city locked down.
Bernie,
I sure as hell.
He's got too many people.
That's a preposterous state,
man.
All right,
let's name a town Iowa.
Okay.
Who's got Iowa silver?
Vandelay silver,
right?
What the fuck are you in Brazil?
You would show on his arm broke
wrong.
What's the guy that let us arm get Tim Silvia.
Tim Sylvia.
That's what I meant.
This from Maine.
He's nicknames the maniac.
Oh,
I thought he was from,
she lives in Sun fight guys,
which today he's a huge a hunting fan.
Yeah.
He lives in Iowa now.
When you go to penguins,
he'd showed up at the shows.
Yeah,
he moved there for a,
the military fighting systems camp was a big camp in the early two thousands I
mean it's one of the,
one of the biggest camps ever,
and pat military had
a place in Bettendorf by,
whether it's from Matthews,
came out of Robbie Lawler camp full of killers.
And when Tim Sylvia was the heavyweight champion,
you know,
that's when,
he was at its peak when he,
when he knocked out Rico Rodriguez to win the title.
Tim Silvia,
man.
A lot of people sleep on that.
But there was a point in time where Tim ScaleIO Sylvia was a scary,
scary mother was,
you know,
he hasn't shown that form and a long time,
but look,
this is a tough business.
It's tough on your body and his,
yeah,
his,
he's still like I was,
I always thought that.
I was like,
it was a fucking gangster.
He moved to let his arm get broken.
Well,
he didn't want to let us,
I'm getting broken.
He just didn't want a tap.
That's fun.
We want to keep going.
And he might not have known that his arm was broken when you're so filled up
with adrenaline when you're in a fight.
But,
but Tim Silvia,
he would've tried to hit him with the left hand.
Tim Sylvia does not have like a lot of physical gifts.
You know,
he was the heavyweight champion physically.
Like,
he's not like unbelievably talented.
Like there's certain guys like,
you know Melvin Manhoef is Melvin Manhoef is this incredible Dutch kickboxer and
he's so frightening,
man.
He's so,
he won.
He had a fight this weekend.
He won with a one knee to the body.
Kayo and the first round over this guy,
Dennis Kang,
who's like a serious guy.
Brian,
pull that shit up.
Pull up dream 18 Dennis Kang,
Melvin Manhoef is one of the scariest.
I don't have that.
I don't have that DNA.
So swole,
we went to,
he's only like five 10 but he's like 205 pounds and he looks like a Goddamn
Superhero.
He looks like the hulk.
If it was a telco,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Kenneth Cole.
Like Macy's.
No.
Just look up pride.
18 we wouldn't.
Melvin just look up the word Melvin.
You know how to spell that right.
Okay,
Sweetie.
We went to do 10th planet.
Me and Joey and we were going to,
we didn't even do 10 planet.
We were going to learn Jujitsu.
Where was this?
I told you about this.
Hold on a second.
Watch this fight because this fight does not take long.
This is Dennis Kang.
Dennis Kang is a
pretty high level.
Melvin.
Yeah.
Wait till you see this guy's body.
It's shifts to retard it did,
did,
did he just a muscle.
He's a giant black muscle and he can't wait to fuck you up.
Right?
The legend shamrock and he fights heavyweights.
He's fighting one 85 in this fight,
but this guy fights heavyweights all the time.
I do is way bigger than fighting one 85 right now.
Yeah,
he's fucking crazy.
He's really fun to watch.
Fight.
I mean he's lost before he'd,
Robbie Lawler knocked him out.
A lot of guys have submitted him,
but if,
if you stand and swing with this guy,
he is a fucking destroyer.
Watch this shape.
They get into like a little firefight.
Dennis Kang lands first and he starts going on after him.
His candy canes going after hangs.
Try it like this is a big win for canyon.
If he can get this motherfucker,
but now sweat.
This name gets the clench.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's some scary shit.
That dude's got some hour.
Look at this body.
Fucking,
oh,
what is the last guy you want to fucking your ex girlfriend
when you go over the house and you'd go to pick up your fucking keys.
You left him there and you got in.
That guy's in his underwear walking around your house and you're like,
oh,
this is Melvin [inaudible].
Hey Man,
I've watched you fight before.
Big Fan man.
Big Fan.
Hey,
you want me to make you something to eat before you leave?
I have my girlfriend,
a good guy.
I know he'll take care of Melvin.
Joey and I joined.
I went to 10th Joey and I talk to Eddie Bravo.
I talked to Eddie Bravo seeing went to the Tab gym downtown La to 10th planet
and on Burbank.
Oh,
that's a long time ago.
Yeah,
it's,
did they move?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Tell us about your really understand the tap out Jim and downtown La.
It's a much better spots.
Huge,
huge,
huge spot parking.
I called up,
I talked to you last time I talked to you about going to Jujitsu and you're
like,
help get rid of anxiety when you know when you go head to head with another
dude,
it really kind of levels you out and you get relaxed.
End of the day.
Definitely relaxes you.
Yeah.
That's a lot of stress.
So I reach out to Eddie Bravo,
I think I called Brian Or said something to Brian and Brian Goes,
call Eddie.
And so I texted Eddie and he just called me and I was in my man cave drinking a
bottle of wine and he's like,
what are you looking for?
I was like,
I don't know.
I want like,
I want to be able to like,
I want to be able to tap someone out.
He goes,
I can get you tap motherfuckers out within a year.
I go,
really?
He goes,
done.
meet me at 10 planets.
So we go,
I meet him up at 10th Planet,
talk to him and he goes,
he was looking at camp like whatever it is,
they're like,
everyone's there trains with him.
It's fucking savage.
So he's like,
why don't I get you up to speed?
You've never wrestled.
You never let anything you need to get up speed.
So he gets Edgar,
this Guy Edgar to give me.
Then I bring them to Joey and Joey was like,
I want to fucking do it too.
So then Edgar,
me and Joey and then fucking Dunkin's like I want to be in Noah's case.
Now we're starting to fight club in my backyard.
Cause Edgar's like,
I'll get the maths,
we'll do it in your backyard.
But then,
then very quickly I realized you do like get black eyes and you do get broken
noses.
Rainwear yeah.
And,
and I was like,
I was like,
I'm on TV.
I can't,
like I can't just show her fucking NOCI listen,
I had two black eyes.
I did fear factor.
Brilliant product and makeup person.
Yeah.
Fucking pussy joke.
When I did the UFC,
I didn't even put makeup on.
I just left it on.
I had black eyes during the whole broadcast.
I was like,
I'm doing a fucking show.
We're dude,
get the fuck beat out of them and you want to put makeup over my black eye.
Eddie Bravo is fucking cool dude.
He's cool as fuck.
Like I that.
It's podcasts now too.
Yeah.
It's called Eddie Bravo radio.
And if you believe in chem trails like he believes in chem trails.
That's the show for you.
The picture,
the picture,
the picture we took after we went to the shooting range has it chem trail in
between us.
Oh and by the way,
the last one I'm told,
I think it's number three,
Eddie Bravo told the infamous stinky polisci stinky feet away,
which is one of the greatest stories in the history of the universe.
I remember,
I remember that hearing common.
Wait,
what you say,
what is this hearing at the comedy store?
And he introduced me to having to take vitamins to make sure smells don't
happen.
What is it?
I can't describe it to Eddie Bravo radio and listen to it.
It's a story about a sexual encounter that he had with the young lady who had a
yeast
infection and smelly feet at the same time.
And he had sex with her in a very,
in close quarters in the back of a truck.
It is such a funny fucking story.
Oh Dude,
by the way.
Oh,
you went to Russell Peters south to Russell Peters House party,
like for New Year's party.
Look,
John Faroe fucking brightest own iron man laptop and was deejay deejaying for
two hours a DJ too.
Dude.
He,
they're all djs.
And then on top of that,
right before new years of Bruce Buffer,
uh,
did like the whole,
get ready for 2003.
You know,
Lailey is so fucking pissed.
So classic.
I'm friends with Russell.
He should've invited me.
I'm actually friends with the guy
invited me bitch.
Lucky.
Got fucking crazy.
Like decorations.
Scarfaces house I guess.
I guess his house,
his house is amazing.
He's such a good dude.
He really is an understated too.
I was so funny you say this.
I was talking to a Mazda and AAA today and I talked about Russell and I've seen
Russell work so much because we've worked together like just like doing the
showtime special and so often he's just like fucking dicking around those days
to a crowd work or whatever.
And I saw,
I went online and watched one of his videos of him in the Middle East doing a
show dude,
he fucking hello.
Like I don't think I've ever,
I don't think I've ever paid them the honest respect probably why we're friends,
but as a comedian,
like I don't think I've ever really watched any of his shit.
And then I started watching all this shit.
I was like,
he's a fucking hilarious.
That's what I was going to say earlier that I got sidetracked about Tom Greene.
I watched a lot of specials when I was preparing for my special,
I was like,
I wanna like you would get a feel of like,
you know what it feels like to go out there and watch someone,
you know,
go out there and kill.
A lot of people were worried about being influenced by other guys.
Without a doubt.
I'm influenced by other comedians.
Yeah.
Helping
worried about that.
Um,
what I'm,
what I'm interested in is I'm interested still in being a fan.
I want to see it as a fan and I think I get knowledge from that.
I think,
um,
it's really widely recognized that the best way to be a writer is to do a lot of
reading.
It's one of the best ways to being a writer,
not just writing a lot,
but also bring a lot of reading if you want to be a good writer.
Um,
that's one of the things that,
oh,
Stephen King stresses a lot of writers stressed that in order to be a good
writer,
you should also be a good reader and you should read a lot of books.
And I think as a comic or the,
there's nothing wrong with being influenced by people.
I think we all support each other and then we all sort of like move each other
in a direction.
I think it's one of the reasons why being around La,
like especially like right now is a really good spot for standups.
Great.
So many of us,
you know there's,
you know Fitzsimmons is here,
Diaz
[inaudible] you guys have done with the ice house chronicles and getting all the
comics there for one night is amazing.
I've got,
I've been on shows that I,
I couldn't even dream
of if we're talking about like if you pitch that,
yeah,
it's a fucking $180,000 show
you did was you me?
Fitzsimmons D as shift fear.
What did you go to?
You might not think you were out of town.
The last one we got to town,
the last one,
the last ice house show,
whatever it was.
I mean you've been in for a million of them that they're shut.
My point is,
yeah,
there's show some we never would be able to do if we didn't all live in this one
area.
But when you do a show like that,
listen man,
why,
why go anywhere?
And we're right here.
Cut It already.
But when you're doing it and you get to see all these like really good guys I
think at like ups your level,
I think it makes it makes you a better comic.
I follow.
I've,
I've been following like whenever recently,
every time I've gone on ahead to follow Benson and I think Benson,
one of the quickest people on his feet talking about absolutely nothing does
great.
Doug's amazing.
And it's like,
wow,
it's so never on the road.
Am I ever going to follow a guy like Doug Benson?
Never.
That's never going to happen.
Yeah.
Well Dude,
I took a,
I took Fitzsimmons on the road with me to San Francisco,
Seattle and he could destroy is,
he was great.
He was bringing heat.
I was like God.
And it was like that old school Boston comedy,
like a real edge and a real honesty to it.
Yeah.
I didn't realize how good he was until I had kids and I and,
and this material that he had done about having kids.
I was revisiting it in life and going like Brexit.
Fitzsimmons already wrote that.
Yeah.
He's a funny dude.
He,
I started out together tell you what they like.
We're like a week apart from each other.
I've known that dude forever.
That was one of my favorite.
I listen to the first podcast you guys did together.
I was driving.
I had like a road trip.
I was driving from Columbus to fucking Dayton or something and I listen to the
whole podcast.
It was a great podcast.
Yeah.
We're going to try to Greg Greg on next week,
but the,
I'm doing a two inch shows with him.
It May,
I swear to God makes you stronger,
better.
I did shows recently.
We will at the end of the world show is a perfect example man.
Let me tell you something with dog and having done that,
Ari,
me,
Dunkin,
all wanted to come and hang out and watch you guys work.
Like we'd all talked and texted and we were all like,
I don't want to fucking interrupt them hanging out like I don't want to,
I don't want to ruin the moment of them hanging out.
No interrupting man.
Everybody said,
you know,
Bill Bursa the exact same thing you said and that is that what that shows me is
how cool you guys are that you'd not selfish at all.
We all wanted to go.
I go,
I said,
you go then because,
because you know,
you and Doug are like actually friends.
Okay.
It's still the bus.
I'm feeling the Starbucks cup and um,
it's like,
look at this.
It's like they didn't treat the whole cup.
You know how like you have a cup,
there's a reason why your cup can hold water or coffee or whatever.
But this one has a spot where they say,
yeah,
you got it.
You got comfortable.
They didn't get all their,
their cunty.
TJ's you've got cut,
fuck.
Get their country just over this side.
There's no here.
So it's like my finger went right through it.
Look,
oh shit.
Listen,
I back that shit up.
Don't worry.
I'm not stupid.
No.
Ari and I talked about it and we were like,
uh,
we were like,
you know,
we,
you want to give your friends respect to have other friends also is so crazy.
Listen man,
you guys are nuts and anywhere come,
come hang out and you'd be on the road.
I'd show up,
but it was la and it was like another thing is like don't come over my house
when I'm trying to fuck
all I'm saying,
man,
I want everything else you're in.
I wanted to see,
uh,
I never get to see you do stand up.
Like when we do the thing,
when we do the thing,
the guys have chronicles,
I get offstage and I have to go back in the room.
She was till podcasting and usually everyone's starting to trickle out by the
time you go on.
So I never really get to see you work and I was like,
I want to see him to do like a fucking ass.
I'm going to see like,
I want to see Stan hope work two minutes.
This is terrible miscommunication then because from now on,
anywhere I am,
you're welcome.
Period.
End of discussion.
I know by know hundred percent welcome.
I don't just show isn't any different.
I went to coffee with Joey the next day.
He goes,
it was genius watching Doug Joe Shadow boxing and Doug's smoking cigarettes.
Like he's got three weeks to live because goes,
I'm in the green room and stand up smoking fucking cigarettes.
And Joe Shadowboxing,
Joey Diaz is,
we have a very different approach.
One of the men,
one of the biggest blessings I've had in my life just to fucking really
interesting guy.
Yeah,
me too.
Um,
and that's why it's always,
you know,
one of the,
I've,
I've tried to figure out a way to make Joey Diaz famous for 10 years.
I knew when I met him that Joey Diaz was just this very unique human.
I was,
I knew like what a rare diamond this is.
Like how do you find one of these,
you know,
so I,
I would never say that I took care of Joey.
Joey takes care of himself.
You know,
Joey doesn't need me,
but I've always been,
it's always been very important to me to try to promote Joey in any way I could,
whether it's talking about them on my website,
doing interviews with them,
telling people how he's one of the rarest,
most beautiful,
unique characters I've ever met in my life and I have a discerning eye for,
for really interesting people as opposed to fake interesting people that are
trying to pretend to be interesting because I have no patience for that
nonsense.
That boondock saints type.
Oh Shit.
You can suck my Dick.
Okay,
that's fake.
I know what fake is on real is not going to get me caught up.
Cigarette commercial.
I just want to smoke inside and you all need to swim until you drown.
Okay.
Just go out there and show me what kind of character you really have.
You fake fucks,
dude.
Have you seen [inaudible] I'm learning more and more about this.
Stephen Dorff a loose cigarette thing.
Have you watched the behind the scenes?
Wait,
hold on.
wait.
Hold on.
A thing on our podcast where we talked about with the commercials burn Stephen
Dorff,
blue electronic cigarettes was the other one the other day.
Oh,
the Brad Pitt Pitt
can Brad Pitt made a perfume commercial and it's one of the Douche and Brandon,
our friend,
a mischief makers on youtube made a video pull up the video.
We actually requested it.
Brandon made it so we,
we have to pull it up.
We said how beautiful would it be if they combined the two douchey has
commercials in the history of the world.
Stephen Dorff stupid fucking electric cigarette commercial and I think it's the
Joe Rogan.
The douchey is commercial in the world.
Yeah.
Ever.
Do you ever see the video of Steve o Shitload,
Stephen Dorff,
how she actually shedding?
No,
no,
no.
With Steve.
Oh,
you never Nivo fucked Steven dwarfs girlfriend
on the podcast and hate Stephen Dorff.
We just,
I have no hatred whatsoever.
Seat.
You haven't seen this video.
You haven't seen this video
fear factor for six fucking years.
I cannot really be in all honestly,
uh,
in,
in all honesty,
rather innocently shitting on someone who's doing a cigarette commercial.
You know,
I did,
I did a lot of stuff that could be
easily can be promoters and Stephen Dorff I did,
he was great in blade.
He's uh,
he's great.
He was great in Sfw.
I haven't seen the garden.
He's,
everyone has a stevedore story.
He's the regular stores like Scotty Con.
Everyone's got a story man.
Those guys,
huge fan of
the comic book blade.
When I was a kid,
that was one of my favorite comic books with that movie came out.
I was super sick and he was pretty fucking bad ass.
He did a great job.
Brad Pitt
commercial return is just to go on the journey ends,
but we go around the world turns when we turn.
Was it,
let's turn to when we turn lesson plans.
Hold on.
We got listed twice.
You got an echo in here.
You fucking tacked them logically.
Confused Bitch.
What's going on?
I you are play this again cause nobody knows what you just said.
Stop.
It
twirled turns.
When we turned.
Was it?
What did your two deep fans disappear?
Put it in my mouth.
Oh God,
my hair.
But wherever I go.
Oh,
you are a bit his kisses salty.
I faked my fortune.
Chanel number five.
Whoa.
No you didn't Brad.
Brad's auditable.
God,
Brad,
Brad.
That's only part of it.
That's
you.
That's you on the podcast.
That's you right there.
You're not working right now.
No.
He has it.
And let someone else like Morgan Freeman.
This is not it.
There's someone.
He combined the two together with that song.
Kiss me playing.
You've got the wrong video,
son.
This is ladies and gentlemen,
before you criticize Brian,
I want you to know that this is not planned out.
We just were trying to win.
Here is here Steven door.
Good.
Here it is.
Until we turned whiskey.
That's what we requested.
One.
I'm tired of being a walking astrick plans to superior negative too.
I'm tired of feeling guilty
every time I want to light up.
Dreams takeover with blue.
He could smoke at a basketball game that you want to.
Can you pause this for one second?
If you make anything in black and white,
you're a fucking Douche bag.
Okay?
You are not going to trick me into thinking you're thing is moody and historic
and interesting cause it's black and white.
Fuck you.
It's 2013 stupid.
If you're only showing me things in two colors,
it means you're dumb and you want me to be all dumb with you and I'm not into
it.
Okay?
Fuck you.
You're black and white shit bag two dimensional world.
I need color.
Stupid.
I want reality.
I don't want things to be romantic.
I can't see him clearly.
I want you to tell me what the fuck is really going on and stop living in a
goddamn dream world.
Okay?
Fuck black and white.
I would love it if they'd color that Steven doors jacket was purple.
He's silly.
He's just silly,
man.
You need a letter?
He's silling Brad Pitt.
Silly.
They're both silly.
They should've never agreed to that.
You only agree to that shit when you're starving for Stephen Dorff for Brad Pitt
and less,
it all went for children's cancer or something.
Might Have Brad Pitt's a great human being.
He's a great human being.
That's why it's hard for me to criticize.
I'm definitely in love with Brad Pitt.
He's a funny character.
Was making electronic cigarettes.
He just wants to add in the bathroom on his house.
I don't know what he's doing.
I can't hate on the guy.
Let's just take,
it's,
would you ever renters commercial
or with your friends wherever I go.
Because you are,
the point is you can smoke blue virtually anywhere.
Oh my God.
Hit pause.
Brian.
What's so funny is that they're going
for the iconic James being smoking and it's so funny to watch him and just know
what to the electrics.
So ridiculous.
And he's got the same peacoat on that like they wrote when when like Jack
Kerouac wrote classic novels,
he paid for your brilliance smoker and I got approached by this fucking company
for my podcast.
Really?
What'd they say?
I think it was blue cigarette.
Oh my goodness.
What'd you say?
No,
and Brad Pitt.
I don't,
I don't care about advertisers as much.
Right pits talking to you like at like being at the w in the elevator pit is
over gang.
It like he's really trying to ear fuck you.
Like if I was to do a commercial for,
for like perfume,
the only way I would ever be able to sit with it is if I did it in character.
And if you look at Brad Pitt's,
oh,
all his older videos,
remember we pulled those up.
Brian,
the Japanese ones,
those were all in character.
He did a lot of Japanese videos and he did,
um,
like almost as if like it was a scene in a movie like weird,
so he can sort of justify like some sort of creative well aspect of this stupid
fucking commercial and maybe that's what he's doing there.
Maybe he was just being like the Uber Douchey Guy.
Like ridiculous.
My Love.
Maybe he's,
maybe he's
listening to this right now.
Going get it.
I didn't get it.
No,
no,
no.
The town at the top.
The top.
Listen to me.
I got it.
It's no,
okay.
I know what you're,
I know what you thinking.
This is what's going on Brad.
He need friends.
Okay.
You need real friends telling me what the fuck is going on.
You live in with that crazy bitch and you have 85 kids and you don't get a
moment to like stick your head up and get some air and so it's showing in your
psyche and one of the ways that's manifesting itself is you just did a fucking
Chanel number five commercial.
How recent that shot.
I don't,
I don't give a fuck if it was a year ago.
It's in the future.
That shit is crazy.
That's what we need to concentrate on.
Not,
not when it manifested itself,
but how the fuck everybody has an up in arms.
Yeah.
Brad Pitt.
What are you doing?
How did you do a Chanel number five cornerstone?
Do they have a video of you fucking they Chanel number five lady.
Like what?
What happened that made you say yes to that?
Right?
You don't need the money.
He doesn't need the money and I agree with you.
He needs friends.
He knows what he needs.
He needs someone to tell him what the fuck is going on.
He needs to go to coffee with Jody as one more to do with mushrooms.
I think it used to be a bunch of the mushrooms he used to party with.
Bill Maher could be too much.
Dude.
Everyone I meet nowadays that's Party with Bill Maher.
[inaudible] Date Bill Maher.
Maher.
I'm like,
what Bill Maher's him pimp.
That dude is a pimp.
Have you come to the girls?
Cause he cool on the show is very nice.
Yeah,
very nice to me.
The mother,
the wife is in love with them.
My wife hates Brian Gumbel.
Wow.
Why hates him?
Because he,
I don't know,
he's a little Douchey and yeah,
Bill Maher.
Uh,
the only thing that I've ever heard people critique about him is that they think
that he's an arrogant or they think that his ego is out of control or egos.
Obese sounded like he had a beef with dice clay and he did one thing that was
kind of crazy as that he wanted to go on after dice.
They did gigs together and Phoenix,
they're supposed to,
they did one Gig for sure.
And this,
uh,
the idea was that dice would go on and do a headline set and then Bill Maher
would headline and going after dice the last thing you want to do it,
let's go on after dice with like essentially a political act.
And apparently it was just just absolutely disastrous and he got booed according
to dice.
Of course you got off the stage fucking dice,
one of the funniest fucking human beings to hear on a podcast.
Bill's like he's a different sort of an animal when it comes to comedy and what
he's doing,
you know,
I think he has is his place and his place is that show that show is you know,
way more impactful than his actual standup.
This show the show where you get to see and yes he said some very good opinions
on things,
very good points of view on things.
I think bill is a very smart guy,
really smart,
smart enough to not go on after Andrew dice clay though I read a article ego
wise,
like that was a silly idea.
I don't know if I told you this or not,
but I read an article about Chris Rock,
you know that show I shouldn't have been there when I was oh yeah.
You know that show,
that show that made me laugh so hard.
Yeah.
Listen to it.
His New Year's Eve special.
No,
it was a good fucking great.
Really?
Yeah,
it's fucking
great.
As he got into showing the dice that he shows people when he doesn't know he's
on like,
like there was a,
there was a of time we're dice was being like,
I only hung out with them a couple nights or I take that back more than that.
But he,
when he wasn't on stage,
he was 10 times funnier than him.
He was on stage.
Well
for while he probably law,
not,
I want to say lost focus,
but wasn't focusing on standing up as much as he isn't it.
Yeah.
He's in family.
I think he was in family mode,
but he told me a story about kids.
Yeah,
he's very involved.
He told me a story about him taking his kids to the park and he had to take
them.
I needed to bring their bikes and it was so fucking funny.
He was telling me Louie Anderson and Chris Rock,
I was lucky enough to be there and I laughed so fucking hard that I was like,
he doesn't even realize this is fucking funny.
Like he doesn't even know how bad this is killing.
He should do it on stage.
It's sucks when you find people that are hilarious in person more so than on
stage.
And I didn't know if that's what he was doing,
like if he had gotten to that place with the stand up yet.
Well I think dice got,
there was a point in time,
well I think it's going to be really hard for you and I to understand how famous
he got.
It's very hard for me to understand.
It's,
he got to like perspective.
I think I'm famous now.
So like,
and so we that's ridiculous.
Exactly.
Yeah,
I know.
No,
that's why,
that's why I'm putting it in perspective.
And Mommy had to know you are,
you are amongst listeners of the podcast is to people who know who I am,
but what is,
um,
what is famous?
Like how many people have to know you before Pam might,
your mom has to know you.
That's what I,
that's what I think it's a mom thing then I'm not even famous.
My mom knows you.
Yeah.
But your mom knows me because you work for yeah,
no,
my mom knows fear factor.
Oh,
okay.
My Dad mom know you because of this podcast.
Really?
Yeah,
but it's interesting.
But yeah,
they do.
If I,
if I said [inaudible] watch UFC,
was you some kind of a pussy?
Actually my mom knows you from news radio.
She was at Phil Hartman.
I knew you from news radio.
I didn't know.
That's where I first found you.
So,
but then what is famous?
Yeah.
What's famous and what level is it when the sky captain,
I mean,
look,
it's a gross
distinction when you're putting it on yourself.
Everybody knows that.
You say,
well,
I'm famous.
Everybody goes,
if Tom Cruise had Melissa folks,
I'm famous.
If you knew it,
I was like to be me.
You'd be like,
but it's so accurate.
Cool.
Well,
Tom Cruise is the most accurate thing ever.
I was with Kevin James.
You want to hear how famous Tom Cruise's?
Yeah,
I was with Kevin James.
We're in Kevin's hotel room in Boston and his hotel room was a in is a very nice
hotel and across the street is this nice restaurant and we're on like,
I don't maybe like the fifth or the sixth floor and we're looking down and we
see Tom Cruise and people start running away from Tom Cruise to tell their
friends.
We watched it all happen that Tom Cruise is down here and they run back over and
you see like all these flash bulbs are going off down the street.
They just,
people decided that it was worth dropping everything they're doing.
It's running over to try to get a picture of Tom Cruise and me and Kevin James,
we're watching.
We were like,
Whoa,
there's Tom Cruise.
But,
and you guys are both certifiably payments.
Well yeah,
he's more than I,
but for sure.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people know who we are,
but we're not,
it's nothing like what it is to be this guy.
Like it gave me a dose of reality because like sometimes like after fights,
after fights,
sometimes it becomes a pain in the ass to try to get out of the arena because
like you gotta like,
like,
like this time I was meeting some friends and they'd come in from New Mexico and
it was like seven o'clock I had to get out of there,
you know,
we're at 10 o'clock rather 11 o'clock whatever it was.
I had to get out of there and I had to get to the restaurant as quick as
possible and you know,
you've got to try to make your way through this gigantic massive people because
if you don't,
you're,
you won't go anywhere for hours and hours and hours.
Yeah.
You will get stuck.
But that's a,
that's a small little microcosm.
Only after a fight in an arena for Tom Cruise,
the whole world is like that.
Everywhere that guy goes,
has it crept into your head?
Like what?
Like,
are you aware of it when you're going to go
grocery shopping?
Occasionally.
It's more young dudes,
you know,
can,
you,
can do,
can you point out someone that you go,
like there was a guy,
his head shaved and he's wearing tattoos.
That guy knows who I am.
I was so,
it's so funny cause I can point out people that w that might know me through
knowing that,
you know,
it's funny,
like the guy sitting next to me on the plane was wearing was,
he definitely was an MMA fighter.
He is a black eye fucking just first class Jack with a tap out shirt,
fucking hat with like he's been wrestlers entire life and he slept,
he got on the planet,
he fucking slept deviated septum.
Like,
and I was like,
yeah,
I go,
I guarantee,
I guarantee that if I said,
or are you involved in MMA or mixed martial arts?
He'd be like,
yeah.
And then I could go,
oh,
do you know Joe Rogan is?
And you'd be like,
yeah,
and he's listening to a podcast.
I couldn't see what it was he had his ear sets in.
I was like,
um,
have you ever,
like,
I was like,
it was,
that's how crazy the I was,
I could trickle down six degrees of separation or you might know who I am.
Well,
that's another thing that I wanted to talk about earlier that I forgot.
Is it one of the things that we've been discussing about like,
um,
what we're doing by doing all these podcasts and you have yours now and you
know,
of course Brian has had like a whole network of them from like maybe like the
first year on right
after the first year.
First Year we did it get started enough.
Yeah.
What year was that?
Like 2009.
Yeah,
nine,
10 maybe 10.
By the way,
I found Steven Tours and Steve O's video.
It's amazing.
I forgot about,
he calls her and Po Stevedores finish the story first.
One second.
Um,
um,
and,
when Shit,
what was my point about these podcasts?
What we've done is created like a legitimate network and like there's always
been networks with comedy central on NBC and CBS and ABC,
but are they really a network?
Essentially?
There are business,
I mean when you call a network,
sure.
They mean if there's a network of people that pick up on their shows.
But as far as like a creative network,
it's not really,
it's just like sort of one business that tries to put on television shows and
they have a network of people that received
them.
But the difference in the kind of network that we're sort of doing right now is
that it's a real network amongst friends and amongst people that are talented
and the people that we respect,
like as,
as we sort of do all these podcasts and link them all together,
Dunkin's to yours,
to Ari,
Joey's to,
and as,
as all of these things get sort of linked together,
that becomes like a real network and then an organic network,
like you're a part of it and Dunkin's a part of it and is a part of it in Joey's
a part of everyone's a part of it and it's all just connected together and it's
connected together by nothing other than true friendship.
There's no paperwork,
there's no bullshit.
There's no contracts,
there's no obligations.
There's,
there's no,
there's not
so interesting that you say that side.
Perfect.
Now that I think about it,
I go,
yeah,
like,
uh,
like a Dunkin,
like the people that have been on my podcast or Joey Ari have fron like it's
just,
it's like jump my buddy John Morris,
all friends and,
and I'm in Dunkin texted me right after he got done the cancer thing and was
like,
Hey,
I'd love to have you on my podcast.
And I was like,
oh,
I'd like to have you on mine.
And he was like,
cool,
we'll do that then.
And it was like,
like,
and I clearly understand what it's like to try to find guests to get on a
podcast now.
I never knew what it was like,
I just always did them because I liked him.
But like you very easily,
there could be a continuance of like,
like there are people that like,
uh,
like,
very candidly,
I'll say this,
I don't know,
I'm trepid walking into anything in this material.
Tom's guru and I,
we're going to do a podcast about Jay,
more about my experience with Jay.
And so we were like going to do it and I was like,
I was like,
maybe it will just be fucking honest.
Why would you bother?
Exactly.
We were like,
maybe we'll just talk about it and like air it out.
And I was like,
fuck it.
It's gone.
It's in my history and my past.
Yeah,
but he keeps on breaking it up.
Well,
he's on Pokemon.
Everything.
It's like,
come on,
just stop and move on.
That's on him.
I know that,
but it sucks.
In fact,
I don't have a problem with Jay more.
I've never,
I've never had a problem with Jay Moore.
The last text I sent him was positive and I w I haven't spoke to him since,
but I don't,
I don't want to necessarily go into anything.
No,
I don't want to dis guy.
I know what things,
I know when things are crazy and when things are normal.
Okay.
I know what makes sense and when you just keep bringing something up when you
keep going back over an issue and responding.
If I wanted to,
I could respond to Joe Rogan.
I smoke rocks all day every day and you would think that that's the only thing
that ever get on Twitter because I get it everyone almost every day,
almost every day.
Someone serious broken.
I don't know if you know this about me,
but I smoke rocks.
Yeah,
I'm and I'm honored.
I was a part of an iconic sketch,
which in my opinion,
the the funniest guy ever in any sort of a show on TV.
Dave Chappelle.
Yeah.
I think that,
I think that show was the funniest show for me that I've ever seen in the
history of my life.
So I'm honored when I don't get upset,
but if I wanted to just respond to that all day,
that's what my Twitter feed would be.
You choose what you respond to.
So
I don't respond to anything.
There is no real drama
between me and Jay more or you if everybody really does move on,
why respond to trolls who are just trying to get you to respond to something
that's a hot button topic by bringing up that shit is childish and I am a grown
man and I don't know,
play 40 years old style this 40 years old.
I'm a grown man and I have a lot of interests and none of them involved
responding to little silly bitches online.
I have zero interest in never.
I've never,
the one thing suggest you do the same.
I suggest to everybody when someone sends you something online,
it's Douchey and Conti and you want to respond.
That is your,
this is the universe giving you a test and just got an intelligence test.
Dude,
I've responded,
uh,
responded to people and regretted it.
Of course we all have in the second.
You do.
Yeah.
The moment you say,
fuck your mother and your fucking mother's assholes where your fucking Dick came
out of the moment.
You do that,
you feel like such a stupid person and then you,
and then you're,
you're sucked into a web.
Yeah,
it's negative energy,
but it's the,
it's Brody,
Stevens mentalities,
negative energy but gets negative energy,
positive energy.
That's all you gotta do.
And I,
and that's why I like [inaudible].
It's been,
yeah,
but I also believe firmly
that,
but then you believe that the people that have sent me negative things online,
there's been truth in a lot of it.
I've read a lot of criticisms of
Dan,
Dan [inaudible] or listen to me.
I've read a lot of criticism into my stand up or criticism.
If my commentary on,
on fighting and criticisms even on the podcast and I have legitimately learn
from it even from people that said negative shit because whether I like them or
not,
they have a very,
they have a point of view.
They've seen something and they seen it from their eyes and for whatever reason
from their eyes,
I'm annoying.
And that's real.
That,
that is how they view me.
And that's not what you say.
It's not to say that the people that aren't annoyed by me aren't correct.
It's just that's what,
what,
how they feel about it.
Like there's a lot of people that I'm friends with that,
you know,
a lot of people like,
look,
my wife would not want to hang out with Joey Diaz.
Okay.
If Joey Diaz was was high as fuck and uh,
you know,
and,
and he was on some wild,
crazy rants about licon Lucy snore bushes,
pussy in the middle of the night.
If he,
if you know,
if she was in this room,
she would absolutely,
she would laugh,
no question about it.
But it's not like she would go seek to hang out with Joey Diaz,
whereas I would yet obviously I love both of them.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
It's like we don't have to change each other,
but we must accept the fact that,
you know,
it's,
you're,
you're not gonna like me always.
I'm not going to like you always,
it's just like just be nice and find the people that you do like and
everything's fine.
But even the people that don't like me or they've seen my shit,
I've gotten criticism
out of that,
that I've incorporated.
But what about looked at it like from their point of view and it's helped me.
No.
What about this point though?
Is that especially on Twitter?
I'll say Twitter exclusively cause I remember when bird,
the conquerors started airing and I started at some guy,
I remember some black dude wrote a very quick like currently who is this ass
clown?
The conquer,
am I supposed to enjoy this shit?
And then I wrote back,
just wrote back positively.
I was like,
imagine BME watching it and then he wrote black.
Oh ha ha ha.
So funny.
He didn't know you'd read this.
Sorry.
I really liked the show.
I was just fucking around.
Like how about those?
Like the opinions have gotten so bold now.
Like people say things they would never say to your face.
Yeah,
there's definitely adapt.
But I don't really mean,
it's like that video just posted twitch,
twitters,
you know,
like people that are just twitching almost like,
like I thick.
Yeah.
Your mom.
Yeah,
I need something to tweet.
Fuck this guy.
It's like that video.
I don't if two inch twitters such a fucking funny ways.
Like,
you know what it is?
It's like tweet Tourette's.
Yeah,
but like those,
you see that like money Todd.
Yeah,
that's the word.
Lucky Todd.
Like last night went crazy.
Fucking psycho.
Well he's just a gentleman trying to make his way through this to get her
spiral.
You're lucky bitch.
We all fall apart eventually.
Every one fucking literally,
and you see the video you tweeted about those.
I don't know if we can talk about it or not cause it's kind of sketchy boys.
The boys who uh,
allegedly gang rape some girl and they were joking about it.
Oh my God.
But here's,
here's the thing.
It's like,
it's like a man.
It's you.
You look at the tweets from them,
the tweets about lying.
My God,
borrowers get no respect or whatever.
And,
and,
uh,
now I didn't grow up with Twitter,
so I go,
how the fuck could you be that person?
But maybe that's a new part of like,
maybe they're going to be like,
oh,
we didn't mean it.
No.
Listen,
those people always existed.
They always existed.
They just didn't have the opportunity to express themselves like they do now
with Twitter to the point where everyone,
anybody who wants to can literally go on Twitter and read what they said.
But what's different now is that people can respond to these kids and these
kids,
do you understand that there forever you're fucking documented.
They've always existed.
Sociopath's have always existed.
Groups of men willing to gang rape have always existed existed.
I can't even fathom out the reason why they've always existed.
One of the big reasons is that there had been no repercussions for it in,
uh,
like an internal way.
Like it's not,
there's never been like,
there's never been like documentation about a gang rape from the Roman era that
we can like put,
go and read online and watch and then go and watch videos of guys joking about
it and then going see photos of the victim.
There's never been an opportunity like that,
but there is now and that,
those images of that,
there's a,
there's one image of a girl.
It's unbelievably shocking.
The girls completely unconsciously dragging her and they're called.
They call them or people call them the rape.
Wait,
hold on.
I didn't,
I was afraid I,
this is how fucking sensitive.
I've got two daughters.
I was afraid to even click on the video that they had because I got nervous.
I was like,
I'm going to want to see an exact,
you should be,
you should creep into my life.
You know?
First of all,
we have to figure out what if you don't end the story.
There was apparently a gang rape in Ohio like a year ago and what happened was
the whole town has struggled to try to cover it up because the team is filled
with these,
like it's all their football team.
The football team is like a big source of revenue and,
and this is [inaudible].
Is this allegedly Joe?
This is not allegedly allegedly like people have like taken.
I don't,
I don't know what's in it.
What is it,
Steubenville?
Where does that stigma goes?
I really Hick Hick town in Ohio or is it really super hero?
Kids were charged.
They drugged up this girl and they hold a broader from party to party.
Hold on one second.
The more than one party.
The lead guy,
it was his ex girlfriend,
she dumped him and he said,
no bitch will ever get over on me or something to that effect.
And then he,
him and his friend set it up.
They had his fucking,
one friend said like,
go,
Hey,
I want to go out on a date.
And they picked her up and then they drugged her and then apparently they gang
raped her and took her from party to party like weekend at Bernie's.
Just horrific.
I mean it's so fucking,
it's so inhuman and end.
They have,
I can't,
um,
the only thing that I just get confused about is their fucking Instagram
instagramming all of these pictures.
Yeah.
And they're not just instagramming.
They're tweeting about it.
They're taught calling the girl a whore and know her,
she gets any worse,
bad conscious.
And it's like,
and you know how this got exposed.
Anonymous seriousness.
Yeah.
Anonymous is important.
You know it,
I have not disagreed with them on any move yet.
I have no fucking every,
I followed him.
I had to unfollow him because he have treats way too much to see their point of
view.
I see what they're trying to do and when they do something like this,
I say it's worth every negative aspect that they bring to the table.
Any idea about vigilantism or any idea that people have issues with when they do
something like this?
I say it makes them,
if they are one of the most valuable assets on the Internet when something goes
wrong and the world is upset when we were all morally upset,
they come in
if Goo,
if anonymous made like a thing where it's like Google where like like I don't
want Google to know all my shit,
but if anonymous knew all my shit,
I'd be like,
I'd be feel more safe than [inaudible].
You know,
despite what a lot of people have said,
you're
a nice guy,
you know,
you're a very nice guy,
you're a nice guy.
I am.
I try as hard as I can be to be a nice guy.
I would never describe myself as a nice guy.
I don't have to self-defining thoughts,
but I try as hard as I could be to be a nice guy.
Jamie's a nice guy.
There's this is,
this is in escapable.
If you go through life and you try to be a nice guy,
generally people are not going to be angry with you generally.
If you can avoid conflicts,
do it and you'll get along way better in this life.
Well,
when you get to a situation,
we're ultimately,
we're going,
no question about it.
We're going to get to a situation where everyone can reach out to anyone at any
time,
all over the world.
It's going to come.
Yeah,
there's going to be privacy filters that we're going to try to put into place to
keep people from contacting you,
but ultimately you're going to be responsible for the frequency that you put
out.
And if you put out a frequency,
if you're a famous guy,
if you're a Bert Kreischer,
I say Berg crushed his famous,
putting out a free,
you're putting out a frequency to whether it's 100,000 people or 300,000 people
with 3 million people,
whatever that frequency is going out to,
you're responsible for that.
And if you get bad pings,
so repeatable,
get upset at that.
There's,
there's opportunities to both learn about yourself and learn about other people,
man,
because when you learn about other people from their interactions with you and
how they interpret you,
you can see weakness in people that you don't have to senior yourself.
You could see mistakes and people that you can learn from.
Well,
you don't have to make those mistakes.
That should super important.
You need losers to show you the way.
They might not even be real.
The more they look into simulation theory and the more they try to understand
that the very nature of the reality that we live in and how fucking truly
slippery it is.
The douche bags that you encounter might be bad guys in the doom video.
Okay.
They might be there so that you can understand what is the wrong way to behave
and learn from it.
They might not even be real.
Yeah.
The anybody out there that's lost a loved one or had someone victim of a violent
crime.
That sounds ridiculous and in your reality,
yes,
but in bird crushes reality.
No.
My upon realities twisted right now.
Fuck.
I was blown away though by the fucking anonymous was like showed the pictures of
the guy.
Yeah.
The guy was fucking so went almost.
You almost appreciate a guy like that.
He should do that for almost man.
I appreciate the,
I appreciate him.
I couldn't tell them on Twitter but I appreciate what they're doing and I and
I'll fall.
Anybody who does that on Twitter?
I have you do follow anonymous?
Probably.
Nah,
I do follow a lot of people don't want to miss tweets.
I phone stop.
You know what?
I was a big thing.
You got it on just recently.
I'm really upset recently that Twitter's been only suggesting porn stars to me.
No,
sorry.
Ever suggested that to him.
God,
what am I,
what are you trying to say?
Okay I to say anything wrong with porn stars but how about a phd?
Every now and again,
am I really just a fucking pervert?
Is that all you're saying?
Twitter Dude,
Asa Akira traceable.
Fucking watch that shit.
You will buy when to buy her flowers.
I feel so bad cause even better.
I got it
chick.
Let's,
let's,
let's make people go and fall somebody.
How about this?
Cause someone named Mackenzie dern and she is at Gracie who mada she meet a
brown belt,
five time world champion.
See Twitter asked me to follow her.
Mckenzie Mac,
Kenzie dern,
d e r.
N.
And I say,
yes,
I will follow her [inaudible] ass chick out this strangling.
Oh,
I didn't look at mine.
Mine.
Oh,
clearly.
Clearly I am on a a desk squad kick because mine are tap out and Frank Mir,
well frank is Wagner's a very intelligent guy to watch sleepwalk with me.
It's on Netflix.
We had Mike [inaudible],
I finally watched it.
That's a great fucking movie.
Started watching.
I started listening to the NPR podcast because of your interview with,
with Birbiglia and I and I think I even told him,
I think I tweeted him or something.
But Man,
American,
uh,
what is it?
Uh,
the one with IRA glass,
the one that he does all the,
all the time.
This American life is great and you know,
whatever other ones.
Great.
His radio lab,
there's a podcast at radio lab did that I listened to on a treadmill.
I had to stop running and sit down and finish it.
It was so fucking good.
It's called the dark side of the moon or something.
It's about an astronaut who's,
he's an old man.
He calls in to moving Demitri Martin directed it.
Dimitri.
They do these live shows in a theater with the lights out because it's a
podcast.
Right.
And they do a live show up on the thing and then they had this guy called in,
he was an astronaut.
So it's like a play it,
no it's,
it is,
but with no,
they know you can't see anything.
They're doing it more dark.
Okay.
So everyone's just coming to the show on radio shows or radio live audience.
Right.
And they're throwing what a great idea.
Fucking right.
And their throat.
And Dimitri said,
I think we could get everyone laser pointers so they can all hit like a bad
idea.
No,
no,
no.
But it's like,
it's like,
so they're all that,
but no,
but everyone's doing it in unison.
Like I,
I,
maybe I'm fucking this [inaudible] so anyway,
but the,
the,
the point of the story of this guy has told is that is no more balls anymore
cause it kind of burned out by lasers.
No,
he doin lasers were dangerous.
I want to,
Star Wars are dangerous if they get in your eye.
Not all of them though.
Anyway,
the point,
good point story is this guy gets locked out of the fucking space station with a
Russian and they have to try to break into a new hole and get it in.
And it's all about him being in the dark and him being in the,
it's w I'm telling you,
Joe,
it's one of the greatest stories I've ever heard I love called.
Uh,
it's called,
it's,
it's a,
a king woods radio lab.
It's a few weeks back,
dark.
Is it in the dark,
in the dark and it's dark and a deal.
It is.
The gradient is the fucking coolest interview I've heard.
And he's an old man,
so he's not trying to be funny.
He's just being an old man and he's like,
uh,
and this is a true story.
True Story.
100% true.
You're just sitting there fucking floored.
Like,
Oh,
I'm just confused.
I thought it was a fiction piece.
No,
the guy is a real story.
He was up there with his Russian and it's,
dude,
it's painted in the dark and weird.
Yeah,
that sounds so good.
You know?
Listen,
man,
we need to do that.
We need to do podcast where we,
this is what we're going to do [inaudible] to the next level.
We're going to hire security guards and have infrared goggles on.
Okay?
So that makes sure that nobody gets crazy cool and they'll hide in the corners
of the room with fucking guns and Mace.
Okay?
Then the rest of the audience is in complete and total darkness.
Joe,
this is a fucking genius idea.
And then sports walking around getting blow jobs.
No,
because the guys with the night vision goggles,
what if they it and no,
no,
no.
They're not allowed to look at it.
This is a genius.
This is genius idea.
You do this on a stage.
We donate.
We have a magic word marshmallow.
Say we have,
we,
we have a safe word.
No record dude.
Who recorded.
Imagine doing a podcast.
We're all getting blowjobs to whole time or doing a podcast.
That sounds like,
that sounds like something that no one would want to listen to.
Brian,
it's a lot like a lot of this.
If you want to listen to,
can listen to the fucking swell dialogue and porn.
You want to say her good dialogue in a movie where it's like,
wow,
that guy has a really good point.
While he's getting blown.
No.
Most of your reserves will be spent concentrating on coq feelings.
That's the next level of stand up.
Stand up in the dark.
No good is your material that you can do is stay up in the dark.
When we look at your bitch,
you're right there.
What's the,
why are we playing games?
Cut off the lights but a podcast in the dark.
Well,
I mean cause that was,
people listen to it.
It look,
it'd be fun to do stand up if we all agreed to lie on the ground.
Yes.
If we had a room.
How about this?
How about if we had stand up and we did stand up like this.
So I did stand up and like a gymnasium and everybody gets like a
one of those pads.
So they like fucking go camping and just like,
it's like partying.
Yeah,
going to bed and you can't,
can't see me.
Everyone's lying down.
We're in the document,
what's up bitches and everybody laughs and then he just started talking about
whatever and whatever.
Everyone's here would have to be.
It would have to be,
you would have to,
it would be completely different kind of shout because you would,
first of all,
the people would be right there.
And there's that element you can't get away from.
By the way,
I'm at the Ice House Comedy Club,
January 11.
That's Friday eight 30 enter within 10 30.
So far.
Sam triply is confirmed.
I believe I'll be there Friday.
Shit,
Brian will be there as well.
To me it's only one night.
Oh,
this Friday,
this Friday.
I that this is a really great idea.
My point is sleeping bags.
Everyone,
we do it in a gymnasium.
We've got to do a comedy show in the gymnasium and uh,
each act lies down and instead of passing the mic back and forth to each other,
you just turn your mic on when it's your turn.
So like we would all lie down together on the stage and if you have to get up
and go pee,
that's okay.
So we're not Nazis.
You know you can get up and leave,
but don't be staring at people while they're lying down.
Okay.
With your eyes closed because that's fucking creepy.
How fucking great is that?
I'm excited just talking about it.
This is the only better idea I've heard from you is our compound.
I won't,
that's happening,
happening.
Aubrey's in Aubrey's done a more realistic idea.
We all go to Joshua tree.
Go to that.
That,
that uh,
place that I stayed at a more realistic idea.
How can you say it's more realistic because we're not all gonna like move our
families.
No,
no,
no.
This,
you don't understand.
This is the latest idea.
The latest idea is we get a set up like [inaudible] why did you make condos gay?
It was at one point
in time,
kind of used to be a mailing work point of success.
Well,
I've got a condo.
I can take her back to the condo.
I leased a BMW three series.
Enjoy yet you do you sexualize that word forever.
Drive knows
timeshare.
Kinda.
Let's
imagine being a dude named Bruce.
Oh,
your name is Bruce.
It's like they sexualize.
That name is literalize Bruce.
They broke it off.
They broke it off with sweet.
What's the next generation of the [inaudible]?
The compound.
The next generation of the combat is a high fence hunting setup.
It's really,
do
you get
lab in Texas?
You get a slab in Texas.
We want to get at least a few hundred acres,
but mo,
ideally several thousand acres with a lake or to Santa Barbara left.
Hold on.
I did.
I tell you now how dedicated on it is to success.
This is the idea and this is I bring in Aubrey,
of course,
this is my main man.
Anything on a business related by the way,
higher-primate.com
the tee shirt.
We will get tee shirts back in.
I'm so sorry.
Everybody keeps complaining.
Eventually a Aubrey is going to be involved in that as well.
The idea is you set up and a purse.
Everyone has a person that's got fucking
glitter on it.
Let it go.
My audit man versus are going to have fake rubies.
You plastic on it man.
Versus we should say,
okay,
am I lying when I say I [inaudible] am I lying when I say I go to the airport
with a fanny pack on it,
man?
No,
I'm not fucking make me pull up the and pull up the,
yeah,
go,
go on.
Amazon is
on and look up saddle leather laptop bag.
We'd go back to the next level.
The next level of the compound is a large self sustaining home in a high fence
set up and the idea is that you have a well or several wells.
I'm neither of those,
Brian.
It might be the one.
Oh yeah,
the far right.
Far Right.
Far right up top.
That's it.
Yes,
that's it.
Yeah,
it's very the George Clooney collection.
It's a very,
I looked very sexy.
Sophisticated.
That's period.
That's not the right one.
The one I got is we've been more preposterous than this.
Just a Oh,
that's it.
That's it.
It's like those,
the far left one.
It's got fucking straps in shit.
Sweet.
Similar.
If it's not the same one,
it's similar.
So this compound sounds a lot like reveal it.
The idea is the idea is not that we're prepared.
We're not prepper.
So K we're not preparing for the end of the world will hold,
but if he in the world happens,
isn't it to have a couple of bucks
in the bank?
That's what I'm saying.
Every motherfuckers worrying about gold.
Let me tell you something about gold,
okay?
It's not,
I'm not going to give you a cow for some gold if there's no internet.
Okay?
I'm not giving you shit for gold.
When society collapsed,
what do you want?
Bullets.
Gasoline.
That's what I want.
Machines last a long time.
If you take care of him,
you need bullets and gasoline.
Okay?
The idea is you have a high fence set up with solar power,
everything on their own animals.
Yes.
You have a high fence in Texas.
They have all these,
what they call high fence ranches and I have a love hate relationship with Ted
Nugent.
Okay?
I love Ted Nugent for a lot of ways.
One of the things I love,
first of all,
stranglehold,
one of my favorite songs of all time.
I love that fucking song.
And I love the fact that he promotes a hunting lifestyle and a lot of people
would think that that makes you some sort of a sadist or someone that hates it.
Animals.
What I am is a person who is really trying to come to grips with the idea of
life and death and like all of us,
I understand that I myself,
I'm a temporary being.
I,
there's only a certain amount of time that you have left a certain amount of
time that the human race has left.
Even the star that fucking heats us itself is finite.
So we all have to face the fact that we're in a revolving cycle of some sort
that may be infinite,
but at one one point in time,
this is going to change and go into something else.
There's no doubt about that.
So if that's the case,
why let all these delicious animals just fucking die of old age?
That seems ridiculous.
Okay.
So I'm with uncle tad when it comes to that and when I see him shooting all
these animals and eating them,
I'm like,
I think that's probably the way to go.
So I hunted for the first time this year.
I got an animal,
I ate it and I've been so satisfied and eating the meat from this animal.
I think that that's a beautiful way to,
to,
to exist,
to be actually responsible for the animals.
You go out and hunt and people have some really ridiculous ways of looking at
that and like,
Ooh,
if you really want to make it a one on one help and you don't bring a weapon,
well what are you anti human.
There's a reason humans invented weapons.
You know why they invented weapons?
To make it way easier to survive,
whether it's by defending yourself or whether it's by shooting animals,
the aberration of the school shootings and and serial killers and robbers in
using weapons dot.
That is all an aberration of society.
It's akin to being a spoiled Brat.
It's a similar thing because the person who spoiled is a person who has had
great success without any effort,
no character building.
They just become successful by virtue of being born.
And that's why kings have been historically so fucking cruel because their
royalty.
So they're putting this position of extreme power and influence without having
the character,
without having the,
the,
the Willer,
the will,
the character of a person who has gone through a difficult life to understand
the ins and the outs of social interaction,
the,
the odd experience of this life when you've gone from complete disarray and,
and,
and total worry about the idea of the future and no idea whatsoever of what
possibility the future may label it comes to having your next meal,
your next place to sleep or your next dollar that you earn.
And comparing that to a person who every day of their life has been assured that
everything will be okay every day of their life has been assured that there's no
effort necessary.
It's akin to people growing,
but hold on a second,
sorry.
But that you special for no reason,
for no reason.
And that's where those crate,
and it's almost as if they know that they're wrong.
So they're begging you to kill them.
Then they know that they're wrong and they know that being king is fucking
ridiculous.
So they're trying to torture people in Maine to the point where you just
violently react.
It's almost like they're pushed by by the universe to reacting in such a
preposterous way that it demands reaction.
It's interesting because my wife has taken to growing,
um,
vegetables and it,
and I heard,
I might've heard it on your fucking podcast,
but the concept that people look for hardship in their life to feel real.
Yeah.
Like my wife grows like nine goddamn tomatoes and then she brings them in.
I got tomatoes and we eat her crappy ass tomato that in polluted with all her
tomatoes just weak.
It's like she just doesn't know what the fuck she's doing.
Bugging wilted and small.
You can't really put them on a Saturday.
You of use all of our,
her whole fucking crop goes onto one salad.
And so,
but it's the idea that she's looking for hardship to make her feel real,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like a fucking,
I get,
I get floored by that kind of shit because I,
I kind of was like,
I wonder if it's a connection with working out because like I love when you work
out and you feel like you get yourself to death row up points.
Did you listen to the podcast that we had with rich roll?
I don't know which one.
Rituals and Meagan
and uh,
I've listened to all your podcasts.
Super,
super intelligent guy.
And uh,
what was his book?
Do you remember Brian?
Look up rich roll's book.
Anyway,
he came on the podcast and he was a guy who was essentially living an unhealthy
lifestyle.
And Yeah,
I did listen to a Vegan and just started living this really and 10 podcast
because,
because great,
I listened to him.
The only reason I remember listening to him is because I remember hearing him
talking about BDB again and then talking about changing his lifestyle and then
going,
oh,
that's so funny.
This whole time I've been listening to him.
I've been thinking he was skinny and I can't imagine him now as a fat person
signing Altera.
Yeah,
I know he's,
yeah,
finding ultra it.
So by the way,
I haven't read it all,
but it's a great book.
Whatever
red,
it's so honest and interesting and having them on the podcast,
like that guy has zero douche bag in his body.
He's a sweetie and,
and,
and he's a really intelligent,
interesting guy.
And His conversion from like going from being living an unhealthy lifestyle to
completely plant based Diet and plant based foods and how healthy he became
because of it is so inspirational.
You know?
And I goof on like vegans a lot of times because there's like,
there's a thing that people do when they become anything or when anything is
possible to become,
whether it's a scientologist or whether it's Catholic or sober or sober w that's
a good point.
That's a really good base where they preach,
they spit it out at you and preach it to you and they're doing it,
not necessarily to let you know that you know that they are Vegan or sober or
whatever it is.
But to establish a social position.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's also this,
it's also in my opinion,
like a perfect,
like it's a self righteousness.
It feels good to us.
I was at a party,
a birthday party for someone.
My,
my buddy James,
um,
it was at a park and he brought up in the morning and he brought a bottle of
whiskey and he was like,
Hey,
let's do shots or morning birthday party.
And I'm like,
I can't,
I have a shoulder and I was working in Irvine or Bria.
I go,
I can't.
And he goes,
oh come on man.
If you don't do shots,
none of us can do shots.
Like you do shots and we can all do shots,
but if you don't do them then we're going to look weird.
If we do shots,
I go,
I can't logic is that,
that's cause that's kind of Sam,
that new deeds need to go to the dunes and run up sandhills.
No,
no.
Think about,
think about,
think about it this way though.
Like you're the kind of person like hypothetically space saying,
do your friends of your kids,
like your friends,
family,
friends,
do they know you smoke pot?
Oh yeah.
Okay,
so now wait,
hold on.
You don't know I smoke pot.
It's because you're not paying attention but you,
but sometimes,
but sometimes you meet new family friends that you haven't asked at all.
But so now Harvey just retiring,
Go du Du Pont documentaries.
But my point is so say say they go to a birthday party and and all the parents
want to smoke pot and you're like,
no,
I'm choosing not to.
Then all of a sudden all the parents look like degenerates.
Cause the guy that is nationally known for smoking pot is choosing to be sober
because he wants to be an,
you know what I mean?
Don't smoke pot around my kids,
but I could smoke pot around my kids.
I'm not,
I'm not saying that I wouldn't smoke,
I wouldn't smoke pot around my kids for for several reasons.
One reason is it would be very confusing,
but when the idea of altering consciousness comes up with my four year old or my
two year old,
I will discuss it.
But with my 16 year old,
I have discussed it with her many,
many times.
We've had some long conversations and my point of view on altering your state of
consciousness as,
as hypocritical as it may be,
and it absolutely is,
is that you should not do it until your brain forms.
Yeah,
I agree with that 100%.
I got very fortunate in that I didn't fuck with any sort of hardcore chemicals
until I was like deep in my thirties I was 14 but I was very lucky because I was
crazy.
In another way.
My crazy was I was terrified of doing anything that was going to inhibit my
physical performance.
Yeah.
Because most of my formative years from my teenage years until my early twenties
were based on fighting performance.
That's what I was mostly concentrating on fighting performance.
And that was dedicated to the idea that anytime that I,
10 minutes,
anytime that I spent working on um,
martial arts or training would be eroded by partying if I got drunk.
I wish I had that condition which had waited until I was older.
This stop cause cause I know your wishes because you wouldn't be Bert.
Kreischer beautiful fucking flower flower gone on.
We'd come on.
Yeah,
it was pretty fucking awesome.
Fucking nirvana got back to us in this podcast is supposed to end because we
don't have much time left but I don't want to go anywhere.
I don't want to go to her.
This let's do another one.
Yeah.
Let's man,
you got any way to go Brian?
I was going to do comedy.
No,
Brian Comedy.
Let's do another hour.
All right,
let's do another.
I'll just stop it.
Piss.
I love another hour.
Fuck out of you bitches.
Listen,
we're going to be right back.
We're going to both Burt and I going to piss separately.
Okay.
My piss on both as comfortable as I am with my soul together with you.
Look you in the eyes and got that condos please.
Before you think about my
piss or even masturbate thinking about my past,
I want you to go to rogan.ting.com that my friends is the last thing that ting
ever wanted when they signed up to be a sponsor on the Joe Rogan experience.
They never wanted anybody to connect pis and Tang and masturbation too late.
Sorry.
But if you got a rogan.ting.com they will give you $50 off the bat,
motherfucking android cell phones available and that will take the sting off the
homosexual implications of anything that I've said in the last 15 minutes that
made you rethink your childhood.
Get a whole phone,
rogan.ting.com
I think it was like condos.
This sponsor was also brought to you by a combination of on it and Jameson at
the same time.
I wouldn't recommend it if you have to drive you around.
Good friends like Jamie,
the new guy,
Bert Kreischer,
Aka the machine or Brian Read Ben.
My motherfucker.
I suggest
that you stick around and we a little bit cause we're gonna pee pee and be right
back.
All right you several thousand people listening online and even more to be
downloading this long after the fact and after the dinosaurs came back on a
space ship I will see you in about three and a half minutes.
holla@yourboyona.com it's o n n I t use the code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements but that does not include
blenders,
kettlebells or battery rubs cause them shits is expensive one day when the Onnit
compound is super successful and we have started our own religion we will offer
significant discounts.
Yes because there will be no money and it won't.
It won't match.
You will be bringing over goats and cheese and spring water because that will be
the commodity of the future or not or the commodity.
Their future will be bandwidth because we'll be living in an infinite dimension
of pixels and particles in non essential bits flying through the interwebs and
Al Gore will be worshiped as Shiva is here at the higher primates studios.
We'll see you guys in three and a half minutes.
Meanwhile,
go fuck yourself.
It shouldn't take that long.
We'll be right back.
[inaudible]
I would maybe I would maybe do.
Hold on a second.
Don't
say a word.
Don't say a word.
Don't say a word until this bitch gets cracking birth.
Quite sure.
Train by the crusher.
Bert Kreischer I want you to keep it together.
I want you to hold on.
I'm holding us to realize this is a gun damn commercial free podcast.
Exceptional addition is an,
except the podcast was so good at cannot be stopped for the greater good of
Shiva or Odin or Thor or Cassio p uh,
did anybody ever worshiped Cassiopeia?
Is that the watch some chick with some dude probably wanted to fuck and he got
all exaggerated with how hot she was named Meryl fucking constellation or some
shit rate.
Cassiopeia I bet her website's available.
Good.
Is your pussy you have to be before they named constellation after it.
Not even like a tree while a rock,
not a mountain.
No.
A series of nuclear explosions in the middle of the universe.
Why haven't they rebooted Thor in like he got a haircut yet?
Because thought is a little bit lucky.
There is red.
He's dope.
Don't be,
hey,
listen,
Brian,
do you have a full head of hair?
You shouldn't be hating because I have almost zero hair and I'm not hating.
Okay?
It's a matter of time before I shaved my head.
It's your issues.
You should do it.
I sprinkled the heroin now bringing things.
Yes.
Yeah.
Dude.
Shaving your head as a beautiful feeling.
Is it just do it.
Trust me.
Just do it once.
You obviously don't give a fuck about your body.
Let's be realistic.
You've,
he's been working out a lot.
No,
you're not.
Okay.
If you're saying you have to be honest,
you know I love you,
but let's be honest.
If you were entering into a bodybuilding contest,
I would say this guy does not want,
okay.
Okay.
He is not trying to win sexiest.
Man.
I don't even look good in Europe,
in his speedo.
Yay.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
I sound not that there's anything wrong with that,
but let's be honest about our pants or his life.
Ladies and gentlemen.
So deaths,
a death squad,
Scotland and desk got Ohio are losing their fucking minds because they're told
you to stop communicating with those people.
You don't know them.
You have not vetted them.
Sir.
I know you guys gotta hire.
They're awesome.
Yeah.
You know he,
Brian does know.
Yeah.
God dammit you none of them.
Mother fuckers have a proper filter in place.
We need to fucking setups of scientific checks and balances.
Much like the CIA uses.
If this,
uh,
can't just decide.
You can let some mother fucker send you some whiskey.
Oh,
I can't believe we have a refrigerator here at [inaudible] water studios were so
not fucking around,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
We're taking this to the next level.
Bert Kreischer to see what we're doing here.
This is not my own Buddha.
I got to fucking care package from on it.
Yeah.
You've got a care package from on.
And we got the Buddha responsible for my tattoo.
What was that?
The Buddha.
He's an asshole.
He's like,
Hi guys,
are you here?
You don't,
but tattoos,
are you gonna are you gonna I'm gonna fill in my right arm.
Can you say that shit?
You're right arm that is the same.
Hello.
The guy who did my offer,
first of all,
he's a beautiful artist and he's a cool mother fucker.
His name's Aaron Dellavedova and he,
uh,
works at Guru Tattoo in San Diego.
I get,
I would get tattoo just to hang out with that dude.
He's so cool.
I want to say I want to kill him,
but he's a real artist.
He easily,
it's really cool paintings and I,
I love his,
like his point of view.
Like it's so uniquely his own that you remember that guy that was,
uh,
Jesse James Rather,
who's married to Sandra boats.
Yeah.
Remember he had that affair with some grow at tap to swap to a bicycle I saw,
no,
no.
She doesn't have that.
Yes,
yes.
No,
no,
no.
She was not a swipe power.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
She didn't know she did do,
she did not know.
She definitely did.
No,
no,
no.
She had swastikas tattooed.
So stop it.
Stop.
No,
swear to God.
Jo.
She's really good at telling you when you,
I'm telling you you're wrong.
What's her name?
Check.
Wait,
it's like Michelle dynamite or something like that.
No,
but anyway,
my point is that she had this sleeve and I looked at the sleeve and I said,
that's an Aaron Dellavedova Tattoo.
I could tell that his style is so distinctive and I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm such a huge fan of individual points of expression.
Why?
Or like,
um,
like there's certain like pool cues where you could look at the pool cue and you
know,
that is a sugar tree.
That's a cue that Eric,
Chris May,
that is a cognitive centi acute at Joe Gold
May that they have like this individual point of expression.
Michelle.
Michelle Mccain.
Yeah.
She didn't
Nacho.
That's what it was.
She just not have any,
she doesn't have tattoos.
Like some crazy photo shoot that she had to do.
Although it does say WP on her leg.
Yeah.
Like as in white power?
No.
Or what it means or,
whoa.
Is that really what it means?
WP?
I'll think.
What else?
Oh,
poop.
What was my point about her?
Uh,
you were talking about,
uh,
your tattoo artists had her arm or something.
I saw her arm and one of her arms.
I think it's a right sleeve.
Yeah.
His style is so distinct.
Did you start to check out?
Well,
I looked,
uh,
in California and I was looking at all these different,
you know,
it's like you,
if you,
there's a lot of really good artists in California,
especially,
you mean Kat von D who we've had on the podcast.
Ah,
shoot.
That's a great podcast.
Yeah,
she was really cool.
There's this,
there's just so many,
like,
I don't even want to name names,
is a million talented artists.
But when I saw Aaron's work online,
especially sleeves and big back pieces,
like his style is really about big,
bold,
like pieces.
And when I started talking to him like immediately we hit it off.
I was like,
this girl is cool as fuck.
He's so cool.
Like right away.
Like I was like,
like,
you know,
you talked to someone you really like happy to have a conversation with them.
And we were like on the perfect level.
Like it really like,
you know,
both of us were talking about all kinds of like different crazy shit and he's
hurt.
He's an honorable person.
He's an artist is like right away.
I was like,
I love this guy right away.
It's perfect guy to do it.
What did you guys,
uh,
if you,
if you remember,
I'm curious to see if you remember.
What did you guys talk about while he was tattooing you?
Everything and anything man.
Like do you remember any of the conversation?
Like is it,
we have it on,
is it like a meaningful gap at the beginning?
Are you serious?
First Sleeve?
Yeah,
at the beginning of the first leak
a lot it was on video,
but then the second sleeve is like,
like about 33 years old.
I still have to go back.
I still,
there's a few spots on it.
It's amazing.
Most of it is a memo to Musashi piece.
Who's the guy who is the,
Oh and there's the graphics joker.
I thought you got rid of the graphics Cherokee.
Yeah,
I thought you did too.
I have to suck.
That's not quite done yet.
I got it.
I think they should pimp that out.
It's not leave it.
Remember it was like really even before I knew what a graphics joke or was.
And you drew it,
right?
Stupid idea.
Yeah,
I drew it.
Yeah.
She's just to cry.
But I caught that shit.
That's my Jujutsu explain it as much.
But uh,
this Jamison experienced that tattoo.
I did draw it.
I drew that in 1990.
It looks like shit now.
It's like the guy who better than water,
if the guy who tattooed it for me did a fucking brilliant job,
his name was Danny Williams and he died of cancer really recently.
And the bottom tattoo,
the really crazy looking Samurai guy that is a meal multi Musashi and he's
fighting a tiger.
And that's what happened.
What happened to sick artwork,
man,
that's all.
Uh,
that's all my man Aaron Dellavedova his work and he just said,
yeah,
he does brilliant work.
It's,
yeah,
the beach.
What was the,
what was the term for what for you?
Like where were you,
you went from like one tattoo and not smoking weed to like,
I don't,
maybe I've heard well,
what it was.
Um,
I,
I always liked leg tattoos.
I always liked the artwork of it.
I'm a big fan of,
I'm a big fan of music.
I'm a big fan of writing.
I'm a big fan of meat movies and cars and,
and paintings and anything that you do that expresses whatever you have inside
of yourself through some medium,
whether it's the medium of making a hot rod or it's the medium of even designing
clothes.
Like,
I'm like,
like I'm wearing some crazy tee shirt right now.
Some dude gave me,
it's a Bruce Lee who's a,
he's acting as a DJ.
I thought that was hilarious.
So I,
but it's great.
It's funny.
It's someone's idea that's expressed through clothes.
You know,
you can express it through furniture,
like my friends in this table tables Badass.
Yeah.
I mean you can express it through anything,
but it really,
it's all the same thing.
The eye,
the idea is that everything that a person can enjoy as someone else trying to
express some sort of positive idea through whatever medium it is,
whether it's a fucking,
whether it's les Miserables,
bowls,
50 shades of grey,
it's all the same thing,
you know?
But what was the turning point?
Do you remember the thing?
No.
Um,
I know I was probably some psychedelic drug related experience or it's likely,
yeah,
yeah.
What got you there?
Um,
well if marijuana is a gateway drug,
I'm really unfortunately a good example.
I don't think that is negative gateway.
I think we have to get over that idea.
And I think a big part of the struggle that we have in this country,
and it's a lot of conservative people misunderstand the position of people that,
uh,
support marijuana or cannabis.
And it doesn't mean that they're mutually exclusive and it doesn't mean that
they have to be in combat with each other.
It just means that for whatever reason,
as a society,
we have associated cannabis smokers and users with lazy bitches.
And that's stupid.
And I think that if I have benefited as a,
an unnecessarily aggro,
you know,
child of the 80s if I have benefited from the magical gift of marijuana,
then I bet you can too.
It just needs to be used properly and it's gonna make you examine yourself in a
way that may be uncomfortable but is most likely necessary.
You know,
and the ideas that we have connected to
any sort of psychedelic experience,
marijuana or pod knew you name it,
mushrooms automatically people of a conservative nature.
We'll assume that the people involved and doing this thing or being lazy or
they're being,
they're being frivolous,
they're being frivolous because they've decided to like seek escape through
chemicals rather than deal with the reality.
But if they really knew,
they would know that that's not the case.
If they really had experienced,
they would know that.
No,
it's exact opposite.
This,
I hate to fucking bring up this Goddamn Radiolab
well show.
Again,
they were talking about religious experiences and people who did acid and,
and they,
and there was a,
there was a,
they were talking about,
they took these kids at Stu at in school,
took him down to a church setting where a church sermon was giving,
going on.
They're all religious teachers.
Okay.
All religious teachers.
I'd like religious students,
they all take acid and they hear a sermon,
the church with the beautiful bells and they said that nine out of 10 people in
the test group,
so there's 2010 have a seat,
uh,
of a bullshit,
you know,
the placebo 10 until the one nine out of 10 had a religious experience.
Wow.
And they were saying that that nine of the 10 also went on to um,
teach in the ministry,
like nine to 10 deal.
It took acid.
And they were talking about the concept of whether or not you could do acid and
whether or not you could create original religious experience.
And if you could,
why wouldn't you have that all the time?
Why wouldn't everyone look for that?
Well,
what's what we were talking about earlier about like one day maybe we can get
our shitty brains to accept the state of opiate and Mgma and at the same time,
all the time,
I want like a low grade cocaine,
like,
uh,
what's going on?
I mean all respect to people who are on antidepressants and this is not an
antidepressant rant.
And I think quite honestly that there's quite a few of those rants that,
or they're ignorant.
And even though,
you know,
we had,
um,
a conversation with,
Carrie Santa Maria who was on the [inaudible],
I fucking loved her.
That girl was so fucking,
I've,
I've regurgitated some of her facts in conversation,
not realizing I'm doing it.
I fucking was.
So I was afraid to Google her and see what she looked like.
So I was like,
what is,
she's not hot because she was so hot on this podcast.
Just listen to her.
You were like,
oh,
she's beautiful smoking.
And more importantly,
she's very fascinating.
Very,
very,
really fascinating.
And what was my point and taking psychedelics are three of them.
Three of them in a row.
Yeah.
Next week I'm taking her house.
You want to double date?
Nope.
Why are you trying to like [inaudible] the fuck out of you?
But anyway,
the point was that is that
she was describing her own personal benefit from,
uh,
from using antidepressants and her own personal,
you know,
her,
her personal benefit from like regulating her state of consciousness,
but with the use of science.
And if you really stop and think about it,
like the,
some of the best feelings that I've ever had have been under the,
uh,
under the of chemicals.
You know,
whether it's right now or whether it's the first time I ever did anything which
was MTMA anything that's significance.
When,
when that feeling is so sensational.
Like what would life be if that feeling existed all the time?
We automatically have this thought in our head that that cannot be managed and
that needs to be discarded right away immediately for the state of consciousness
that you exist right now can never be elevated.
This is what it is.
But how do we even know that's true?
I Wa I,
I wonder sometimes because I go like,
I feel like I spend my day chasing,
chasing a buzz where it's like,
like coffee in the morning and then there's just like dead period in the
afternoon when my quad before the beer.
When do you feel it's respectable?
Just start drinking at five 5:00 PM 5:00 PM
5:00 PM or you can say,
leave me alone.
Oh God.
At work.
Who keeps the fucking lights on some of the best moments of my life or when my
wife had a job,
we were living in an apartment complex.
We had a nanny only because I was on the road and sometimes the nanny and I
would overlap and I'd be there when she would be there.
The best feelings my kids are,
they're sunsetting in Hollywood.
My wife fucking them up in the door and just going,
did anyone open a bottle of wine?
Oh motherfucker.
I remember getting like chills.
Like it's Christmas Eve.
Like,
Oh and we crack open a bottle of wine,
pour one for the nanny.
We just sit on the couch at socks.
Fuck.
Oh your love.
I love those kind of moments.
You love like ultimate relaxation moments where everybody agrees.
Yes.
It's time where everyone's on the same page.
I think that's a one that opened the bottle.
Everybody agrees.
It's great.
Why you like sort of the ultimate party meister?
It's like you're the guy that would get everybody.
Ah,
fuck it.
Bert was you shot.
Let's do shot.
Well,
we do a shot.
Give me a hug.
You fucks.
I love you.
And everybody would get together,
I think.
Yeah.
I love that feeling when you win.
Like it's like just fucking,
someone just goes,
uh,
I go,
who's going to be all grown up?
If I owed her a beer and someone will be like,
if you get one,
I'll get one.
I'm like,
we're fucking,
yeah,
right away.
Can love that feeling.
You think that's what the feeling people get when they connect with they smoke
marijuana is that someone liked it and then they're like,
Nah.
They're like,
okay.
Like it's such a great,
like
there's definitely a thing that comes with being like in that sort of fraternity
of people that know,
you know,
they know you'd smoked pot,
everybody's in this like,
oh,
we're all cool and then,
right.
Geez.
You sort of accept that traditional notion of reality.
Like if you've never gotten high,
you and I have very little to talk about.
I mean we can talk about a few things for certain.
We can talk about facts and Statistics and history numbers.
We can talk a lot about a lot of things,
but we can't talk about what the fuck is going on.
When you think about someone and then the phone rings and it's them.
We can't talk that because you're
going to give me some scaredy cat answer.
You're going to go whoa.
It's just sort of a coincidence.
There's no relationship whatsoever.
There's never been a statistical correlation between you thinking about someone
and then them calling you and that meaning anything significant whatsoever.
It's just nonsense.
I need you to get a ramp and put a tile where some shiny shoes with slippery
soles walk down the street like a gentleman.
I don't know,
but I know that when I,
a little light bulb goes off in my head and I think about Bert Kreischer and
then I looked down at my phone and it starts ringing immediately and it's Bert
Kreischer will call me crazy,
but I think something's up.
Okay.
I think there's something fucking going on when I think about you and then all
the sudden you call me immediately.
It happens every day nonstop.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
And you know when it happens,
you ready for this Brian Red Band?
It happens when you live in your life correctly.
When you live in your life correctly,
the universe gives you a lot of fucking secret messages.
You
University,
that's what it is.
I like yesterday,
this is something crazy.
As an example,
yesterday I was talking to my friend who's a ginger and I'm like,
is there such things as Jewish ginger's I've never even heard is like I've never
seen a Jewish ginger before.
She was like,
of course there is.
And then like two hours later to somebody else,
it's just like,
oh this guy,
he said,
ginger,
he's a Jewish ginger.
I've ever seen one.
I'm like,
all right.
I've never talked about ginger Jewish ginger's my whole entire life now twice in
one day
there's a possibility that you attracted that there's a possibility that much
like you ever sent an email on Google,
you know,
it could be about anything.
You can send an email and say,
hey man,
I'm looking to get a lifesize copy of the robot from lost in space.
And then you look in the corner of your Gmail when you get on and it'll be all
lost in space.
Shit.
That's cause it's reading your email.
Right?
Right,
exactly.
So you think somebody reading my presently,
oh I like this.
This is my point.
If reality is a simulation,
wouldn't it follow the same principles that your genes or your Yahoo has where
you'll see the corners were shit that you've sent emails about.
We'll be reoccurring themes and you're like,
I do that in life all the time.
I've put it out there.
But isn't it fascinating it out there,
Graham?
It mirrors.
It mirrors what we know is a program.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's fucked up.
It's true.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's just the fucking natural course of history of how life's going to go down.
It already happens in life.
God does.
It will.
The universe does it.
It trickles down to you.
You sound like you're ripe for a cult.
I couldn't fucking get you to sign up.
Right.
Let him give me some Blue Nike,
my deck in a house full of feathers.
I could be so quickly put on called.
I've been watching
this documentary on the vice guys made a documentary about this fucking dude
who's a,
uh,
the,
these,
the new Jesus.
He's a Siberian Jesus.
Have you seen that Brian?
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen
pulled up.
No,
we shouldn't pull it up because it's a really long piece.
You guys are crazy.
It's at least I've only watched the first two 10 minute pieces,
but it's fascinating.
There's a guy in Siberia that's created a village and he's like,
the second coming of Jesus is like the new Jesus and he has thousands of people
that are living up there.
Thousands.
They're all living up there,
but meanwhile they live in an unbelievably unbelievably beautiful place.
I mean,
it is stunning if you maybe maybe seeding and find some photos,
but it's staggeringly beautiful and this guy,
he's not appreciate anything bad except being a Vegan.
That's silly.
I can't really get it.
I got to have Vegan fucking,
even when I was doing that clean program,
Jesus,
I'd have a chicken with fucking lettuce wraps.
Oh,
I love spicy shit.
Yeah.
I wish that animals aren't so fucking delicious.
The fucking amazing.
And I wish that they didn't fucking keep making animals.
Maybe they would just all live forever and everyone will be a mortal when you
have enough numbers now and just keep it going.
I had duck heartlands dude,
let me say that was the photo of the dude.
Who's the,
the Russian Jesus.
Meanwhile,
he's getting an awesome spot.
I don't think I ever saw Jesus smile.
Yeah,
well he does.
When Green Day's playing cause he's hurt
the GSG all Jesus,
his pictures were like hip hop cover albums.
I just was up
the Australian,
Jesus is a guy in Queensland and he says he's,
Jeez,
I was just in Queensland.
What's that guy look?
What are you doing?
Stand up.
No,
he did a triplet,
but Australia in Queensland,
Australia,
this country I've ever been to.
I'm telling you what to say this and I don't,
I'm not shitting on America and I'm not shitting on Kaniqua Canada.
You guys are second.
But Australia blows everyone out.
I love,
I love the people there.
I love their attitude.
It's like a,
except more.
We were so uptightness country,
we're,
we're really so unbelievably uptight,
especially when it comes to like going out and having fun and relaxed.
I'd moved to Australia in a fucking heartbeat in a heartbeat.
It's like there's this thing about America that America was sort of founded and
created by a bunch of people that have come here from somewhere that sucked and
they had enough and they just made it over to some new spot.
But I think that the type of person that it takes to be able to get in a boat
and travel across the ocean and land land,
I think it takes several generations before everybody fucking relaxes.
That's the bad ass motherfuckers that could get a boat had fucking
do that.
Cause you just shook the,
the,
the loose leafs got shaken off the tree.
They,
they were,
they're so gangster.
They gotten a gun,
damn boat and traveled across.
Do you ever do that with no radio?
You ever think about that though?
When you travel with your kids somewhere and then you go,
how would we travel across America?
Like how would,
how your family size up in a wagon train going from New York to La bye
family would have either stayed.
I mean if you had little children,
you did the state in Italy or Ireland,
you would have done whatever you could do to stay where you were.
But my uh,
Grandfather's family came over here and
I want to say the early 19 hundreds of my grandfather's family came over here
from Italy and my grandfather lived on a farm and he said,
tell me stories about how they used to kill rabbits with their hands and grabbed
him by the neck and snap them.
That was like a normal part of your life.
And there was,
you know,
winter in square,
like they would run out of food.
Like there was no food.
Like they'd have to go and borrow food from people that were neighbors.
So crazy times,
man,
it's crazy.
I know.
It's crazy.
More crazy thing that is the like can I say this?
I said this guessing Lee,
but like the amount of humility your grandfather must've had,
he was a very humble guy.
Do you like to come here?
Almost two.
Oh,
you know,
I,
he got walked on by my grandmother.
My grandmother was in a really strong woman and she used to yell at him all her.
I was like a little kid because my mom had me when she was 20 and you know,
my mom did her best,
but she was really young.
You know when you're 20 years old and all the sudden you're raising a baby,
that's a parent.
I was 2021 I was 21 when I was born or when my,
um,
my mother was 21 rather when I was calling,
I was 21 when I was four.
I might as well,
Ben,
I would probably feel like,
oh my God,
this bitch is 21 she doesn't know what the fuck is going on.
I got to get up
to 20 grand grandparents or tally immediate seven.
No,
they're over 40 they could have been,
no,
no.
At the time you were bored.
I don't know.
I don't know how old they were.
I mean they care about me to wrap my head around now I don't want to do the
math,
but the point was,
Mike,
you know,
my mother was young and so like growing up or like a,
uh,
a young mother that doesn't necessarily know what the fuck is going on really
makes you realize at a young age like,
Oh
shit,
it makes you start looking at everything a little differently.
He doesn't know what's going on.
She,
I don't think she can make eggs.
She
okay with that.
But they're both in his fucking crazy thing together.
Shit.
And you know,
you realize like kind of early on knows the fuck.
That's crazy.
I can't imagine being,
I can't imagine that my biggest hiccup in life was getting into stand up because
my,
I just that,
that I didn't,
I didn't have any humility at that time of my life and my dad gave me a speech
on my 26th birthday that was like fucking aggressive,
like [inaudible] like 20 seconds.
The 20th.
It was all my birthday.
Like he called me and I thought he's going to wish me happy birthday.
And he was like,
you're a fucking loser.
Oh my God.
He's like,
you make me embarrassed.
I'm embarrassed it.
You're my son.
I lie about you.
Oh my God,
he's,
do you know what that's like to love private type?
Judge heard your son got his life's option by rob Oliver stone and he's in New
York and standardize.
He doing here's I lied in fucking court.
He goes,
it makes me sick to my stomach.
I was like,
what can I do different?
And he goes,
nothing.
I was like,
well,
can I fix this?
And he goes,
I know I failed you as a father.
And I,
it it me to like,
it changed my life.
Like I went,
he taught me how to get taught me how to be humble enough to get a job in stand
up.
So you just needed to work the door.
But I thought I was above that.
I thought that I was better than that.
Like I thought that someone would just grabbed me and put me on stage and I'd be
discovered.
That's how I thought it happened.
I know you could literally be humble and say,
I want to do this.
How do I go about doing this?
Please help me test someone.
And he got me into it and literally fucking started doing it the next night and
six months later I had a deal and it was like I was a fucking,
one of the greatest things I ever did.
I look back at that.
So family,
there's times me like outside,
this is every single night hanging outside.
Jim Norton,
Bobby Kelly,
Patrice O'neil,
Collin like [inaudible] quaint.
Actually he did.
I didn't,
I've never actually met him until recently.
Just throw him in
because I,
I started getting into a tough crowd mentality.
I started looking at the credits.
I'm tough crowd.
I was like me,
Bobby Kelly,
like [inaudible].
I'm honest.
I'd never,
I'd never met Nikki there.
So No,
I mean I've seen them come,
I worked the door when he'd come in and do the club,
but I never liked it.
There's ECM onstage,
there's fucking next brotherly love.
Nick Depaulo to me is one of the most underrated comedians in this kind of hands
down.
No questions asked.
He's the Kinda guy.
You can tell his jokes to your friend at a bar and a fucking lose their mind.
He had a joke about her.
Do you remember when Katrina hit do is?
It's so cruel.
It was so,
it was so fucked up.
But he goes,
yeah,
they were.
They were writing rescue of rescue,
rescue signs on the row,
on the roof.
But I'm not sure
doing this any justice.
I was like,
there's no way I'll get through it.
It was signing a rescue.
Uh,
you know,
signs on the roof,
but there were misspellings them instead of help.
But said Hap once.
I'm happy.
The trick,
that fucking water,
if you want some hap drink that water,
Nick Depaulo I'm not,
I'm sorry nick.
I butchered your joke.
I apologize.
I wish I knew his joke about,
uh,
he goes,
ah,
Guy,
I'm not going to do this.
Ain't justice either.
They a lot of bills.
I,
they haven't said the n word.
A lot of people say that rarely.
I guess you'd never put $1,000 on a playoff game.
I knew I ruined that bit,
but no,
no,
no fucking good.
Nickname follows is one of the funniest.
I watched naughty,
naughty,
naughty and
I watched Nordion rd and nick
on uh,
on,
on the fucking,
uh,
it's same thing Dan.
Patrick shows on,
I want to watch it because I respect both of those guys so much that I go,
it's not the best shows sometimes,
but this is what I,
what I
think that show would be fucking magic if it was uncensored and to take nick and
rd and put them on regular radio.
It's like taking Joey Diaz and make him instead of talk.
Write with a Crayon.
Yeah,
it's nonsense.
It's fucking stupid.
I watch it all the time though.
Cause it's like I love nick and Arnie.
Someone with some fucking balls.
Please take that show,
put it on the Internet.
You'd make more money than if you want people listening and you could still
put it on direct TV or whatever the fuck you're putting it on.
It's still would be,
but leave.
Let Nick Be Nick.
Let rd already let him be crazy.
Let him let him talk.
Complete
unhindered.
The way he,
what did I,
we were talking,
I was talking to someone recently about bomb lines and Nixon,
BombBomb lines I go to when you,
when you're doing bad in the hecklers attacking you and you have your comeback
and Nick Depaulo has a time.
I've once again a butchering whatever this story is because I don't remember it,
but nick said that he was getting heckled by this girl and it was her
bachelorette party and he was on the road and some podunk town and he was like,
he was like,
ma'am,
I hope the next time you reach under your armpit you feel a lump.
And he goes,
I've never had an entire crowd hate me more.
And they had to escort him to the green room,
but he's a fucking old school,
like old school.
Kind of like,
that's the kind of dad I want to meet dads at like my kid's school.
And I wonder if they knew who the fuck I am.
Like then,
then they,
then they do know who I am.
They figure out who I am,
they'll Google me and they'll go,
oh shit,
I didn't know you were this guy can be this guy around you.
Like I want to know.
I said,
I wonder if like parents,
cause he's got kids.
If they meet him and they have no clue of who he is and then like Google him and
then they're like,
oh my God,
I can tell this joke in front of you.
He's one of the funniest fucking human beings,
man.
I really,
very nice guy.
Did you ever do tough crowd?
Tough crowd was a definitive show on my life.
Yeah.
I would just have my first daughter show.
I've been doing the road and I would,
and I knew a lot of those guys,
most of those guys from doing stand up comedy or tragedy that chose cancel,
but it's so silly bullshit.
Like,
like why would you ever,
I mean it's such an easy resource,
you know,
it was easy to get comedians.
Everybody wanted to be on it.
It was very entertaining.
Well you got to talking to him and it's pretty much a podcast.
It was a limited
like time,
a time limited podcast.
This,
listen man,
we're so lucky that we are existing in this time where you can do this thing
where you could do whatever the fuck you want.
No one's telling us what to do.
We're doing whenever we want.
We decided to keep going.
We did.
We decided to end the podcast,
take a leak and keep going.
There's no producers don't.
That's the of the beauty of
situation.
This is when Greg Giraldo fucking dentist's,
sorry,
hit pause for a second.
Brian.
This is Dwayne or keeping my money story because Geraldo never even went to the
nuclear weapons,
which is plagiarism.
He never even went to that.
You know,
he never even went to that,
but leary was so conti with them.
Like right off the bat.
Greg Geraldo was a fucking beautiful dude.
He was just the nicest fucking guy.
He was very intelligent in a time where in my life when no one needed to be nice
to me.
There were two people that were distinctly nice to me and,
and,
and gentle.
And that was bill burr and Greg Geraldo,
like,
you know,
Norton and Bobby and all those guys were always nice to me but men good Gerardo
and bill Burke took time,
pulled me aside and like,
they were fucking great guys.
I remember one time calling into my buddy cow head show,
uh,
and,
and because Geraldo was on and calling in to listen to your elders interview,
cause I just loved Greg and cow had told him and dread goes,
I'll put them on the phone and talk to him.
And I talked to Greg for like fucking 10 minutes in between a break in a song
and just was like,
man,
how,
how's everything going?
And he's like,
well,
it was a very sincere fucking fucking great guy.
He had a show,
I don't remember what network it was on,
but it was,
uh,
it was his sitcom.
It was on during when yours was right.
Yeah.
He talked about partying with the girl that was on your show.
Which one?
Uh,
the girl with big tits.
Who on newsradio girls are they tense?
Didn't that one girl with big tits?
No,
not who is the girl?
There was beautiful girls,
but I always thought why?
Yeah,
I was actually a big data.
Have they?
I thought her tits were so big they had to tape them on.
Maura was the white girl with black hair.
Yeah,
she was though.
That's a release.
Listen nickels,
terrible misunderstanding.
She was beautiful.
Known that she's very beautiful and incredibly townhome.
Fucking want to try the white wine with her so bad.
I did a scene with her once,
I'll never forget this and I told her and she just sort of laughed it off cause
she's,
she's like really like you.
She wasn't,
she would never like brag about her talent like as an actor.
And she was good,
but we did a scene together and um,
I didn't realize that she was acting.
I thought she was saying something to me and I was like,
oh,
that's the words.
Oh whoa.
I go,
Holy Shit.
You bad ass bitch.
I go,
I didn't know you were acting like you just fucking rocked me.
Like she blocked me with what you were saying because the set of news radio was
very loose,
there was a lot of fucking off and there was also a lot of improvisation where
it's like Dave Foley was responsible for a huge amount of like what got on the
air or that show because it's sort of like,
he was like sort of like almost like a secret producer and it was because of the
guys who wrote the show were like,
they were so open minded and so smart and Paul Simms,
who is the executive producer was just,
it's really brilliant guy who recognized that there was a lot of people like n d
or like Phil Hartman or like Dave Foley or whatever who would have this
intuition while they were on stage working out the scenes that they would come
up with new things and to incorporate those new things.
So Dave was like constantly tweaking things and adding things and it was,
you know,
and being able to watch that and to watch someone do that and to be in that
situation,
I was like,
wow.
I'm like,
this is,
this is like an ideal situation.
Uh,
I was the is um,
this is gonna Sound Conti Conti but weird.
But uh,
so like last year was a very good year for me and,
and I'm also in the middle of our,
our school,
so we're like,
our kids are in third grade and like now we've been at school long enough,
they kind of bored and we know all the parents.
And so like I was this like a,
I was the resident famous comedian parent.
Like,
oh,
he's a comedian.
I think Dave Foley's kids go to our school now and Dave folded.
They were like,
have you heard Dave Foley?
He's spoken to PTA money apparently is fucking amazing dad.
Like I'm either that or it's a guy that looks like Dave Foley.
What do you mean these amazing dad?
Like he like he shows up and does all the shifts and they were like,
and I don't go to anything.
I don't even go to recitals.
Like I just fucking,
he's a very solid dude.
That was a great set.
But what I'm saying about Morris,
she did,
she was built,
oh yeah.
She's very pretty beautiful woman.
She didn't have big knocker.
She was fucking hot as shit.
Yeah.
She's very bright.
But yeah,
but Greg Giraldo across from you guys and you guys just to party,
right?
And Well Greg was right next
store and um,
he was,
there's a lot of guys who had TV shows.
There was a lot of guys who like got gigs back in those days.
It's like they got a development deal and maybe they had a few episodes.
Like my friend Tom Rhodes,
he had a show for us.
Why can love Tom Rhodes a good dude?
He's a great dude.
And um,
I met Tom.
The first time I met him was,
we were both on NBC.
I was on news radio and he had his own show and then he went over to Amsterdam
and it's just,
he's Tom's beautiful,
he's fucking awesome.
But he never lost his shit,
you know,
he was,
he's always been cool.
He's always been like that.
The night I met,
he's a,
he's a Tom Rhodes.
It's like,
in my opinion,
like a fucking ledge yet.
Canadian
Tom Rhodes is from Florida.
And uh,
I've told him the story a number of times and he never really remembers it,
but we ran into each other.
And Amsterdam,
we did that show time special with Russell Peters.
And I said,
uh,
the fucking first night I met him,
I was working in the Boston comedy club.
I came downstairs and he was at the bar and I knew he was from Florida and I was
from Florida.
And I like to stand up.
And I walked up to him and I was like,
I was like,
hey man,
I'm,
my name is Bert.
I'm a comedian.
I just started,
I'd love to ask you.
And he stopped me,
like put his hand on my chest is handled.
Manchester was like,
listen,
you start buying beers,
I'll answer every question you want.
And I was like,
all right.
So I started,
I put my fucking Dad's credit card down and I fucking bug beers and talk to them
about comedy for like three hours.
It was fucking great.
He was,
well,
the one dude's that did,
uh,
the icehouse chronicles and we had a long conversation afterwards when I was
with you.
Yeah.
He was like the comradery.
So cool.
Here it's like we have like real comedian comradery.
He was hammered and I said,
yeah,
I was with the two.
I think I was with the two I was with.
I had a guy with me to drive me and I,
I was like,
Tom,
let us take you to your,
cause he was hammered.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we were trying to tell them there's no way you're drunk.
And he was like,
ah,
don't worry about me.
I sleep in the car.
I wake up and I go,
yeah,
he passed.
He slept in his car.
Do you do that?
That's illegal if he's sleeping.
Yes.
Yeah.
I just had a simulation thing happened to me.
Joe,
I uh,
that,
that Denis leary video that we were talking about last night,
I watched this movie called happy,
which is all about depression and stuff like that.
It's a documentary on Netflix.
I recommend.
It's all right.
But there was a guy in the movie that was like a motivational to kids
and I was like,
who is this guy?
It's the guy on the right,
right there.
I've never seen this guy.
Never in my life.
Yeah.
And now he's in his,
he's going to be on the podcast.
Let me tell you something.
The second time I ever did stand up for money,
I opened for Lenny Clarke.
I used to say it was the first time,
but that's a lie,
ladies and gentlemen.
The first time I opened up a guy named more McDonald's,
that's the first time I ever got paid.
But the second time I ever got paid,
the truth is I opened up for Lenny Clarke and I was in a place called js and
Pittsfield,
Massachusetts and Lenny.
Um,
he's always been like super cool to me.
He's like,
look how fat Greg Looks.
Does it look real fast?
Well,
considering like comparing now Brian.
Wow.
Oh,
Brian,
where you saw that a bit.
At least you know that Greg would have been going into hives.
A horrible joke.
Yeah.
The big guy,
by the way.
Uh,
Lenny has lost a shitload of weight.
Yeah.
Lenny is really thin now back,
wait,
is this serious?
In that documentary he was pulling out towels because he wouldn't stop sweating
and I was telling,
I was talking to the girl was with last night and it's like,
isn't that crazy?
He's just standing there talking to kids and he can't stop sweating.
There's like sweat all over his body and documentary.
It's called happy.
And I just saw it last night.
I never seen this guy before my life and I just pull up this video and he's in
this video.
It's so fucking simple.
Where's the part where Greg and we call fight.
We did that movie together.
I'm,
here comes the boom,
the Kevin James [inaudible] and Lenny Clarke was in that movie because it was
shot in Boston and Lenny played a local Boston guy,
Lenny Clarke.
I fucking love that guy.
But he's,
you lost a lot of weight man.
He lost a ton of what he looks great.
I mean,
he's like really lean.
He doesn't ever,
I've got it all.
Is this where [inaudible] it's,
it's,
it's about the time,
I think right here.
Gotcha.
Well,
you got to tell you what happened.
The left,
Denis leary gets mad.
They'd,
Greg Geraldo has prepared material.
It's really hilarious.
And that's how he found out where they were buried.
The ball.
Yeah.
During the Dukes of Hazzard.
I don't know.
Someone should like find this off air and figure it out because it's a really,
there might be they're asking for is a non violent way to solve a problem with
the country that we hate that Dustin's got weapons pointed at?
I don't think so.
No,
you're right.
Like Russia for example,
that big Russian war.
There are things that,
there are things that
Denis Leary's upset.
What about
it?
But there are approach to their economic benefits that we're giving them in
order to put them to stop developing their with him.
I heard recently they agreed to stop that stop building nuke if American women
agree to get their nails done at least twice a week.
But I ran the good boy.
You can't write so many jokes before the show was not a report.
It's unbelievable.
He's got to,
he's got a pocket full of yeah.
Don't know,
I'll have it was Mike,
that that's kind of what we do here.
Identify with a comedy writer.
You're a guy who did all the homework and then after three weeks any more that
needed to be done.
That's a good point.
And if you would try a little comedy writing,
have you show and still be on the air,
hey [inaudible] hey,
tell me all the time
you just crushed him Pumpkin,
you know,
but that's okay.
Thing that happens when dudes get famous.
I think you guy can come along and clown.
Yeah,
dude,
tell me about,
it's a first time I went on the road and I realized there are killers that I've
never heard of.
No,
please.
When a guy gets famous to a point where you're,
uh,
Tom Cruise or any,
any,
any sort of a person's been in movies.
Yeah.
Dennis leary,
when that came out,
had been in a ton of movies.
He'd been in some really high profile movies.
Mean he thought of himself as a guy who had made it.
So I think he probably assumed he was going to get a certain level of respect.
Sure.
You did a little writing.
Your show would still be on the air.
That was like a nuclear weapon that he didn't see common.
He didn't see that to help me at all.
He got detonated.
What's great about [inaudible] is that you,
oh bro,
that was hubris.
You look at the look on Geraldo's face and you can see his eyes twitching and
you can see him go angry going uh,
three,
two,
I got this,
I got this.
And then like making is make it as tactical call in his head.
You could see that happening almost.
It's a superior mind.
Yeah.
It's superior mind.
Just not as famous but a superior product.
Like what he would,
he would put out his points of view.
It'd be superior.
I'll watch this.
I got to get the idea that there would be like something funny and saying that
someone prepared the Glucodin me for Pitta bully.
Well that's the idea.
That is ridiculous.
Like that's so crazy.
Like,
oh look at the painter.
He went and painted like,
what the fuck?
Well,
it's,
it's uh,
there's a,
there's a certain personality that,
and I,
I'm not gonna speak,
I don't know,
I'm not saying this is Dennis leary,
but there is a certain personality that's so arrogant in that the way I say it
will be so much better than the way you say it.
As opposed to what I say is better than what you say.
So like,
Hey,
like you could hear the statement before him when he says,
well,
we're going to go to war with a country like the,
it was very arrogant and he was like,
yeah,
like that great Russian war.
Like,
yes,
that does fucking work.
You're not listening to the words you're,
you're,
you're overlooking the thought.
Well,
he has this idea that somehow or another he's going to be able to solve what
hundreds of scholars and heads of states and yeah,
diplomats and emissary workers and no,
no one can solve.
No one can solve it.
He's going to come along and tell you exactly how things need to be blunt.
It's,
is it co the,
the ideas of first of all,
communication between nations where they don't even speak the same fucking
language.
Yeah.
Difficult.
That shit is,
it's so fucking hard just to understand things and cultural context and explain
those different people that are in your country that you're sort of representing
because Koreans are not like Americans and Americans and all I Koreans and
people that live in North Korea do not understand how we're living in North
America.
And the people in North America for the most part really are fairly ignorant
about what the fuck is going on in North Korea.
And one of the big reasons is because we can't fuck them communicate with each
other.
But if we could communicate with each other,
if everybody in Korean in North Korea knew how to speak English and they all
could read the shit on the Internet about how the world is run and what the fuck
is really going on in the country and how the rest of the world views things,
they would probably slowly but surely take action.
But the fact that there's separate from the rest of the world.
In fact they speak this one very unique sort of a language.
It's difficult to learn and isn't translatable very easily to English or Spanish
or
it's Korean,
not translatable is difficult.
See that symbol,
you know the,
the,
this,
the way things are written and everything are good friends are Korean and that
when you go to,
we went to a Korean barbecue,
mind saves Roy Choi.
He's the guy that started the Taco truck.
The concept of the TACO truck.
It's him.
He started,
it started,
he was the first guy.
But the premise of these formation,
these gourmet taco trucks,
he's Asian.
Yeah.
Roy Choi.
He does.
He's good friends with Bordain.
Asians don't give a fuck dude.
They get things done.
They get things done,
don't they?
They really get the thug.
They fucking get things done.
They really do.
They're the fucking future of America.
When you eat,
how the fuck did they ever figure out how to get,
I don't even know what you've said yet.
Full of full
like strangle hold on the manufacturer of like electronic parts and TV's and lab
cars.
Cars,
cars are over there now,
Lou and they're to wear in Detroit.
No one's doing cars in Detroit.
Well isn't Chrysler still in Detroit and listen forward?
No,
but no one's in Detroit.
Detroit's apparently in peril because everyone took their business to Asia.
Why?
It's more?
Is it more,
is it more a,
an idiocracy not idiocracy a theocracy.
Not The ocracy,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Any audience.
See is that,
what do you,
what are you trying to like where it's like the idea of the state is better than
the person.
So everyone looks up to the state and it's something like that where they care
about their job.
Like Americans just don't care.
Well,
you know what happened is first of all the cars they made sucked that,
that hat
in American.
Yeah,
this something happened.
We have to figure out,
there's a part where we got really lazy.
What the fuck went wrong from like 1973 to four
tempo 90 fucking yeah,
for tempo was a fucking was a,
that was a phone in job by the Americans.
Like that's that car sat.
It sucked Dick in 1989 Ford tempo demos
for Tampa.
What the fuck happened to the Mustang?
Okay cause [inaudible] 82 months.
It was great.
And say this,
I can say this,
I have a Mustang today.
I have a Shelby gt 500 I fucking love it.
Okay.
But that's a 2010 and between like 1965 and 1972 or 73 they had some dope
fucking car.
Really liked to 69 but then something happened and like the 70s and the 80s like
you call that up fucking Mustang.
What are you a communist?
What did,
what are terrorist infiltrate the fucking the four plants and hold down the
designers by gunpoint and gay up all the drawings.
I go,
Huh,
fuck do you call that [inaudible] gave them I spell gay g,
h e y
or none gave them Joe homosexuals like,
like,
cause I wonder if it was a,
it had to do with homosexuality in the,
and the fear of homophobia and they took all these great gay designers that were
super closeted in the fifties and then got,
and then like there was this manliness and they disappeared.
Are you trying to say that Dick Suck designed the corvette?
No,
there's no way you can tell me as a man,
what is sexy without knowing sexy as a man.
What the fuck are you talking about Pete Townsend Corps vet is the sexiest car
you can put me in.
Is it really fun?
I just drove one from Miami to Marco Island and I tell you right now,
the second I sat in that seat,
I would let the steering a bit close to my face because I wanted it there.
It was just fucking,
it was a god and the car was a corvette,
a brand new brand new 3000 miles convertible.
Two new ones.
Was it a four 26 I have no,
I have no idea.
For 26 is they have the zero six [inaudible] zero six engine and suspension and
a convertible.
So fucking hot.
Like I just felt coolest shit in that car.
It's not a corvette,
Brian.
That's God damn Miata and it's pink.
How dare you?
How dare you hate America on this podcast?
Hating on my rock.
I got poop.
Well,
why don't you go poop,
man.
We'll wait.
Oh,
hold on.
Yeah.
What time is your raw comedy show tonight,
Brian?
And can kind of,
can we guide people in your general direction?
I'm just going to try to get up somewhere now.
When you do that,
what do you do?
You just show up and say and try to sneak my way in.
Hey,
my name's Brian Red Band and you might know me on Twitter.
Is that what you're doing?
Yeah.
Why don't you,
uh,
start a start up a room your own Brian.
Huh?
I did.
I have like three rooms,
so yeah.
Do you think ever will be all contained under one roof?
Do you think that ever the full death squat family will have podcast studios in
one gigantic warehouses?
Cause that's what I'm seeing.
I'm seeing we also duplicate this at the onset compound and Texas.
Why don't,
why not Austin
a thousands of acres.
We're our own lake plus deer to shoot.
How do we get it?
How do we get our power?
Bitch,
did I say what?
What?
Maybe we can have our own fucking satellite.
Okay.
How do we get,
how do we get like a death squad like studio in a warehouse where we can make TV
shows.
I don't want to make it a CV.
So why not?
Why not?
I don't usually match.
I'm bad.
It just needs to be an umbrella.
Listen,
if I make a TV show,
here's my next TV show.
I'm going to play pool around.
Boring,
boring.
Some few bitch slap.
99% of the show is,
we are very close to a sign.
I can't say with WHO.
[inaudible] there's a,
there's a show that is a,
um,
uh,
a lot of it is based in the podcast.
What are you doing?
Taking text message?
Because no,
come on them live on the air.
This person said that they got a new phone number.
They're like,
sorry,
I got a new phone number and I thought they were lying.
But now they're sending me pictures of this.
Is that,
is that,
who is that?
Is that Kadafi?
Yeah.
All right.
So might be not the person,
I'm thinking of you getting someone sending you murdered people and what's,
what's,
what's that,
what's the new TV show you doing?
Oh,
it's uh,
it's based a lot of it on his,
like controversial subjects in a lot of it.
It'll be big.
It'll all of it.
We'll start off from the podcast,
like examining all sorts of different wood.
There's no tenant,
well,
we sorta have a tentative title,
but I'm not necessarily happy with it.
So the idea is that like the way we've done the podcast,
where we explore all these different ideas,
whether it's,
uh,
shamanism or ghosts or big foot or Ufo Ios or fringe topics,
crop circles,
reincarnation,
psychics,
and we're gonna,
um,
talk about it on the podcast.
Like,
I'll have a guy like you or Ari or Dunkin or Jolie or any comedian come on and
we'll say,
you know what?
It's like,
we'll do it right now.
What do you think about big foot,
do you think?
Do you think that is possible?
There could be an undiscovered primate that people have been talking about
reporting for ages and it's somehow or another alluded photography except for a
few really questionable photos and some really fucking shitty video that looks
fake as fuck.
Put all that aside.
Pull the hoaxes aside.
Do you think it's possible?
I think it's possible.
100% why do you think?
Cause I believe,
whoa.
Yeah.
I believe,
well I believe at lochness monster.
I believe in Tuba.
Calm.
You can fly.
Do I believe I can fly?
Yeah.
Kelly pee on you.
If you were a 14 year old girl and you didn't know why you were there in the
first place,
I definitely believe that I have the capability to fly in my body.
I just haven't figured it out and once we do tap into that,
we'll be able to fly.
But like Bill Hicks,
she used to say start on the ground floor.
Right.
Had a great joke about a young man who I'd asked it thought he could fly lept to
his death.
What a tragedy it goes.
What an idiot because he can fly.
Why did you start off from the ground go?
You feel like that?
I remember when Star Wars,
Star wars return of the Jedi came out.
No,
no,
no.
A empire strikes back came out.
I remember watching Luke move with his mind
and I remember being in the back of my car trying to do that hard as fuck.
Like staring at objects.
Go and like try to make sure it flies where dogs.
I was like,
that seems logical.
Well there's certain aspects of life that seems so preposterous.
Unrealistic electricity.
What the fuck is that?
It just hits you.
Have you seen those Tesla and like experiments where he's like touching
electricity and it was like a Bolton's flying big Tesla coil and is connected to
his arm.
Hold on.
Have you seen as photos?
Did Tesla just,
have you seen the new Tesla fucking car?
Did you see them all explode when hurricane sandy hit the beach in a,
in New Jersey?
What?
Yeah.
There was a whole warehouse that had like this.
Uh,
they were uh,
they had a dock and they had all these new uh,
Karmas that's what it was.
The Fisker Karma was the Tesla.
Oh that as well.
The grant.
It's looks gorgeous.
There's quite a few really?
Yeah.
Beautiful Electric cars right now.
But the Fisker Karma is the one and they have like 16 of them I think exploded
on the,
on the docs because they had them on the docks and the water came up on the
water,
hit these fucking
electric cars.
They just [inaudible] just fucking blew up.
And everybody was like,
Oh okay.
Shit.
We,
I don't think they knew that would happen with Amazon.
You drive over fucking standing water.
What have you driving home from a flood?
Is Your fucking car explode?
Okay.
Cause I can deal with my car shorting out.
It's you sitting there scared.
If I can save like two bucks a gallon,
but my car explodes when I hit a puddle.
Is that going to happen?
Is that what the fuck is really going on?
That doesn't look that Tesla looks bad.
His Shit.
We've one,
uh,
it was either murdered,
murdered motor trend or road and track car of the year.
One of those big magazines made it the car,
the or the uh,
Tesla,
not the roadster but the larger car.
Something that something asks,
it's like a four door and uh,
apparently it's just a marvel of engineering,
but
the real problem is going to be a row state taxes on roads.
The roads are going to shit
problems.
Then another problem is the fact that everybody wants to pretend that buying
some sort of an electric car removes you from the fossil fuel food chain.
Yeah.
But it doesn't.
No.
And in fact it connects you with some even shady or minerals on like a really
large scale like lithium ion and all those different minerals.
A lot of those or conflict minerals,
they come from the Congo that come from Afghanistan.
They come from like,
if I was Brian Count,
I'd say I've got to Stan [inaudible].
If I was a amber Lyon,
I'd say,
uh,
was that she was fine
brain please not in the bottom lane lane.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
you know,
these,
these minerals that you need to create a lithium ion battery.
By the way,
Matt Loves Brian Callan and mad love to Amber Lyon,
which is fucking with him
minerals that you need to batteries.
They come
from like really fucking imprisoned in poverished areas.
Their conflict minerals,
lithium ion is officially liquor conflict mineral,
like a lot of shit that you need to even make cell phones if it's like,
I think the vice had a guide they had,
they did a,
a vice guide to travel episode where Shane Smith went to the Congo and they
were,
I don't know why they're not troubled channels.
One of them would love to see one of their fucking shows because it's too deep.
They go to the same shit.
Bordain does.
No,
they go way further than [inaudible] further,
they sent him in close.
It's not even close.
We're vice vice goes to the fucking Congo deep,
deep,
deep and talks to warlords.
Really?
Do they go looking for dinosaurs?
Yeah,
I would,
I'd love to see that.
I could put that on.
Why not?
We enjoy watching her on the Internet.
Why can't [inaudible] your correct.
However,
most people that run these organizations,
whether it's a network or you know,
you know,
cable or,
or whether it was broadcast television,
they,
they're very conservative because they're trying to sell advertising space.
So when a,
when a company like vice comes along and they have,
and there were literally in there,
they have no respect for any corporation at all because they'll do what the puck
they need to do to make what they think of videos where Hamilton Morris goes
into the jungle and he's taken Chris Drugs and a lie back.
And you know,
I mean,
it's like they're not going to sell tide during those times.
You know,
they're going to have to accept that they're not going sell time.
But they do see that's what's really stupid.
It's like there's this weird sort of game that we play.
Whereas we pretend that the people that see all the fucked up things that you
can find on the Internet are not the same people that wash our clothes.
Yeah.
That washed their clothes or wash my clothes by gas or you know,
any of the variables and the things where we try to target people.
We're all,
we're all the same fucking people,
man.
The [inaudible],
we just have access to different shit now.
We need to accept that.
You need to just stop pretending that we're living in some sort of a Catholic
school.
You know,
Sandra Bullock movie view of the world.
But it's not,
that's not reality.
Reality is there's a lot of fucked up shit about out there and I can find it
now.
I can find it on the Internet.
It's really easy.
So you need to sort of adjust your expectations accordingly because there's a
lot of evidence,
a lot of evidence that shows that reality.
It's pretty fucking slippery.
Yeah.
There's a lot of nutty shit out there,
but that tells the car looks bad is fuck yeah,
but it will explode if he hit a puddle.
What a horrible feeling.
They look dope.
I liked the,
uh,
that's the four 26 at one that Brian just put up.
I see.
Uh,
the new corvette convertible that's got a 505 horsepower,
the last,
um,
version of this,
uh,
this engine,
I think it's called the ls one,
but it's a,
might be wrong,
but it's a huge fucking power and torque that's also in the [inaudible] the same
engine.
They supercharge it and the Zr one,
it produces 648 horsepower.
Like this is like
for people who like talk about like muscle cars.
This is like the greatest era of a muscle cars in the history of the fucking
world.
No one.
Yeah.
The muscle cars that people are creating now actually can take turns and they
actually have good brakes.
Like there's a Shelby Mustang they have now that's unbelievable.
The regular,
but they have the three Oh two boss Mustang that's like,
you know,
it's like,
they're like moderately powered.
It has 440 fucking horsepower.
It's unbelievably powerful.
Well,
what's the,
is it the Dodge Dodge Challenger challenger?
Yeah.
We went to muscle car though.
Then we went to drive,
um,
uh,
Lamborghini's and Ferrari's and Porsche's on a track for trip flip.
And the dude's just wanted to drive the dodge challenger.
They would take you out for a ride and they were like,
this is more fun for us to drive.
Why is that?
I have no fucking idea.
But they did everything.
They do the,
the,
the burnouts where they spin in circles.
It's just more fun.
Like those things.
I,
you know,
I think like,
I definitely have driven a ton of those,
uh,
Lamborghini type cars.
Those things are fun as fuck,
but it is a different drive than like,
it is really,
you don't feel as loose maybe as you do as a doll.
It's challenger like,
and it does challenge you.
You're fucking sliding and your if it's feeling it.
Yeah.
Well they have a,
they,
they have a broad sort of a um,
uh,
you could pick from like a lower horsepower engine to like a really ridiculous
engine.
Those things.
Yeah.
You could like ramp it up and there's a lot of people take those cars and they
ramped them up even more.
Like the Hennessy Hennessy makes like a 700 [inaudible]
horsepower to love windows.
I love when you get like those special edition cars.
Yeah,
possible what they are though.
Like the muscle cars of old,
those things.
You couldn't take corners in them like this.
These are completely different animals.
But the challenger is still like a muscle car.
Whereas like the Camaro has become almost like a sports car because they handle
so well.
It might've been,
it might've been a Camaro they were driving now that I'm thinking about it,
but like we were taking corners in the lamb,
Lamborghini,
I like 90 miles an hour taking corners fucking and say,
yeah,
you can do ridiculous shit with sports cars.
I drove,
I flew to Italy for a day to drive a Ferrari down the coast.
Yeah.
Like I had to fly to drive a fly.
I think I texted you about it.
Yeah.
Which one did you drive?
Uh,
I have no fucking clue,
but it was,
I just drove down the coast and I had to chase car in front of me and tests car
behind me.
They just taped it and I just fucking Fillioux.
It was so much fun.
Like those paddle blah blah blah blah.
Just finalizing.
Yeah,
those paddle shifts.
There's a lot of people are upset about that shit though.
A lot of people think that a real sports car,
you should shift it manually and that just because it's quicker to shifted with
the paddles,
like you're missing out on part of the experience
kind of agreement because I like shifting my own gears.
I just too fun about it.
I do too,
but there's so many people that probably have never learned how to do that.
They can't learn on a Ferrari and I'm sure it's just a sales thing because the
paddle shifters are
much easier.
Yeah.
Um,
way,
ways here,
but it's not as satisfying.
It's not,
it's not that it's hard to shift your own gears,
but there's something that's like mechanically engaging about putting a clutch
in slide in the shifter for letting the clutch out,
he and the gas the same time.
There's something super sexy.
When you met a girl that knew how to drive a stick and you were like,
yeah,
like,
you got it.
You're a good dad.
Especially if it was like a fucking Mustang or something crazy.
This dirty pitches of it driving a big fat VA,
boom,
Whoa,
whoa.
She wants to drive.
When you go to the movies and you got to say no,
and you've got to not let her be on top of the first time we fuck either.
It's very important and establish dominance immediately.
Bert Kreischer,
you've got to grab that bitch and let her know the feeling of gravity and the
density of the bones in your hips.
You know what I'm saying?
Brian?
Hollaback.
Ooh,
so Bert Kreischer,
how much time you spend on the road?
Lately I'm fucking Dick load.
I bought on the road every week.
I feel like I'm home two days this week.
I'm going to take a leak.
Talk to Brian about it.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is in the podcast.
It's been four hours.
Five minutes by Brian.
I'll tell you a story.
All right.
Tell me a story,
sweetie.
Okay.
Um,
do you wanna hear the story that I had?
Uh,
gonna make it.
Oh,
okay.
I'll tell you a good story.
Story,
story.
And this is the reason no one would listen to the Brian and Bert podcasts
because I find you funny too often.
Oh,
thank you.
I find you funny all the time.
No,
no.
But we like,
like I listened to the podcast and when I hear you say things that fucking fit
maybe stopped Joe or like dice,
like you said,
like two or three things that made me laugh so hard during the dice podcast.
I'm smoking in the studio right now.
Like a bad boy.
What's in that room right there?
That's a,
behind me is just an empty room.
There's a lot of empty rooms here at the studio,
so I'll tell you this story.
Okay,
Brian.
All right.
Um,
so I checked into,
I did Columbus and then I did right after that I did at Kentucky,
right.
Checked into the Kentucky Hotel.
Uh,
the hotel in Kentucky and I have four backs.
I've shirts,
I've shirts for two weeks.
So I four bags a bellman takes my bags,
take some,
I have to take it,
let him take it in my rooms.
You know,
he's going to get a tip.
We go on the elevator,
he asks what I do.
I said,
I'm a comic.
We get out and second our door opens,
another door opens and it's a,
uh,
it's a older white dude and he walks out like three steps mindless and he
follows me down the hallway,
three steps behind us,
all the way,
all the way until we get to the end of the room,
the hall where my door is.
And I'm like,
is he going to my room?
It turns out he's in the room directly next to mine.
So as he goes to open the door and like,
like put his key in,
I jokingly in front of this bellman thinking,
he laugh.
I go,
hey man,
if you want,
we can open up that center door and hang out all weekend.
And the guy now is like nervous and not in these trying to get his key.
And he's like,
no,
I don't.
I don't want to do that.
And I go,
well,
it could be cool.
We'd like get to know each other.
Yes.
I said this to this guy just fucking around him to kiss you or something.
Just fucking ready.
Ever even bring that up.
I'm just fucking around.
Just fucking around as a comic.
Should do.
All right,
but what did he said?
Yes.
Uh,
I don't think you will.
He's an older man,
but what if he did?
He's an older man.
No,
no.
Listen,
I'll tell you.
Let me tell you.
Let me,
I'll tell you the story.
So I get,
I,
I checked into the Kentucky and I go to do the Kentucky and proper,
uh,
whatever it in Louisville,
and I have four bags with me and the bellman takes my bags up the elevator for
me and I've got on them.
No,
it's not at all.
It's really,
it's one of the funnier things I've done in the winter.
Music to the back of it.
Yeah.
A it up with this.
This is a strong enough story to close the podcast.
Might be,
you might pull up roadkill,
ghost choir,
beggars guild,
and we're going to play that in the background.
Come on sweetie.
Let me design this thing.
I know what I'm doing.
Trust me.
Oh,
did you pull up Miss d?
You can't kiss me.
You got to stop that.
You know we're playing that out.
We already did that today with Brad Pitt.
Steven doorways,
the roadkill
ghost choir and the song is beggars guild.
We need to get a desk,
quad iTunes account.
Don't worry.
You just order things online.
You know we need real internet.
Hi.
Hi Real Internet.
Hang out.
Death Squad.
Yeah.
Okay,
we'll do it.
We can do one this week though.
We want to do Fridays then we could do Fridays.
There were Callan Fridays.
Yeah,
cause I have the ice house.
Okay.
Beautiful.
All right.
Now Bert Kreischer.
What were you trying to tell us?
To Christ?
Who are you telling me,
buddy?
What were you telling me?
You're in Columbus,
Ohio.
Fuck.
Neck,
neck.
I just invented it so I never heard it myself.
Probably the wrong song for this,
but it's a perfect time.
So tell me what happened.
A little,
a little volume please.
Yeah,
a little more volume.
So I check into the Kentucky Improv and a black dude checks in my bags.
He grabs her bags,
puts him on the trail trailer thing,
brings me to the elevator.
I gotta let him take it to the room.
He's earned his tip,
right?
Right,
right.
So we take them up to my room.
He says,
what do you do?
I said,
I'm a comedian.
He goes,
okay.
And we don't talk.
After that door's open,
take an elevator door,
open the doors next to us in the elevator next to us to open and an older white
dude walks out and follows us.
Any ghosts?
US down like the whole hallway.
Everywhere we go,
he follows us.
He's going wherever the fuck we're going to get all the way down on the end of
the hallway.
How far away is he walking behind?
Three feet behind us.
The whole time we smack them on the fucker unconscious.
It's awkward.
It's awkward,
and we're both know.
Didn't confront him.
You were all noticing it.
So we get to the last door and I'm thinking,
is this guy going to my room?
I would assume that guy's trying to do something bad kids on this.
Something really wrong going on.
But I would think no.
What would you do?
Overdo it.
What would the last thing you would do,
Joe?
Listen.
The point.
Here's what,
first of
all,
when someone is mirroring you like that three,
there'd being very disrespectful because they're not,
they're not just not just following you,
they're letting you know they're following you and they're doing it in a very
arrogant way,
or they're being flirty.
Well,
they could be.
That's what happened.
Be psychotics.
Here's what happens.
What would you do?
Meet up immediately.
I would ask them what the is going on.
Watch what he does.
It turns out he's in the room next to me.
So he was going to his room.
So as he goes,
well,
you lost that was drunk.
Oh,
see you're paranoid.
Nobody was thinking about it.
We scared about life.
I have a lot.
I was thinking about black,
I knew I was a comic and I wanted him to news know that I knew Kevin Hart cause
that's what I thought he was going to save you.
No,
no.
Hold on.
And so the guy,
the old guy goes to open his door and I jokingly now told the black,
I'm a comic but I haven't done anything funny.
So I jokingly look at the old guy and I go,
hey,
if you want,
we can open up that connecting door and we can hang out all weekend.
So wait,
it gets better.
It gets better price to the guys name
can't get his,
cause he's known,
panicked him and he can't get his door open.
And he goes,
no,
I don't want that happen.
And I go,
no,
it'd be cool man.
We'll open it up.
We'll hang out with like the darkness and just talk to each other at night.
And he can't get his door open and finally gets his door open and he goes,
I don't want that to happen.
The door opens and before we can close it,
I stick my head in and I go,
hey man,
if you change your mind,
knock and scratch.
Sure.
So he goes down,
no,
and he shuts the door and he's fucking panicked.
And I looked to the black guy,
the black guy is gone.
He's in my room.
Okay.
So I go,
fuck.
I did that joke for nothing.
So I go into the room and the black guys putting the bags down and he gets done
all the bags and I go to take,
you might want to get ready to cue the music.
Brian,
he,
I go to give them a tip and the black guy looks at me and shakes
does that.
And he goes,
no.
I said,
well,
I gotta give you a tip.
Maybe took my bags up here.
He,
no,
just knocking scratch.
So I look at the black guy,
go,
okay.
So I knock and I scratch the guy to the route goes
apart laughing.
He's on the ground.
Like,
so the guy in an extra room called downstairs and,
no,
no.
The Black Guy,
the guy who I told the joke for in the first place heard the whole thing and he
goes,
no man,
don't do it.
You got knock on scratch.
So I knocked and scratched and the fucking guys,
I don't want to hang out,
man.
Bert Kreischer that's rude.
Oh,
it was fucking the funniest.
Getting better die with a lot of insecurity in your fucking with his head.
Funniest thing I've ever done.
I the belts kind of bullyish.
He's so bad for that poor dude scare to Dickson his ass so bad the whole
weekend.
I kept talking loud as fuck in my room.
Just going.
I know he's listening to me.
Why don't you just knock on the door and say,
hey man,
I'm a comedian.
I'm really sorry it was,
it was past that.
It was past that.
It's past that.
Oh,
so you had to just like fucking just
burn all the evidence.
Bob Flame thrower.
You just had a Vegan shoot rockets from helicopters.
Is this incredible whole community is the end.
This is the n I can bug him.
I could do my
friend Ben.
Well.
Thank you very much Debra.
Crisis One,
Ohio.
You Sir are a bad mother.
Fucker has such a great time today,
man.
You're welcome.
Anytime my friend,
if there's anything we could do to help you in any way,
shape or form,
you've done everything you could imagine my vodka company,
what would it starts?
Well,
not us know Bert Kreischer.
We will launch that bitch machine vodka.
She's been emotionally you gentlemen,
machine vodka just became an official sponsor of the joy of the screens.
Podcasts.
They have one year free sponsorship.
We will talk about machine vodka for one year,
absolutely zero money and you will buy it all up and Bert Kreischer.
We'll have a helicopter and a place on a volcano in Hawaii so I can fly to our
Texas compound with our high water crisis,
going to buy pants and Mckenna's house on the big island and converted into a
Bikini factory
where the hottest girls in the world will make $1,000 an hour and they'll make
bikinis and leaving Easter will be one of my models.
Exactly.
With Rachael Ray,
les Miserables roles.
We'll play in the background until everyone becomes a sex slave.
Zombie robot control afternoon to talking.
Yeah,
it was beautiful,
man.
This is what we should do all the time.
Let's do this once a week.
You are the reason I have a podcast.
I'm grateful.
Fucking bays in the podcast is successful or how I know how to get a cup
podcast.
We are all together in this crazy soup of life.
Bert Kreischer,
I am as happy for you as you are for me.
We are both together.
Very fortunate along with Jamie,
the new guy along with
have you said anything?
Jamie?
Shout up.
It's not ready yet.
He's not ready to go through an apprenticeship.
You need to see success and failure.
Just dislike puzzles.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the end of the commercial free podcast here at the Joe Rogan experience.
What?
What can you do to give thanks.
Wait,
can you do incorporate all the messages of the Bert Kreischer,
Bert,
Bert pod test into your life,
bitches,
bird cast,
baby.
Check it out.
The Burt cast at Bert Bert,
bert.com you can find all the information.
Incorporate those lessons of your life.
A don't be.
It can be.
Look in the mirror.
See,
get Josh Shit to Kevin Pictures.
I can show shit together.
We love you,
but first you must love yourself in order for you to love yourself.
You must respect yourself in order for you to respect yourself.
You need to get your shit together,
bitch.
Give yourself advice.
Pretend you are an outside and objective observer of your own existence.
And what kind of advice would you give yourself to get your shit together?
And why won't you follow that Shit Yourself?
Stop for attendance.
You can't bullshit a bullshitter.
Socket that squad 2013 bitches.
We're here.
Fuck a Mayan raise.
Odin son.
Praise Odin bitches.
Oh,
Adam knows what the fuck is up.
We can go to [inaudible] dot ting.com and say 50 bucks goblets Jihad.
[inaudible] [inaudible].